ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIED NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN. BENNETT BERMAN. BIGELOW
BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH BONTA.
BRIAN BURKE. CALDERON CARRILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU. CHEN CHIU. CHOI
COOLEY. COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY. DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN. GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GONZALEZ
GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN. IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA. KILEY
LACKEY. LEAD LEVINE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN.
O'DONNELL PATTERSON.
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK. QUIRK
SILVA. RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO
SMITH. STONE TíNH. BELLA THERE
IS V. APPROVED WHAT. VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD. WEBER WICKS. WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR SO WE MAY.
CONTINUE THE BUSINESS. ON THIS
LAST DAY OF SESSION. PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD. TODAY
BEING THE LAST SESSION OF THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY TODAY
WE REFLECT. THAT WE WERE SWORN
IN DURING THE PEAK OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE'VE ALL
WITNESSED HOW IT HAS AFFECTED
THE LIVES OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE LOST THEIR
LOVED ONES. WE'VE ALSO
EXPERIENCED WILDFIRES THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES AND BUSINESSES IN THESE
FIRES. WHEN WE REFLECT ON THESE
THINGS WE'RE REMINDED OF THE
PAIN THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE EXPERIENCED.
WE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THEY HAVE
SHOWN THEIR HERO ISM AND
SELFLESSNESS BY RISKING THEIR
LIVES BY BEING IN THE FRONT
LINES. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
COMMUNITY BASED FOOD BANKS THAT
HAVE PROVIDED FOOD TO THOSE
THAT NEED IT THE MOST. ALONG
WITH SO MANY MORE AMAZING
NONPROFITS THAT HAVE PROVIDED
MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE. AND
SOCIAL SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATION. AND SO MUCH MORE.
OUR TEACHERS. THAT HAVE WORKED
SO HARD TO EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN.
HOW MUDDY GUARD. WE ARE PROUD
OF ALL OUR HEROES. THAT DESPITE
GOING THROUGH WHAT THEY WERE
GOING TO BE CELLS. THEY DREW
THE STRENGTH TO SERVE OTHERS.
WE AS ASSEMBLYMEMBERS HAD
SITUATIONS WHERE WE DIDN'T SEE
EYE TO ALL RIGHT AND HAD
DISAGREEMENTS. ALLOW US TO MOVE
PAST THOSE EXPERIENCES AND
ALLOW US TO SEE EACH OTHER AS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
HUMANITY. AND ALSO AS
CALIFORNIANS THAT LOVE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE.
FORGIVE OUR SHORTCOMINGS AND
BLESS US WITH MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE AND MAKE
THIS WORLD A BETTER PLACE AND
UPCOMING YEAR OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I MEAN. THANK YOU MOM YES
SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER. YOUR HAND OVER
YOUR HEART AS WE HONOR OUR
GREAT FLAG OF THIS NATION.
READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
SERVER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ASSEMBLY MET ANTHONY ON THE
ALL REBEKAH BACKING INSISTENCE
BECAUSE REPORT USING THE
PRESIDING CHIEF VIRTUE PROGRAM
AT THIS PARTICULAR DAVID BOWMAN
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL
SCHOOLS RARE S. MOVES AND-
MISTER FLORA SECONDS. THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATION TEMPTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS. OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE- GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE- TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
MS RAY YES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AGGREY FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER AND GIPSON TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA.
THE FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB THREE
SIXTY SIX RUBIO TODAY UPON CALL
OF THE CHAIR AND ROOM FOR TWO-
TO. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY
EIGHT TO REMOVE ITEMS EIGHTY
FIFTY EIGHT THROUGH EIGHTY
SIXTY INCLUSIVE FROM THE
INACTIVE PHYLUM REFERRED THESE
BILLS TO BUDGET COMMITTEE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SEVEN ALSO PURSUAN TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SEVEN. I
FURTHER REQUEST THAT ITEMS
THIRTY FIVE THROUGH THIRTY NINE
INCLUSIVE. ALSO BE RE REFER TO
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE MOE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ITEM EIGHTEEN SB TWO
NINETY NINE LEYVA. ITEM TWO
FIFTY FIVE SB FIVE SIX TWO
PORTANTINO. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MEMBERS WE ARE. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND RATING COVERAGE SENATE
BILL EIGHTY. ALL BILLS ALREADY
IN RED. AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO THE. SENATE THIRD READING
FILE. WE'RE OING TO BEGIN
BUSINESS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. BEGINNING WITH
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN WE'RE GOING
TO START. WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN. THIS IS SB. SEVEN
FIFTEEN AND THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN BY
SERVER PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
TACKLING THE CRIMINAL LAW MR
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS IT MAKES CHANGES TO MY
LAST YEAR'S BILL RELATED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL INVESTIGATING
INCIDENTS OF DEADLY SOURCE BY
UNARMED CIVILIANS AND CLARIFIES
THAT THE AG CAN INVESTIGATE THE
SHOOTINGS OF THE DEATH OF AN
UNARMED CIVILIAN. IF THERE'S A
RESULT DISPUTE WHETHER THE
CIVILIAN WAS ARMED OR UNARMED.
SECONDLY THIS BILL UPDATES AND
REQUIRES SOME LAWS RELATED TO
TRANSFER OF FIREARMS IN
CALIFORNIA RELATE TO DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. THIS ISSUE LAST TWO
YEARS AGO WE KNEW ABOUT WHEN A
NINETEEN YEAR OLD A LEGALLY
PURCHASED. A SEMI ATTIC
CENTERFIRE RIFLE FROM A DEALER
AND OPENED FIRE AT A SYNAGOGUE
IN POWAY THERE WAS A LOOPHOLE-
THE GUN STORE FAILED TO CHECK
THE ADEQUATE VALIDITY OF THE
HUNTING LICENSE ANDTHE DOJ
CLEARED THE BACKGROUND CHECK-
INAPPROPRIATELY SO THIS WOULD I
RECTIFY THAT SITUATION AND
BRING ABOUT A SMART GUN LAW
CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
REGARDING. SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CARCLUB THE
ROLE. THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. IT.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE.
TELEVOTE ICE FORTY THREE NO
SIXTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SENATE BILL
EIGHT OH FIVE. CORKERY SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH FIVE BY SENATOR
RUBIO AND OTHER SNACK- IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT MISS CLARK
SILVA. GOOD MORNING MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY AS A CHAIR OF
THE ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT
COMMITTEE I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
S. B. EIGHT ZERO FIVE THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
ASSISTANCE TO OUR SMALL
NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
COMPANIES BY ESTABLISHING THE
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT.
PERFORMING ARTS PAYMASTER UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL SB
EIGHT OH FIVE WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED LOW COST PAYROLL AND
PAYMASTER SERVICES TO SMALL
NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED DEVASTATION DREAM
DRAWING QUOTE COVERT NINETEEN.
THESE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
SUPPORT YOUTH SERVE AS
INCUBATORS FOR ARTISTS REYES
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND WELL
BEING AND BRING NEEDED DOLLARS
INTO OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA. THE SCENE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLUB THE
ROLE. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIME ICE
FIFTY ONE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON. FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN WE ARE ALSO GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEMS.
SEVENTEEN WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
THE FILE ITEM. NINETEEN THIS IS
FILE ITEM. NINETEEN CORRECTION
MEMBERS THAT'S A PASS
TEMPORARILY WILL TAKE THAT UP
LATER TODAY. WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM TWENTY. FILE ITEM. TWENTY
THIS IS SENATE BILL. THREE
FIFTY FOUR. AND THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
OTHERS NAPOLI THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES THIS RUBIO YOUR MAIL
BUT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
THREE FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER WHICH HELPS CHILDREN BE
HOUSED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS AND
ADDS SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE SUCH
PLACEMENTS DO NOT ENDANGER THE
CHILD CHILDREN DO BETTER WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS BUT CURRENT
RULES PREVENT SOME FROM EVEN
FROM EVER HAVING THE
POSSIBILITY OF FOSTERING A
RELATIVE. CHILD SOLELY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A CRIMINAL RECORD
CURRENT RULES APPLY EVEN IF THE
CURRENT ONE CRIMINAL RECORD IF
DECADES PAST OR WOULD HAVE NO
IMPACT ON THE SAFETY OF THE
CHILD SIMPLY PUT SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR WILL HELP KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER MEMBERS THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THIS REVIEW.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS OF. WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE ROLL AND
TIE THE KNOT EYES FORTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO. TAKE
THIS PARA QUE HANDS ITEM THIS
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY SEVEN. COOKERY
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS
NOT HAVING THE CRIMES THIS
PACKAGE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR WIENER'S REPRESENTS
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH REPEALS PROVISIONS OF THE
LAW THAT CRIMINALIZED LOITERING
WITH THE INTENT TO ENGAGE IN
SEX WORK. THE LEGISLATION ALSO
PERMITS THE SEALING OF RECORDS
FOR ANYONE PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED
OF THIS BOY DURING OFFENSE AND
PROVIDES RESENTENCING FOR
ANYONE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
FOR THE OFFENSE. SINCE ITS
ENACTMENT IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE THIS MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE
HAS FAILED TO PROTECT PUBLIC%
SAFETY AND UNSURPRISINGLY WE
SEE IT DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTING BLACK AND BROWN
TRANSGENDER WOMEN. DUE TO THE
BROAD NATURE OF THE OFFENSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS LICENSE TO
PROFILE PEOPLE AND STOP THEM
PRINT HURRIEDLY DISCRIMINATORY
REASONS SUCH AS WEARING
REVEALING CLOTHING WHILE
TALKING TO PEOPLE IN AREA WHERE
SEX WORK HAS OCCURRED IN THE
PAST. REVITALIZING PEOPLE FROM
LOITERING SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES THE MISTRUST THAT WE
DISCUSS OFTEN BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TARGETED
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS
DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE IT DESTROYS THE
RELATIONSHIP. AND MEANS PEOPLE
WILL NOT ENGAGE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN THEY NEED IT.
THE LOITERING OFFENSE IN FACT
CREATES UNSAFE ENVIRONMENTS
WHERE SEXUAL EXPLOITATION CAN
OCCUR. I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
I HAVE DONE WORK TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND BELIEVE
DEEPLY THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN ON THIS FOR TO
COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND TO
HOLD TRAFFICKERS ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS LOITERING LAW IS NOT THE
WAY TO DO THAT. CRIMINALIZING
THE VICTIMS AND LEAVING THEM
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS THE
CREATE FURTHER BARRIERS TO
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND
RELIEF IS NOT THE ANSWER.
LEADING TRAUMA INFORMED AN ANTI
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
COALITION TO ABOLISH SEX
TRAFFICKING OR CAST. ASIAN
PACIFIC- ISLANDER LEGAL OUT
REGION JUSTICE AT LAST I
UNDERSTAND THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS ARE
HARMED. BY THIS LOITERING LAW
WHICH IS WHY THEY STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN
INNER DRIVE VOTE TODAY. TO BE
CLEAR NOTHING IN THIS BILL
DECRIMINALIZE SOLICIT TATIAN OR
ENGAGING IN PROSTITUTION OR SEX
WORK. UNDER THE BILL'S SEX WORK
REMAINS ILLEGAL AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN CONTINUE TO
APPREHEND THOSE ENGAGED IN THAT
ACTIVITY. FURTHERMORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN CONTINUE
APPROACHING MAKE CONTACT WITH
PEOPLE THEY BELIEVE ARE VICTIMS
OF TRAFFICKING TO OFFER THEIR
HELP. SEX TRAFFICKING
SOLICITATION AND PROSTITUTION
AGAIN WILL REMAIN ILLEGAL SB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN SIMPLY
ELIMINATES ANY ENTRY WATERING
OFFENSE THE RESULT IN THE LEGAL
HARASSMENT OF LGBTQ PLUS BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES. FOR
SIMPLY EXISTING AND LOOKING
LIKE A SEX WORKER TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER K. HIM MISTER
MURATSUCHI. YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIVE SEVEN.
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR. WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN OFFENSES
THAT THE- THAT- DON'T ALLOW
BETTER TO AMBIGUOUS TO ALLOW
FOR ABUSE. AS ARE CALLING FOR
MARANDA JUST STATED. WE HAVE
THE TOOLS IN THE PENAL CODE. TO
CONTINUE TO PROSECUTE FOR
SOLICITATION FOR. THE ACT OF
PROSTITUTION NOTHING IN THIS
BILL UNDERMINES THAT THIS
SIMPLY ELIMINATES. THIS VAGUE
PROVISION IN THE PENAL CODE
THAT ALLOWS FOR ABUSES FOR
PEOPLE THAT. MAY SIMPLY BE
PROFILED FOR THE WRONG REASONS
AND FOR THAT RATE REASON- I
RISE IN SUPPORT AND I URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT SB THREE
FIVE SEVEN. MISS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIVE SEVEN. AND ONE EXPLAIN WHY
THIS POLICY SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS LEADING ANTI
TRAFFICKING SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND LGBTQ ORGANIZATIONS. THESE
PROSECUTORS SERVICE PROVIDERS
AN LGBTQ LGBTQ GROUPS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE
RELYING ON BOTH PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS NATIONAL
AND WORLDWIDE RESEARCH
UNDERSTAND THAT CRIMINALIZING
SEX WORK AND THOSE BEING
TRAFFICKED. FOR LOITERING DOES
NOT HELP THOSE IN NEED. INSTEAD
THE ENFORCEMENT OF THIS OFFENSE
IS INCREDIBLY HARMFUL TO WOMEN
ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF COLOR AND
OUR TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY. WHO
ARE BEING DISPROPORTIONATELY
TARGETED BY THESE POLICIES AND
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
ARRESTING SOMEONE ARE
THREATENING TO ARREST THEM. AS
MEANS TO HELP THEM IS NOT A
TRAUMA INFORMED OR RECOMMENDED
WAY THE LEADING- ANTI
TRAFFICKING SERVICES SERVICERS
RECOMMEND. AND ORGANIZATIONS
SUCH AS CAST THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM AROUND HAD MENTIONED AND
JUST AS THE LAST DO NOT
RECOMMEND THIS IS A WAY TO
HELP. THOSE THAT ARE SEX
TRAFFICKED CAST IS THE LARGEST
HUMAN. TRAFFICKING GROUP- IN
THE ENTIRE NATION AND A
SERVICING ARRESTING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDSOF PEOPLE FROM SEX
TRAFFICKING THEY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ARE
CONFIDENT THAT IT WILL. HELP
NOT HARM THOSE BEING SEX
TRAFFICKED WE SHOULD LISTEN TO
THEM WE SHOULD LISTEN TO OUR
FORMER PROSECUTORS HERE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. I THINK
MANY OF US WOULD DESCRIBE HIM
AS SORT OF A LAW AND ORDER
DEMOCRAT IN THE FACT THAT HE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I THINK
SAYS A LOT ABOUT THE STRENGTH
OF THIS BILL AND THE FACT THAT
THE AUTHOR. HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY TO CREATE
SMART PUBLIC POLICY THAT HELPS
WOMEN HELPS OUR TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AS
WICKS MR KALRA. URANUS THANK
YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN AS A FORMER
PUBLIC DEFENDER WHO DID
REPRESENT ALL THE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS OF
SEX TRAFFICKING THAT RECORD UP
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM-
AND YOU KNOW SOME OF SAID THAT.
POLICE WON'T BE ABLE TO HELP OR
OR APPROACH PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING TRAFFICKED WHO WHO OR WHO
ARE SELLING SEX BY CHOICE OF
THIS BILL IS PASSED. AND THAT
SIMPLY IS NOT TRUE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN HELP PEOPLE
WITHOUT THREATENING TO ARREST
THEM IT HAPPENS EVERY DAY
FRANKLY SHOULD HAPPEN MORE
OFTEN AND THERE ARE BETTER WAYS
TO HELPING WITHOUT FEAR AND
INTIMIDATION THE ONLY TOOL YOU
GIVE SOMEONE A HAMMER THAT
EVERY PROBLEM LOOKS LIKE A NAIL
SUMMARILY. THE ONLY TOOL WE
GIVE GIVE IS OF ONE OF OUR REST
THE ARREST IS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AND THAT LEADS TO SO
MANY OTHER ISSUES AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM OTHER COLLEAGUES AS
WELL. THE MOST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH TO HELP THIS
POPULATION DO NOT INVOLVE
ARREST FOR EXAMPLE ANTI
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS
ALREADY DO A REACHES SEX
WORKERS AND THOSE BEING
TRAFFICKED OF THEIR APPROACH OF
OFFERING A HELPING HAND A MEAL
A COUNSELOR AND ESPECIALLY A
SAFE PLACE TO SLEEP IS MORE
EFFECTIVE AND TRAUMA INFORMED
EVEN EMERGENCY ROOM STAFF HOTEL
EMPLOYEES IN TRANSIT EMPLOYEES.
ARE TRAINED TO WATCH OUT FOR
PERSONS BEING TRAFFICKED AND
INTERVENE APPROPRIATELY THIS IS
MORE EFFECTIVE THAN A REST WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT SEE SOMEONE IN
DANGER OR DISTRESS THEY CAN
OFFER TO HELP THEY CAN
INTERVENE OR THEY CAN SUMMON
SOCIAL SERVICES OR COMMUNITY
BASED GROUPS WHO CAN HELP. US
FOR MINORS POLICE RETAIN THE
POWER TO ASSIST ANY MINOR
DANGER OR TO DETAIN THEM UNTIL
SOCIAL SERVICESARRIVE SB THREE
FIFTY SEVEN DOESN'T INTERFERE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY
TO HELP OR APPROACH PEOPLE
CONVICTION RECORDS ARE NOT
HELPING THREATEN PEOPLE WITH
THE TRAUMA OF ARREST AND
INCARCERATION IS NOT HELPING.
VOTING FOR THIS BILL WILL
ACTUALLY BE HELPFUL THAT IS WHY
SPONSORED BY TRANSIT TRANS
BEING A COALITION STRANGER
JAMES INFIRMARY. AND OTHER
GROUPS LIKE THIS IS MY
COLLEAGUES MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
TO AN- EXPLOITATIVE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME I BY. THANK
YOU KALRA VALID YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RESPECTFULLY AND I
TO THIS BILL MEMBERS I HOPE
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
HUMAN SEX TRAFFICKING OR MODERN
DAY SLAVERY NEEDS TO BE
ELIMINATED IT HAS NO PLACE IN A
MODERN NATION IT IS SHAMEFUL
THAT IT STILL EXISTS. THE STATE
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO THREE OF THE TOP OF THE TOP
TEN CITIES. MOST KNOWN FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
DIEGO. ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WORK HARD TO HELP
IDENTIFY AND RESCUE VICTIMS OF
THIS HORRIFIC PRACTICE AND
ARREST THOSE WHO TRAFFIC THESE
VICTIMS. SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN
WILL UNDERMINE THE ABILITY OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
INVESTIGATE HUMAN SEX
TRAFFICKING AND BRING SEX
TRAFFICKERS TO JUSTICE. I HAVE
FRIENDS THAT HAVE BEEN ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE. BUT IF
I HAD TO ARREST AND HAD TO
INTERVENE AND GIRLS TRAFFICKED
AT TWELVE YEARS OF AGE. AND
IT'S A CYCLE OF ABUSE AND BEING
ABLE TO SEPARATE THAT SOME OF
THESE GIRLS LITTLE GIRLS IS
VITAL AND ENDING THE CYCLE OF
ABUSE THAT IS HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO UNDERMINE
THAT. WE NEED TO BE GIVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT MORE TOOLS TO STOP
HUMAN TRAFFICKING NOT LAST. WE
NEED TO WORK THROUGH THIS BODY
AND HELPING. WOMEN AND GIRLS
THAT ARE BEING TRAFFICKED THIS
BILL DOES NOT DO THAT WE NEED
TO BE WORKING ON BILLS AND
POLICY THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER THIS DOES NOT
DO THAT IN FACT IT'S GOING TO
ENDANGER MORE LIVES. OF GIRLS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. I STRONGLY
URGE FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IF YOU LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE DEBATE PLEASE RAISE
YOUR MICROPHONES AT THIS TIME.
MR SAY ARE TELL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THIS DOES NOT MAKE
COMMUNITIES SAFER FOR ONE WHO
HAS WORKED A LONG TIME IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE AFFECTED
WITH THIS. I CAN TELL YOU THAT
IT IS NOT VERY HARD. TO SEE
WHERE THESE PEOPLE ARE ARE
HANGING OUT ON THE CORNERS AND
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE APPROACH.
POLICE ARE TRYING TO REMOVE
THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY FROM
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THESE
COMMUNITIES AND THE FAMILIES
THAT LIVE THERE. DO NOT WANT TO
BE SUBJECTED TO THIS OR HAVE
THEIR KIDS SUBJECTED TO HAVING
TO WALK THROUGH THESE AREAS ANY
MORE THAN ANY OTHER FAMILY IN
ANY OTHER COMMUNITY. SO THIS
ALSO TAKES ANOTHER TOOL AWAY
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT TO TRY TO
HELP DEAL WITH THIS. THE SEX
TRAFFICKING ISSUE HAS BEEN
CLEARLY- TALKED ABOUT BY
SEVERAL MEMBERS IN HERE AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CLARITA.
AND THEN IT IS THAT'S TRUE THE
POLICE HAVE VERY FEW TOOLS TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE SOMEBODY OUT.
OF THE SYSTEM TO FIND OUT
WHETHER THEY DO WANT HELP OR
NOT. AND IF THEY DON'T WANT
HELP THEY'RE NOT GOING TO STAY
IN JAIL THEY GET RELEASED WE
DON'T EVEN PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL
THAT STILL NINE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DOLLARS WORTH OF
MERCHANDISE THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
NOT JAILING PROSTITUTES
ANYMORE. SO THERE ARE THERE IS
A PLETHORA REASONS FOR NOT
DOING THIS BUT THE PRIMARY ONE
IS IT DOES NOT MAKE COMMUNITIES
SAFER. IT DOES NOT. SO WE NEED
TO STOP THIS THIS TREND OF
TAKING AWAY THE TOOLS THAT ARE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS NEED
TO CLEAN UP OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IT WE CAN ACTUALLY WE CAN
HELP THESE PEOPLE IF WE CAN
IDENTIFY THEM. PEOPLE THAT ARE
NOT ENGAGED IN THIS ARE NOT
BEING HARASSED. I DID NOT SEE
ANY OF THAT IN THE CITIES THAT
I WORKED IN AND BELIEVE ME. IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE WORKING OR
SERVING THOSE COMMUNITIES YOU
BETTER KNOW WHAT THOSE FOLKS
WANT IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD THAT BEFORE
I'VE HEARD ALL WHERE YOU DON'T
REALLY KNOW OF BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE WANT. YOU KNOW WHAT
BALONEY. I WORKED WITH THOSE
PEOPLE I WENT TO THERE. ARE YOU
KNOW I HELP THOSE PEOPLE ALL
THE TIME THEY WANT THE SAME
THING EVERYBODY WHAT ELSE ONCE
THEY WANT A SAFE CLEAN
COMMUNITY. AND THEY NEED HELP
DOING THAT AND THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE HELPING THEM TO THE
OFFICERS.SO WE NEED TO STOP
TAKING TOOLS AWAY. AND DIED IN
THIS THIS BILL JUST DOES THAT.
SO YOU KNOW I OF I URGE YOU TO
VOTE OF VOTE NO ON THIS. AND I
CONTINUE TO ALLOW OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO BE SAFER
COMMUNITIES AND ALLOW POLICE
OFFICERS TO DO THEIR JOBS THANK
YOU. MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS NINE I MEAN NOT
TO- INSULT YOUR INTELLIGENCE
BUT I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO JUST
READ TO YOU AND REMIND YOU SOME
OF THE GROUPS THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND I
THINK IT'S SELF EXPLANATORY
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THANK YOU.
BAY AREA ANTI TRAFFICKING
COALITION. BEACONS FOR VICTIMS.
CAPITAL RESEARCH INSTITUTE
CHILD AND ADULT SEX TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING. CONCERNED WOMEN
FOR AMERICA FREED COLLECTIVE.
NATIONAL CENTER ON SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION. RESTORATION RANCH
A WOMEN'S SHELTER. AND THE ONLY
INTERNATIONAL JUST TO NAME A
FEW I THINK THOSE ARE VERY SELF
EXPLANATORY THAT OF THESE ARE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COMMITTED
THEIR LIVES TO TRY TO PROTECT.
THESEVICTIMS WERE IN THE
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION OF
CIRCUMSTANCE. MY SEATMATE
KNIVES VISITED AN AREA IT'S A
BRAND NEW GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COMMITTED THEIR LIVES TO A
REHABILITATING THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN CAUGHT IN
THE CYCLE OF ABUSE AND IT'S
REPREHENSIBLE AND THEY REMINDED
US OF THE DANGERS AND THEIR
CONCERNS FOR THIS BILL AND ITS
PASSAGE SO PLEASE PLEASE.
LISTEN TO THE VOICES OF THOSE
WHO ARE TRAPPED OR HAVE BEEN
TRAPPED IN THIS VERY UGLY CYCLE
THEY DESERVE BETTER THANK YOU.%
AND MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
AS A CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LGBT LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM A
NUMBER OF OUR COLLEAGUES- WHO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES WITH BEING
MORE INSIDE OF LAW AND ORDER
AND THAT'S SOME OF THE SPACE
THAT I AM VERY PROUD OF AS
WELL. BERMAN THE PERSPECTIVE OF
OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY. SIMPLY
BEING TARGETED FOR THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF POTENTIALLY
SOLICITING OR THE APPEARANCE OF
SO. THAT'S IN WHICH THERE'S
BEEN ABUSES IN THIS PENAL CODE.
AND WE THINK ABOUT THE
LEGISLATION AT HAND PRINCIPALLY
IT'S TAKING A SURGICAL APPROACH
AT RECTIFYING THE INJUSTICES
SPECIFICALLY TOWARDS TRANS
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. AND WE THINK ABOUT THE
PERSPECTIVE OF OUR COMMUNITY I
ASKED YOU FOR EMPATHY AND
SAYING THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
THE TOOLS ON ITS BOOKS ALL. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE RECTIFY
THE INJUSTICES SO AGAIN AS A
PROUD MEMBER OF OUR LGBT
COMMUNITY I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND YOUR EMPATHY AT
TAKING A LOOK AT THIS. BILL AS
IT SURGICALLY RECTIFY THE
INJUSTICE IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR LOW MEMBERS IF YOU LIKE
TO PARTICIPATE DEBATE FRAZIER
MICROPHONES RIGHT NOW PLEASE.
MISTER COOPER YOUR RECORD LAST
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
COMES A MISDEMEANOR THE SAME IS
A BROKEN WINDOW OR DO A LOT ON
JOB IMPACTS MUCH MORE PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT THIS. TO TALK ABOUT
AFTER LAW HUMAN TRAFFICKING
REFERENCES ON THIS A LOT OF
JUVENILES ARE USED IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE KNOW THAT LOVE
ORGANIZATIONS OUT THERE SO THIS
BODY THIS LEGISLATURE HERE
PASSED THE BILL A FEW YEARS
BACK WHERE YOU CANNOT DETAIN A
JUVENILE SUSPECTED HUMAN. BEING
INVOLVED IN PROSTITUTION WE'VE
BEEN THAT SO YOU CAN'T STOP
SOMEBODY FOR THAT YOU ALSO CAN
INTERVIEW A MINOR. SO HOW DO
YOU RESCUE A MINOR. AS BEING
HUMAN TRAFFICKED. IF YOU CAN'T
DETAIN THEM. THAT WAS PASSED
HERE YOU CAN'T INTERVIEW THEM
THAT WAS PASSED HERE TO SAY THE
FROM THE PEP. SO LONG AS YOUNG
GIRL BEFORE BEFORE YOU EVEN
HEARD THE TERM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS A LOT OF BLACK
AND BROWN GIRLS EVER BEING
VICTIMIZED BY GANGS CRIMINAL
STREET GANGS AND OUT YOU KNOW
IN THE YEAR SINCE THIS TOOK OFF
IN THE TRAFFICKING TAKEN A BIG
THING THAT THAT THAT'S THAT'S
REAL TALK I DON'T HAVE A DOG IN
THIS FIGHT BUT- I SEE IT OUT
THERE ARRESTED PEOPLE FOR THIS.
AND WHEN SOMEONE'S LOOKING OUT
TO YOU SEE THAT A LOT OF TIME
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT ROCKET
SCIENCE. MAYBE THERE'S SOME
DISCRIMINATION CASES I'M NOT
BECAUSE THERE AREN'T BUT FOR
THE MOST PART YOU'RE OUT THERE
DRIVING AROUND YOU KNOW. WHO'S
OUT THERE WORKING WHO'S NOT
WORKING THE SPECIAL THEIR RISK
OF CERTAIN AREAS THAT'S THAT'S
HOW IT IS BUT- THE PART ABOUT
IT IS THOSE YOUNG GIRLS OUT
THERE. LIKE I SAID. WHAT DO WE
DO THAT DO WE DEAL WITH THAT. I
MEAN IF YOU WANT TO. JUST TO
CRIMINALIZE PROSTITUTION. THEY
MAKE A SIMPLE AND SIMPLE IS
REALLY WANT TO DO THAT THIS IS
WHAT IS DONE YOU TALK ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TOOLBOX. IF SOMEONE
CAN HERE CAN TELL ME RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU'LL MINOR THAT IS OUT
THERE AND PEOPLE USE MATTERS A
LOT. HOW DOES LAW ENFORCEMENT
TACKLE THAT. BECAUSE THE WAY
THE LAWS ARE WRITTEN IN THE
LAWS OF IMPASSE THERE THERE
REALLY IS NO WAY TO TACKLE AND
DEAL WITH IT. I'M I'M BEING
HONEST WITH YOU. I BUILT A
SENIOR PERSONALLY WE SEE ON A
DAILY BASIS. SOME OF YOU
ANOTHER DAY FOR THE OTHER THE
VAN OUT THERE DOING ID THE
DOCUMENT TRAFFICKING. DURING
COVERT IS BLOWN UP HUMAN
TRAFFICKING- CHILDREN BEING
ABUSED ON THE INTERNET INTERNET
CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN. YOU
KNOW THAT THEY GET FORTY SIX IN
OUR CASE THE YEAR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THEY GET TIPS ON
THEY CAN'T RESPOND ALL THOSE
TIPS. AND LOVABLE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SO. I SCRATCH MY
HEAD IS HOW DO WE DEAL WITH IT
YEAH SOUNDS GOOD PEOPLE SHOULD
BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BUT
NOT IN ALL CASES THE LAW CASES.
WRITTEN A CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOOD
AND YOU'RE DRESSED LIKE THAT
GOT A PERSONAL CONDOMS AND
STUFF. IT'S JUST CERTAIN THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT YOU DO WITH IT
DAY IN AND DAY OUT. AND YOU
KNOW WHO THE PLAYERS ARE WHO
THEY ARE LIKE I SAID IF WE
REALLY WANT TO HELP MINERS YOU
TALK ABOUT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THAT'S IT IT BY THE WAY IN
CALIFORNIA. RIGHT NOW TODAY
PRISON DAY. HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OF MINOR TO PEOPLE KID. IS NOT
CONSIDERED A VIOLENT FELONIES
FEW PICK A KID GUESS WHAT.
BECAUSE THE CALIFORNIA'S LAWS.
YOU GET RELEASED EARLY FROM
PRISON. WHICH IS ALSO LAST
NIGHT. YOU KNOW I HAVE BEEN SO
MUCH MONEY GOES THAT WE WILL
WE'RE ALWAYS BANKING ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT IF WE'RE GONNA
BANG ON THAT. LET'S NOT JUST
TALK THE TALK LET'S WALK THE
WALK AND HELP. A LITTLE BILLS
LIKE I SAID YOU CAN'T INTERVIEW
MINOR. YOU CAN'T ATTAIN A MINOR
FOR PROSTITUTION LOT OF MINOR
SO YOU CAN LOOK. THEY GIVE THE
FINGERS WALKOFF THEY'VE BEEN
TOLD BY THEIR PARENTS. WE CAN'T
TALK TO YOU. DON'T TALK THE
COPTIC NOR THE COPS. THEY TELL
THEM THAT'S WAS BETTER OFF
YOU'RE BETTER OFF HAVING MINORS
BECAUSE YOU CAN DETAIN ADULT
MUCH SIMPLER. THE NEW CANAAN
WHINER SO- THIS BILL IS THE
COOKED A WHILE WELL INTENTIONED
IT'S A LONG WAYS TO GO SOURCE
IF WE ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS.
MISTER PATTERSON. THANK YOU
SPEAKER MEMBERS OUT. I RISE UP
ASKING YOU TO. THINK SERIOUSLY
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
AND I WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS- WITH THE- MY FRIEND
FROM SACRAMENTO AREA AND HIS
EXPERIENCE BUT LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT WE DO IN FRESNO. WE HAVE A
ROBUST. CONNECTION WITH MANY
SEX TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT HAVE SAFE HOUSES AND
RELATIONSHIPS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND IT IS TOOLS
LIKE THIS. THAT ALLOW OUR
POLICE. TO SEPARATE. THE VICTIM
ON THE STREET. WITH THE
PAMPHLETS DOWN THE BLOCK AND
AROUND THE CORNER. AND WHEN WE
SEPARATE. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
JAIL. THEY'RE GOING TO A SAFE
HOUSE. THEY'RE GOING TO A PLACE
THAT CARES FOR THEM. M. THOSE
RESCUES. ARE SO OFTEN TIMES
FACILITATED. BECAUSE THERE ARE.
ASSESSES AND LAWS. THAT CAN BE
USED TO IDENTIFY THE VICTIM.
BUT ALSO SEPARATE THEM FROM THE
PAMP. AND UNLESS YOU HAVE SEEN
THIS UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL AS I
HAVE BEEN OTHERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I THINK IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHY THESE TOOLS
MATTER. IT IS A PROTECTION. FOR
CUSTODY. KEEPING THEM AWAY FROM
THE PIMP THAT'S GOING TO BEAT
HIM UP SCARED TO DEATH. HURT
THEM. THAT SEPARATION TAKES
PLACE. AND THEN THEY ARE HELPED.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF TOOLS.
AND THEY'RE BEING EFFECTIVELY
USED. TO RESCUE THE VICTIMS. WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN THOSE KINDS OF
TOOLS. NOT BECAUSE WE'RE
TARGETING. WE'RE PROTECTING.
THAT'S HOW WE USE IT IT'S WHY
IT NEEDS TO REMAIN BECAUSE IT'S
EFFECTIVE IN SAVING. CARING FOR
AND TRANSPORTING THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO SAFE HOUSES AND
PLACES WHERE THEY CAN GET HELP.
DR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I WAS NOT
PLANNING ON RISING I'M TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL BUT JUST.
LISTENING TO THE DIFFERENT
ARGUMENTS- THERE IS A LOT THAT
WE NEED TO DO TO PROTECT THOSE
WHO ARE BEING SECTION SEX
TRAFFICKED NOT JUST IN THIS
RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT JUST
FALLEN POLICE OFFICERS IT FALLS
ON OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM BECAUSE
MANY OF THESE KIDS ARE IN
SCHOOL SYSTEM INVOLVED IN AS IN
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION. WHEN
THEY COME INTO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM FOR TREATMENT AND
SCREENING AND WHEN WE FIND OUT
THAT THEY HAVE EITHER INFECTION
OR PREGNANCY AND THERE'S A LOT
OF. THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE.
BUT THIS BILL REALLY TALKS
ABOUT PROFILING. AND WE'VE
ALREADY SAID HERE ON THIS FLOOR
THAT WE DON'T AGREE WITH RACIAL
PROFILING. THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GIVE SOMEBODY A GANG
ENHANCEMENT BUT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE PROOF. AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL BASICALLY SPACES YOU CAN'T
ARREST SOMEBODY FOR HOW THEY
LOOK. WHERE THEY'RE WALKING. OR
WHO THEY MAY LOVE. YOU NEED TO
ACTUALLY CATCH THEM IN THAT ACT.
AND SO IT'S NOT A BILL THAT'S
GOING TO ALLOW. PREDATORS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR YOUTH.
AND LIKE I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING THERE'S A LOT THAT WE
NEED TO DO AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF OUR
SOCIETY WE DO NEED TO DO BETTER.
BUT THIS BILL. IS ABOUT
PROFILING AND WE'VE ALREADY
STATED ON THIS FLOOR THAT THIS
IS NOT A STATE. THAT IS GOING
TO PROFILE SOMEBODY. BASED ON
THEIR RACE. THEIR GENDER THEIR
SEX. AND THAT'S WHY I ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU. TECH
DATA WEBER. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M I TWO HAD
NOT INTENDED TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL TODAY BUT SEVEN I FEEL
COMPELLED TO STAND AT BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THAT I AND MY
INABILITY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
IS DEEPLY DISAPPOINTING TO MANY
OF MY FRIENDS AND MANY PEOPLE
THAT I CARE ABOUT. I'M HERE'S
THE THING WE OFTEN VOTE ON VERY
WELL INTENTIONED TO PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT HAVE AN
INTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE ALWAYS
NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AND
FOR ME WHEN THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE IS MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT MORE DIFFICULT TO
PROTECT. VICTIMS OF CHILD
TRAFFICKING. EVEN IF THAT'S
JUST A POSSIBILITY THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT I CAN SUPPORT
AND TIME SO REGRETTABLY I WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
THIS BILL TODAY. MEMBERS. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE BAIT. I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES AT
THIS TIME. MISTER PRIME YOUR
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I WILL BE
EXCEPTIONALLY BRIEF. THERE WAS
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE WE
PUT THIS LAW ON THE BOOKS. THE
LAW I BELIEVE WAS RIGHTEOUSLY
INTENDED TO HELP CURB HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THERE HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY ZERO DATA OR
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT IT HAS
WHICH IS WHY I HAVE BEEN CITED
ON THE FLOOR. THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE THAT OCCURRED. IS
THAT BLACK WOMEN. IN TRANS
WOMEN HAVE BEEN PROFILED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESULTING IN OVER
SIXTY PERCENT. OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE PICKED UP FOR THE START
BEING BLACK WHEN. BEING THIS
ABORTION THE TRANSFER THAT'S
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE WE
MADE A MISTAKE. AND WE NEED TO
ROLL IT BACK. THIS DOESN'T
PREVENT. US FROM GOING AFTER
TRUCKERS IT DOESN'T PREVENT US
FROM GOING UP TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
SOLICITING. STATION WE CAN
STILL DO THAT WORK WHAT WE CAN
DO IT WITHOUT THE PROFILING
THAT THE CARD FROM THIS LAW. I
ENCOURAGE NOVEL. THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME. THANK YOU MEMBERS
MS PARA QUE HAN YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
FOR THE ROBUST DISCUSSION THAT
WE HAD ON THIS BILL BUT I ALSO
WANT TO CLEAR A COUPLE THINGS
THAT BECAUSE A LOT OF THINGS
WERE SAID THAT ARE. PATENTLY
FALSE ONE OF WHICH WAS THE
FOCUS ON CHILD TRAFFICKING AS
MY COLLEAGUE MEL GROVE ACTUALLY
POINTED OUT THAT WAS
DECRIMINALIZE THE LOITERING FOR
THE PURPOSE OF PROSTITUTION FOR
MINORS WITH DECRIMINALIZED IN
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE BILL CARRIED
BY. SENATOR MITCHELL THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALM DOES IN
FACT A CO AUTHOR ON SO IF YOU
BELIEVE THIS IS THAT LOITERING
FOR THE PURPOSE OF PROSTITUTION
IS A TOOL NEEDED TO END CHILD
TRAFFICKING WELL YOU SHOULD
TALK TO WHOEVER THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. BECAUSE THAT
WAS DONE IN THIS BILL RELATES
TO PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN SO I TRY TO BE REALLY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT ABOUT WHAT THE
LAW DOES TODAY AND WHAT THIS
LAW WILL CHANGE BECAUSE I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF
MISSTATEMENTS OF FACTS THAT
WERE MADE IN THESE DEBATES.
SECONDLY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO CALLED THIS A TOOL USE
THE WORD TOOL MANY TIMES IT'S A
REALLY NICE WORD FOR
CRIMINALIZING VICTIMS IT IS NOT
JUST A TOOL MEMBERS THIS IS A
CRIME. AND I WANT US TO CALL IT
WHAT IT ACTUALLY IS. SO IF YOU
BELIEVE. THAT FULL HER LAWYER
DURING SHOULD BE CONVICTED OF A
CRIME. THEN DO WHAT YOU GOTTA
DO BUT IT'S NOT A TOOL IT'S A
CRIME AND THESE PEOPLE END UP
WITH A RECORD THAT WILL STOP
THEM FROM GETTING HOUSING AND
JOBS IN THE FUTURE THEY DESERVE.
AND SO I WANTED TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS IS. AS A
BODY WE PASSED A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN AID
FOR VICTIMS. SO WHICH GOES TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS WE-
AS A BODY BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE BELIEVE DEEPLY AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE SPOKE
ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD DISCUSS DOING
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE ALL WANT TO END
HUMAN TRAFFICKING I THINK EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US. IS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO SAYS WE'RE
LOSING THE WAR ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BUT CAST LA WHICH
IS THE STRONGEST ADVOCATE FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
SUPPORTS THIS LEGISLATION. AND
SO WHEN THE QUESTION WAS RAISED
ABOUT. WHAT MAKES OUR COMMUNITY
SAFER I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
WHICH COMMUNITIES DO CARE ABOUT.
AND THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY IS NOT
SAFER WITH THIS LAW ON THE
BOOKS AND IS A LONG TIME ALLY.
AND LGBTQ PLUS RIGHT I AM PROUD
TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TODAY. AND LASTLY. WHEN
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUE SAID. WELL
IF THEY'RE DRESSED THAT WAY.
HOW MANY OF US HAVE FRIENDS
THAT HAVE BEEN RATE WHO WERE
TOLD WELL. YOU WERE DRESSED
THAT WAY BEING DRESSED THAT WAY
IS NOT A CRIME. AND IT WILL
NEVER BE OKAY TO BE VICTIMIZED
BECAUSE YOUR DRAFTS IN ANY
MANNER. I WANT TO BE CLEAR TO
EVERYBODY WHO'S WATCHING AND
LISTENING TODAY. AND WITH THAT
ON BEHALF OF EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF OUR LGBTQ PLUS SISTERS AND
BROTHERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
ED. THE CLUB THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO GO TO A MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE
KNOWS TWENTY SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN FILE ITEM FIFTEEN.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY FIVE.
AND THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL A TWENTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AND I PLEDGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE MS BURKE
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE IS
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE BILL WHICH
COMBINE SEVERAL LEGISLATION
PROPOSALS INTO ONE MEASURE TO
HELP TAX ADMINISTRATION THIS
BILL CONTAINS ONLY NON CONVERT
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES IN TAX
LAW. SUGGESTED BY THE B. O. E.
AND C. A. C. T. T. C. S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION AND RECEIVED NOT A
SINGLE NO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS AND I. THANK YOU MS
BURKE. SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CIRCLE OF
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
THE I. SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE UP.
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WE ARE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO- A PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NUMBER.%
THREE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR THIS IS
THE CONCURRENCE FILE AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE SEVENTY THREE BY
SOMEONE RODRIGUEZ AND ACCORDING
TO JOHN TRAINING MYSTERY GUESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWELVE SORRY THREE
WOULD PROMOTE EARNER LEARN
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
PREVIOUSLY PASS ON THIS FOR
CONSENT AND PASSED ON THE
SENATE FLOOR WITH UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT. THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THAT THE BILL WOULD
NOT REQUIRE OR FORCE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS TO ENTER
INTO EARNERS- GRIEVANCE AND
REMOVE LATE OPPOSITION FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. AB TWELVE SORRY THROUGH
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE A
PATHWAY TO ENTER THESE
PROFESSIONS AND CREATE A MORE
DIVERSE AND REVOKE ROBUST WORK
FIRST. RESPECT US PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLICK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS
WILL. WHO IS THERE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOR THE
CORPORATION A SYMBOL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT CLEANS HOUSING
MISTER DAVID CHIU RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR IS THE ANNUAL HOUSING
OMNIBUS BILL IT MAKES A SERIES
OF TECHNICAL NON CONTROVERSIAL
CHANGES TO OUR STATE'S HOUSING
LAWS ALL PROVISIONS IN THE
OMNIBUS HAVE BEEN VETTED BY A
DIVERSE BIPARTISAN GROUP OF
REVIEWERS AND THE BILL HAS NOT
RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES TODAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. SAYING
NO DISCUSSION FOR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK BELOW FOR THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE TELL
YOU ABOUT I SIXTY NINE NO. ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
I'D ABOUT THE CONCURRENCE FILE
WE'RE GOING BACK TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT. BY
MISTER LEE AND THE CORPORATION
SOME PEPLE TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
BY SUMMARILY IN ACKLINS
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. MISTER LIAM
AILMENT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT IS BACK OCCURRENCE
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE TO NARROW THE BILL AND
REMOVED OPPOSITION REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM GROUPS
INCLUDING THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS CALIFORNIA THE STATE
COALITION OF PROBATION
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. WE ALSO RESEARCH
RECEIVED ENORMOUS INPUT FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LATE. SAME NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM KRIKALEV THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY TWO KNOWS NINETEENTH
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MEMBERS WE ARE MAKING GOOD
PROGRESS WE ARE GOING TO. TAKE
A RECESS FOR LUNCH. PER THE
USUAL REPUBLICAN LUNCHES CAN BE
PICKED UP AT THE WILLIE BROWN
ROOM I BELIEVE. BEFORE YOU
BEFORE YOU LEAVE MEMBERS CAN WE
JUST CONFIRM THAT. AND I
BELIEVE LUNCH IS THAT'S A
THUMBS UP REPUBLICAN LUNCHEON
THE WILLIE BROWN AROUND- YOU'RE
ABLE TO PICK IT RELIGIOUS ITALY
BROWN ROOM THE DEMOCRATS YOU
MAY PICK UP YOUR LUGGAGE IN THE
LOUNGE WE ARE GOING TO RECESS
UNTIL TWO FIFTEEN JUST A LITTLE
OVER AN HOUR MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN TO THE FLOOR AT TWO
FIFTEEN PM SO WE MAY RESUME
TAKING. UP THE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE HOUSE. ENJOY YOUR LUNCH.
MEMBERS AN ANNOUNCEMENT THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
WILL BE MEETING RIGHT NOW AND
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES MEETING RIGHT
NOW IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO.
MEMBERS WE ARE PASSED TO
FIFTEEN AND FOUR SESSION WILL
BE RESUMING PLEASE MAKE YOUR
WAY TO THE FLOOR SO WE MAY
PRESUME FLOOR SESSION.
MEMBERS.
I WON'T NAME ANY NAMES BUT IF
YOU HAVE A BILL ON THE
CONCURRENT FILE. THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE CENTER THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE I'M HERE TO TAKE IT UP.
I DON'T SEE ANY OF THE MEMBERS-
SPEAR THE BILL'S APPEAR A LOT
ON THE CONCURRENT STYLE.
MISTER
YOU READY FOR A CHANGE. ANY FOR
MY CONCURRENT- HEY I NEED TO
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT BEFORE WE
CAN TAKE THEM OUT GETTING THAT
READY RIGHT NOW SIR THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO WORK ON
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILED CHIU
STARTING WITH FILE I. WITH ITEM
OF ONE NO ONE WORKING IT
THROUGH. I HAD A. ONE THIRTEEN
WE WILL GO TO I DON'T WANT TO
ONE OF THE SECOND READING FILE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL.
THREE EIGHTY ONE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM ONE OH TWO. AB
THREE SIXTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KIRK
SILVA AND ACCOLADES HOUSING IS
VIRTUALLY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. AB THREE SIXTY TWO
IS BACK FROM SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL INSURERS
MINIMUM HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS ARE FOLLOWED WHY
SHELTER OPERATORS AND THAT ALL
SHELTER RESIDENTS ARE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
ALIGNS THE BILL TO THE CURRENT
STATE HOUSING LAW AND INCLUDES
REPORTING REQUIREMENT OF
CITATIONS SHELTERS RECEIVE AS
WELL AS REMEDIES TAKEN THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THEIR VOTE. HOME MEMBERS GO TO
DO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THIRTY VOTE. FIRST.
FORTY ONE. NO.
ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES
FORTY ONE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TELEVOTE ICE FORTY ONE
KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CAN HEARD IN. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM ONE OH THREE AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
MAC LEVINE PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT.
IT'S YOUR CAR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER VISORS IN AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX BACK FROM THE
SENATE WHICH IS AMENDED. TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT TEMPORARY
EXEMPTION NEWSPAPER CARRIERS
THE ABC TEST FROM PLANET
STATUS. AB FIFTY SIX THE RESULT
OF THOUGHTFUL NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY AS WELL
AS CONSULTATION FEEDBACK. FROM
LABOR STAKEHOLDERS. THIS
EXTENSION BECAUSE CRITICAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER
FOR THE STATE AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO ASSESS THE USE OF THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR MODEL
INDUSTRY. AND ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW. THE BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION AS YOU
SEE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH
THAT ASPECT. OF THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTED THIRD
OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY
VOTE. WHERE WILL THE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
SIX NO ONE SENTIMENTS ARE
COMPARED IN. ONLY TO FILE ITEM
ONE OH FOUR AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER MACK
LEADING THE HORSE RACING COOPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THIRTY
MINUTES BE REMEMBERS WHEN AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE PASSED
THIS COMMITTEE THE BILL ADDRESS
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
THOROUGHBRED HORSE RACING. IN
THE SENATE I'M IN THE BILL TO
BE THOROUGHBRED RACING
PROVISION AND INSTEAD ADDRESS
THE PROCESS FOR DETERMINING
COMPENSATION PAID LESS ACCOUNT
WAGERING SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR
PROCESSING WHICH IS A LIFE
FORCE RACES. INCLUDING
ARBITRATION CLAUSE FOR
RESOLVING DISPUTES. ARE
STRICTLY ASPEN I'VE A- THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER. SEEING AND
HEARING FURTHER TO BE ON THE
MATTER WELL THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTE THURSDAY. HOME MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO GO.
NONMEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TELEVOTE I FIFTY NINE TWO ZERO
SAN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR FORTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE FOR
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON MACKLIN TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN
RESERVE RESULTS THREE TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT HAVE ARISEN WITH
RESPECT TO THE STATE LAW
GOVERNING THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM IS PRIMARILY THE METHOD
FOR FINANCING THE ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION AND
REHABILITATION. OF AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME TENANTS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL IS ENJOYED
BY PARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. TO
VOTE. HOME THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
GO. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY TWO
THIRDS VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IT WILL BE TO FILE
ITEM ONE OF SIX AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL HE SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND OTHERS
NATALIE TO HOMELESSNESS. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER CALLING SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN OUR STATE HAS RECEIVED
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE
NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUND TO
CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS THIS
BILL WOULD PRIORITIZE THOSE
TRUST FUND DOLLARS FOR
DEVELOPMENTS THAT SERVE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
SPECIAL EMPHASIS ON PROJECTS
THAT USE MEDICAL BENEFITS TO
PAY FOR SERVICES THE BILL
ONLINE FEDERAL FUNDED. WITH THE
STATE'S GOALS OF REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU MR CHIU SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
OUT OF THE CLERK WILL OPEN. ALL
MEMBERS GO THROUGH THERE TO GO.
ALL OF THEM VOTE TO THE ART OF.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW IT ABOUT ICE FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS TWELVE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE INCURRED IN. LIVING A FILE
ITEM ONE OH SEVEN AB FOUR OH
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
BILL FOUR OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS AND OTHERS SNACK
LATER HEALING ARTS THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS WHO IS READY TO
GO. IS NOW RECOGNIZED ON HIS
BILL. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AB BOROUGHS IS THAT CONCERNS.
EXPAND ON THIS QUALITY I CARE
ABOUT THE RISING. TEMPERATURES
TO TREAT ADDITIONAL CONDITIONS
OF THE I. THE FALL. WITHIN
THEIR SCOPE THIS IS A PRACTICE
BILL THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER SALAS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT
OF IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THAT I SIXTY NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE OH
EIGHT AB EIGHT THIRTY THE
PERCHLORATE ASSEMBLY BILL HE
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORENT ACT LEADING TO BUSINESS
OR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE MALE
SPEAKER AB EIGHT THIRTY IS BACK
ON THE CURRENT SENTIMENTS AND
RESPECT LAST NIGHT OF THANK YOU
MISTER FLORES SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- CALL MEMBERS VOTED THIRD
OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE TWO
THIRDS THOSE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEDINA FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOR BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
IMMACULATA HEALING ARTS. HELLO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MINISTRY CURING COLLEAGUES THIS
IS A SERIES OF SUNSET BILLS.
BEGIN WITH THE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR ON THE
BOARD OF ATOMIC TREE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRANCO. THANK
YOU MR LOS SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER OF
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
ABOUT ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TEN
MAYBE FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
ACCORDING TO HIM THE GUARDS
HELLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD EXTENSION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER. DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ROAD CALL MEMBERS THIRD OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR. TO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TYLER I SPEAKING NINE TWO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS IMMACULATELY IN THE
GARBAGE WELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF AN
AFRICAN COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE
BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTED
THIRD OF THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING ABOUT
I SIXTIES YOU KNOW ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE TINKERED IN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE
AB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOULD NATURALLY THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES MISTER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AB FIVE TWENTY
SEVENTHS BACKTRACKING CURRENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR. ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY
NEW ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONFERRED IN. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY A FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
GO BACK TO THE SENATE TO REFILE
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
BY CEREMONY BACKLIT IN THE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
UPDATES THE GOVERNING STATUTE
OF THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
OPPORTUNITY ACCESS PROGRAM
KNOWN AS COUNSEL TO BOTH
REFLECT THE POSTSECONDARY
ACCESS NEEDS OF TODAY'S HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND TO ALIGN
EXISTING BEST PRACTICES OF EACH
OF THE COUNTS SO PROJECTS.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY SIXTEEN
COUNCIL PROJECTS WITH A VARYING
RANGE OF SERVICES TO STUDENTS
IN THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING NOT ONLY FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION ASSISTANCE BUT
ALSO TUTORING AND ACADEMIC
SUPPORT. SB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
REDUCES DUPLICATION OF
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAMS LIKE
AVID TRIO AND GEAR UP ALREADY
PROVIDE ACADEMIC SUPPORT
PROGRAMMING BY FOCUSING COUNCIL
PROJECTS ON FINANCIAL AID
ASSISTANCE AN AREA WHERE THEY
HAVE EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE
FOUND LESS OFTEN IN HIGH
SCHOOLS. S. B. SEVEN THREE
SEVEN ALIGNS WITH RECENT
EFFORTS BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
FINANCIAL AID ACCESS FOR ALL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS BY REQUIRING
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION
COMPLETION. AMONG HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA SEEING NO MEMBERS WISH
TO DISCUSSOR DEBATE THE ITEM
WE MANITOBA PURPLE OPEN THE
ROLE. NUMBER IS THERE TO DO.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS LOW WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES I FIFTY SIX NO ZEROS THE
BILL IS PASSED. WILL MOVE THE
FILE ITEM THIRTY SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE TRIPLE READ. SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE BY CENTER
BACK HER BACK LOOKING TO MURDER
SOME OF OUR CAN YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS BODY
PASSED SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER. THE BILL
CHANGE CALIFORNIA'S LONG HELD
AN UNJUST FELONY MURDER LAW
WHICH WAS IN OUR CAKE MEASURE
THAT ENABLE PEOPLE WHO NEVER
KILLED ANYONE NOT EVEN ABOUT A
MURDER AND NEVER EVER EVEN
INTENDED FOR DEATH TO OCCUR TO
NONETHELESS BE CHARGED WITH THE
MURDER COMMITTED BY SOMEBODY
ELSE. AND WHEN THIS LEGISLATURE.
THE MEASURE WE CREATE A PATHWAY
FOR PEOPLE WHO TOOK PLEA DEALS
TO LESSER CHARGES. SUCH AS
MANSLAUGHTER APPLY FOR
RESENTENCING. IT WAS A LANDMARK
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
TRANSFORMED OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE LONG
MARCH TOWARDS FAIRNESS. JUSTICE
AND EQUALITY. HOWEVER SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN SOME COURTS HAVE
INCORRECTLY LIMITED ITS
APPLICABILITY. ONLY TOWARDS
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED
OF MURDER BUT NOT LESS CULPABLE
OFFENSES LIKE ATTEMPTED MURDER
AND MANSLAUGHTER. IN PRACTICE
THAT HAS LED TO THE UNFAIR
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR RESENTENCING IF
THE VICTIM DIED. BUT OUR
INELIGIBLE IF THE VICTIM DID
NOT DIE. SB SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
OF THE NARROW LIMITED MEASURE
TO CLOSE THE UNREST LOOPHOLE.
IT DOES SO BY CLARIFYING
EXISTING LAW TO INCLUDE
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER AND
ATTEMPTED MURDER CONVICTIONS AS
ELIGIBLE FOR RELIEF UNDER SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE ALSO ALLOWS FOR
COUNSEL TO BE APPOINTED IN
PETITIONS FOR RESENTENCING. AND
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR ALL
THOSE WHOSE MURDER ATTEMPTED
MURDER OR MANSLAUGHTER
CONVICTIONS ARE FINAL TO
APPEAL. THE REFORM WOULD ASSIST
HUNDREDS OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE
THAT THE APPELLATE COURTS HAVE
DEEMED TO BE EXCLUDED BY
TECHNICAL LANGUAGE OF FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THE BILL WAS
AMENDED IN THIS HOUSE OF THE
QUEST OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WHOSE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND
ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF NUMEROUS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMER
INNOVATIONS. THE BILL IS CO
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. BIGAMIST ARCANE SEEING.
THE DEADLINE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER JUST A COUPLE THINGS TO
POINT OUT AS YOU DELIBERATE
THIS BILL SOUNDS LIKE A FAIRLY
TECHNICAL INNOCUOUS EXTENSION
OF A LAW BUT IT GOES A LOT
DEEPER THAN THAT. FOR ONE THING
IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND MOST
PEOPLE. A MAJORITY I WOULD SAY-
THAT ARE CONVICTED OF VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER DONE SO AFTER PLEA
AGREEMENT THEY'RE CHARGED WITH
MURDER AND THE EVIDENCE IS
SHAKY MAYBE ON THE MURDER OR
MAYBE THERE ARE YOUNG OR MAYBE
THERE ARE MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES OR MAYBE. THEY
DON'THAVE A RECORD AND THE
DA'S OFFICE OFFERS THEM A PLEA
BARGAIN WHERE THEY PLEA TO
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER. THE
PENALTIES ON THESE TWO CRIMES
ARE MUCH DIFFERENT. MURDER ONCE
TWENTY FIVE TO LIFE MURDER TO
FIFTEEN TO LIFE. VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER IT'S THREE SIX OR
ELEVEN YEARS SO YOU CAN SEE WHY
THAT BE PRETTY ENTICING TO A
DEFENDANT FACING THE POTENTIAL
FIFTEEN OR TWENTY FIVE TO LIFE
TO TAKE THAT DEAL SO THEY TAKE
THAT DEAL AND THAT'S THE DEAL
THEY MADE WITH THE PEOPLE THE
PEOPLE'S REPRESENTED THE
PEOPLE. OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOW WE'RE COMING
ALONG AND SAYING. WELL YOU GET
TO READ BE RESENTENCED WELL
OKAY. BUT IT ALSO SAYS THAT THE
JUDGE HAS TO LOOK AT EVIDENCE
AND IT EXCLUDES HEARSAY
EVIDENCE PUT ON A PRELIM.
PRELIMS ARE ALL DONE WITH YOUR
SENTENCE. PLEA DEALS DON'T EVEN
SOMETIMES HAVE PRELIMS. SO
YOU'VE GOT NO RECORD THERE'S
NOTHING TO LOOK AT FOR THESE
RESENTENCING. WHICH MEANS
THEY'RE BASICALLY GOING TO BE
RUBBER STAMPED BY THE COURTS.
SO PEOPLE THAT WERE CHARGED
ORIGINALLY WITH MURDER GOOD
CHUNK OF THEM. THAT TOOK A DEAL
THAT THEY MADE WITH THE STATE
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE.
GET A SEVERE REDUCTION SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF EVIDENCE.
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM. THAT'S A
BIG PROBLEM TURNS JUSTICE.
BECAUSE JUSTICE HAS DIFFERENT
SIDES THERE'S JUSTICE FOR THE
ACCUSED THERE'S DUE PROCESS FOR
THE ACCUSER JUSTICE FOR THE
VICTIMS AND THE VICTIMS FAMILY
TO. THE LAW HAS ALWAYS TREATED
ATTEMPTED MURDER AND MURDER
SERIOUSLY ALWAYS. FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF YEARS OF PRE
RECORDED HISTORY AND THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF YEARS OF
RECORDED HISTORY. MANKIND
KILLED EACH OTHER INTENTIONALLY.
READ SOME HISTORY IT'S PRETTY
UGLY. THAT'S WHY EVERY
CIVILIZED SOCIETY SAYS MURDER
IS GOING TO BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY THAN EVERYTHING
ELSE BECAUSE IT IS A CRIME FOR
WHICH YOU CANNOT UNDO THE HARM.
NO NOT A COUNSELING FIXES
MURDER. NO MATTER
REHABILITATION FIXES A LIFE
THAT YOU SNUFFED OUT. AN
INNOCENT LIFE THAT YOU TOOK
WITHOUT JUSTIFICATION. THE
CHANGES FAMILIES. WRECKS LIVES
THAT'S WHY THE LAW HAS ALWAYS
SAID MURDER IS TREATED
DIFFERENTLY THAN EVERYTHING
ELSE BUT GUESS WHAT. THE
PENALTY FOR MURDER IN
CALIFORNIA AGAINST TWENTY FIVE
OR FIFTEEN TO LIFE DEPENDING ON
THE TYPE THE PENALTY FOR
ATTEMPTED MURDER. WHICH HAS THE
SAME CONDUCT AND THE SAME
INTENT THE ONLY DIFFERENCES THE
VICTIM GOT LUCKY AND SURVIVED.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE THAT'S A
FACT IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT
LEARN CRIMINAL LAW. THE PENALTY
FOR ATTEMPTED MURDER. IS FIVE
SEVEN OR NINE YEARS. THIS
BRINGS UP A CASE I WORKED ON
WHEN I WAS A DA WAS THE LEAD
ATTORNEY BUT I WROTE BRIEFS IT
WAS UNDER THE NATURAL PROBLEM
CONSEQUENCES MURDER DOCTORAL
TRY TO BE FAST BECAUSE I'M
UNDER A TIME LIMIT. DEFENDANT
LET'S CALL MISTER J. MISTER JAY
WAS THIRTY YEAR OLD HOW LONG
RECORD HE CONVINCED THE
NINETEEN YEAR OLD WILL CALL HIM
MR EIGHT HE COMMITS A NINETEEN
YEAR OLD BARELY ABOVE A KID. TO
GO RIP OFF A HOUSE WHERE THEY
WERE DEALING WEED A LITTLE
SLEEPY BEACH TOWNS IN THIS
BESPOKE COUNTY MISTER J. GAVE
MR A THE A- HAND GUN. HE SAID
GO IN THERE. TAKE THEIR MONEY
TAKE THEIR DRUGS. MR A WIN IN
THEIR IT'S ALL MASTERMINDED BY
MISTER J. THE OLDER GUY SITTING
IN HIS CAR RIGHT OUTSIDE THE
HOUSE. OUR WAY TO GET A KID TO
DO THAT. MR A WIN IN I NEED THE
GUN AT THE DRUG DEALER.
BASICALLY JUST SELLING WEED NOT
EVEN A LEGAL NOW SHOULDN'T BE
AYE BUT FOR THAT. WHEN THE GUN
ADAM SAID GIVE ME YOUR MONEY.
UNBEKNOWNST TO HIM. THE WE
DEALER HAD TWENTY TWO UNDER THE
BED. AND HE GRABBED THE TWENTY
TWO TO DEFEND HIMSELF MR A SHOT
MISSED. AND THE WE DEALER SHOT
BACK TO DEFEND HIMSELF HIT THE
NINETEEN YEAR OLD IN THE RIB.
THE BULLET PUNCTURED THE LONG
NINETY YEAR OLD DOT. CAN'T
PROSECUTE HIM. HE'S HE'S IN
MANY WAYS A VICTIM. WE
PROSECUTED MR J. THE MASTERMIND
THE GUY WHO SET THIS ON THE
MOTION WHO CREATED THE
CIRCUMSTANCE UNDER WHICH A
NINETEEN YEAR OLD WAS MURDERED.
WAS KILLED CAN'T PROSECUTE THE
KID DEFENDING HIMSELF. YOU GOT
EVERY RIGHT UNDER LAW TO DEFEND
YOURSELF AGAINST. DEADLY FORCE
USING DEADLY FORCE THIRTY
SECONDS. THOSE ARE THE KIND OF
SITUATIONS THAT THIS TYPE OF
STUFF APPLIES TO. SO KNOW THAT
pMISTER A BEEN A LITTLE LUCKIER
HAD THAT TWENTY TWO ROUND.
GONNA MILLIMETER TO ONE
DIRECTION IT WOULD HAVE GLANCED
OFF HIS RIB ANY BE ALIVE TODAY.
MISTER J. WOULD'VE BEEN A
PROSECUTOR FOR ATTEMPTED
MURDER. AND HE WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE IF THIS BILL BECOMES
LAW. TO BE RESENTENCED AND LET
OUT EARLY WITHOUT ANY INPUT
FROM ANY VICTIM. OR ANY
EVIDENCE BECAUSE THE EVIDENCE
IS PROBABLY GONNA. THINK ABOUT
THAT WHEN YOU VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO DISCUSS
OF A BABY ITEM IS MARKING YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO
FOR HIS REMARKS I JUST WANNA
MAKE A CLARIFICATION ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES AND DOESN'T DO
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THOSE WHO
WERE CHARGED AND CONVICTED
UNDER THE FELONY MURDER RULE.
THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN AIDING
AND ABETTING MURDER WHICH WILL
STILL REMAIN ON THE BOOKS AFTER
THIS BILL PASSES THIS IS PEOPLE
WHO DO NOT INTEND FOR MURDER TO
OCCUR AND THEY ARE BEING
CHARGED WITH THE MURDER OF
ANOTHER WELL WE'RE YOU YOU I
WAS NOT HERE AT THE TIME BUT
THIS HOUSE RT SAID THAT THEY
CANNOT BE CHARGED WITH THE
MURDER COMMITTED BY ANOTHER.
BUT IF IT IS A MANSLAUGHTER
CHARGE THEY CAN STILLBE
CHARGED EVEN IF THEY DROVE UP
THINKING ALL THAT WAS GONNA
HAPPEN WAS SOME CRIME MUCH LESS.
THEN WHAT OCCURRED DURING THE
INCIDENT AND NOW THEY'RE BEING
CHARGED THE CRIME OF ANOTHER.
AND I THINK WHAT. THE QUESTION
THAT IS BEFORE THIS HOUSE TODAY
AND WAS BEFORE THIS HOUSE. WHEN
SENATOR SKINNER BROUGHT HER
BILL YEARS AGO WAS. WHERE
SHOULD THE CULPABILITY LIFE.
THE PERSON WHO PULLS THE
TRIGGER COMMITTED MURDER
COMMITTED MANSLAUGHTER WHATEVER
THE CRIME IS THAT WAS
COMMITTED. AND THEY WILL SERVE
THE TIME IF ENABLE PROSECUTOR.
PROVES GUILT BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT BUT- ARE YOU
GUILTY FOR THAT ACT IF YOU WERE
NOT THE ONE WHO COMMITTED IT.
AND IF THAT ACTS RIGHT NOW IS
MANSLAUGHTER LOSSES YES. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE QUESTION
BEFORE THE HOUSE AND I BELIEVE
THAT MANY OF US BELIEVE JUSTICE
IS SERVED WITH THE PERSON WHO
COMMITS THE ACT IS CHARGING
SERVES THE TIME. AND WE EACH
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR ACTIONS
THAT WE SHOULD SERVE THE TIME
AND I GET AWAY DRIVER WILL
SERVE TIME FOR CRIME BUT NOT
THE CRIME COMMITTED BY ANOTHER.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS JUSTICE
MEAN AND EVERY VICTIM DESERVES
JUSTICE. AND THE PERSON WHO
PULLED THAT TRIGGER WILL SERVE.
FOR THAT CRIME WHICH HAD
SOMEONE ELSE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU TO PURPLE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MRR
CAN MOVE THE CALL. MEMBERS WILL
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN THIS IS SB SIX SIX SEVEN
THE COURT WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTY SEVEN BY CENTER
ROTH AND OTHERS MACKLIN'S
TAXATION- A RESTAURANT IF YOU
MAY OPEN. YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB SIX SIX SEVEN
CLARIFIES THAT AN EXECUTOR
ADMINISTRATOR TRUSTEE OR
PERSONAL LEGAL REPRESENTATIVE
OF A DISABLED VETERAN TO STAY
OR TRUST ASSETS MAY FILE A
DISABLED VETERAN PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION OR DVD WITH AN
ASSESSOR ON BEHALF OF THE
ELIGIBLE. CLAIMANTS WELL THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION ALREADY
ALLOWS THIS TO OCCUR THERE ARE
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATIONSAMONG
THE COUNTY ASSESSOR'S
INTERSTATE ABOUT WHETHER THIS%
ABILITY TO FOLLOW DEVIOUS
PERMITTED UNDER EXISTING LAW.
BY MAKING THIS CLARIFICATION SB
SIX SIX SEVEN ONE SURE
CONSISTENCY ACROSS ALL OF OUR
COUNTIES AND REMOVE UNNECESSARY
HURDLES FOR FAMILIES OF
DISABLED VETERANS. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED ZERO VOTE VOTES
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB SIX SIX SEVEN. THANK
YOU MR BONTA SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS WAS TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE ITEM THE PURPLE OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
WHO DESIRE DEVELOPER WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY OF VOTES I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE BILL IS
PASSED. WE WILL MOVE BACK UP
THE FILE ORDER TO. MISTER
CALDERON AS PROMOTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS SPEAKER AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR IS
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
TO THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM NINE
SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR HERTZBERG
AND ITEM TWELVE SB SIX THREE
SEVEN NEWMAN THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA. WE WILL TAKE UP NEXT
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE THIS IS SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY
ONE BY CENTER CORTESE AND
OTHERS SNACK WITHIN THE LAND
USE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PORTUGAL
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR OPEN. YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
RESENT SB SEVEN NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR CORTESE THIS BILL
CREATES A TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
UNIT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON LOCAL
SURPLUS LAND. LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES CONTROL THOUSANDS OF
SURPLUS SITES THAT HAVE SAT
VACANT FOR YEARS DUE TO THE
NUMEROUS BARRIERS THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES FACE AND GETTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILT SUCH
AS A LACK OF CAPACITY AND
EXPERTISE IN THE PAST FEW YEARS
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION OF SET THE
GROUNDWORK. FOR UTILIZING
UNUSED PUBLIC LAND YOUR MUM TO
PROMOTE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. RECENTLY PASSED
LEGISLATION REQUIRED EACH CITY
AND COUNTY TO REPORT TO THE H.
C. D. AN INVENTORY OF ITS
SURPLUS LANDS BY APRIL OF THIS
YEAR. SINCE THESE MEASURES HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE HCD HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMED WITH CALLS FROM
LOCAL AGENCIES ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE IN DISPOSING OF
THEIR SURPLUS LAND. THE STATE
MUST TAKE A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
AGENCIES IN GETTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUILT ON LOCAL SURPLUS
LAND. SB SEVEN NINE ONE
ACHIEVES THIS BY CREATING A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE UNIT
WITHIN H. CD THAT WILL
FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE ANY RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE UNDER
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT AND IT IS
COMPLETELY OPTIONAL FORCE
AGENCIES TO CONTACT THE UNIT
FOR ASSISTANCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MATH PERKS SILVA SEEING NO
MEMBERS WISH TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE ITEM THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS OF
HIS IRON TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
PALATABLE I FIFTY SIX NO SEVEN
THE BILL IS PASSED. NEXT WOULD
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO THIS SB
FEET- TO THE CORPORATION SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH TWO BY CENTER
ROBIN ACCOLADE IN A PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION A
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
SB EIGHT ZERO TWO IT IS OUR
SENSE THAT BILL FOR THE BUREAU
OF PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR ROSE SENIOR
MEMBERS WISH TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THIS ITEM THE PARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS.
TO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
CALENDAR I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE BILL IS PASSED. NEXT IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE SB EIGHT
OR SIX CORKERY SENATE BILL
IT'LL SIX BY CIRA AN ACCOLADE
HEALING ARTS SUMMER LOW ME OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES THIS IS
OUR SUNSET BILL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD. FOR THE
MEDICAL BORDERS WAS THE LAST
REBEL. THANK YOU MR LOW SENIOR
MEMBERS WITH TO DISCUSS AND
DEBATE THE ITEM PARK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
FOLKS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
BILL IS PASSED.
WITH RAZOR
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
TAKE UP ITEM ONE S. B. MCGUIRE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING. THANK YOU PRESENTED
GRANTED. WITHOUT MEMBERS WE
WILL BE MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SB EIGHTY CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY BY SENATE
MCGUIRE AND OTHERS NEVER IN THE
COMMERCIAL FISHING AND CLEARLY
OF THE CEDAR OF THE CORRECT
MEDIALLY. THIS IS TONY MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ANNUAL
OMNIBUS BILL COMING OUT OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE. THESE ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS COMING OUT OF
THE- DUNGEON THIS CRAP TASK
FORCE WHICH IS STATUTORILY
MANDATED ORGANIZATION DEALING
WITH ISSUE RES ISSUES AROUND
THE CRAB FISHERY. THIS HAS
BROAD SUPPORT FROM BOTH THE
FISHING INDUSTRY AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHTY.
THANK YOU MR STONE SENIOR
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE ITEM PARK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THOSE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING CALENDAR VOTE I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THE BILL IS PASSED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENCE
ITEMS THIS IS THE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE. ONE THIRTEEN. AB THREE
SIXTY SIX PARTNERING. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND OTHERS BACK IN THE FALL SO
YOU NEVER REALLY IN THE OPEN
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB THREE SIXTY SIX
ADDRESSES SHORTCOMINGS
REGARDING SIBLING PLACEMENTS
WITHIN OUR FOSTER YOU SYSTEM AB
THREE SIXTY SIX STRENGTHENS
EXISTING PROTECTIONS IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM ASSURING SIBLINGS
ARE PLACED TOGETHER UNLESS
THERE IS A SHOWING THE
PLACEMENT WOULD BE CONTRARY TO
THE WELL BEING AND SAFETY OF
ANY SIBLING. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS LONG PRIORITIZED THE CARE
OF YOUTH IN OUR FOSTER SYSTEM
AND THIS MEASURE WILL REFLECT
THIS THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS BEEN CAREFULLY CRAFTED
WITH THE INPUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RUBIO JEAN
NOEL MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS
HER BABY ITEM PARK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL. CALL NUMBER VOTE THE
DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
BECAUSE I HEARD A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO THE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO. SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONFIRMED IN. NEXT WE'LL MOVE
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS
IS AB FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE
KERKORIAN. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS IMMACULATE IN THE
HEALING ARTS SUMMER LOW EVEN
OPEN. YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE IS OUR
SENSE THAT BILL FOR THE BORDER
PHARMACY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR LOW SEEING
NO MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS
OR DEBATE THE ITEM PARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE. THE PARK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE I SEVENTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE MEMBERS
ARE CONCERNED.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP A FEW
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. ALASKA
YOU. EITHERTAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TEMPORARILY TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF.
FOR
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER-SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSET WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ONE OF OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA
STATE REPUBLICAN ASSEMBLYMEN.
DOWNLOAD WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JULY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ONE OF OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA
STATE REPUBLICAN ASSEMBLYMAN
DAN LOVE WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JULY TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WAS A TWO TERM YUBA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND ONE
ELECTION OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. IN
THE ASSEMBLY LOK SERVED AS THE
CHIEF WHIP FOR THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS. WHEN HE WAS APPOINTED
THE CHAIR OF THE CAUCUS TASK
FORCE ON JOBS AND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. HE ORGANIZED THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY GROUP WHICH
MET REGULARLY WITH BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL
SECTORS OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. TO DISCUSS WAYS TO
ELIMINATE IMPEDIMENTS AND
RESTRICTIVE GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
THE STATE'S BUSINESS CLIMATE.
HE FAMOUSLY LED A GROUP OF OUR
COLLEAGUES OUT TO TEXAS- AND
BROUGHT ALONG WITH HIM- THEN
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM. THE NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF INDEPENDENT BUSINESS AWARDED
LOK A PERFECT SCORE BASED ON
HIS VOTING RECORD IN SUPPORT OF
SMALL BUSINESS. LOGO'S THE YOLO
COUNTY CHAIRMAN FOR RONALD
REAGAN'S NINETEEN EIGHTY
CAMPAIGN. AND THEYUBA COUNTY
CHAIRMAN FOR GEORGE W. BUSH'S
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR CAMPAIGN.
HE ALSO HEADED UP IN WAS A KEY
PART OF ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER'S
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
GUBERNATORIAL CAMPAIGN SO WAS
VERY INVOLVED IN AS- YOU KNOW
ALWAYS A- BARNSTORMING
CAMPAIGNER. FOR OUR FOR OUR
CAUSES. BUT HE WAS VERY FOCUSED
ON OUR COMMUNITY. HE WAS THE
FOUNDER OF OUR FOR FLOOD
CONTROL FOR YUBA SUTTER
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE- HE
WAS A MEMBER- IN OUR COMMUNITY
HAVE HAD ENOUGH- MEMORIAL FUND
TO ENSURE THAT WE WOULD HAVE
VETERANS MEMORIALS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN DOING THAT HE
WAS ALWAYS. FIGHTING FOR.
VETERANS AND ENSURING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY RECOGNIZE THEIR GREAT
SACRIFICE. OF I CAN RECALL WHEN
DAN. ACTUALLY SHUT DOWN AN
ENTIRE THEATER READ IT FOR THE
NIGHT TO SHOW A SHOWING AFTER
THE COMMUNITY OF SAVING PRIVATE
RYAN- HE WAS ALSO INSTRUMENTAL
IN BRINGING WALMART- TO LINDA-
WHEN HE WAS YUBA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND ALWAYS VERY
FOCUSED ON. BRINGING JOBS AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES- TO HIS
DISTRICT TO HIS AREA. HE WAS
MOST PROUD OF HIS INVOLVEMENT
IN THE ADVANCEMENT OF
TELEHEALTH MEDICINE. AND HE
AUTHORED AB FOURTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE AND HE HAD
NO IDEA HOW GREATLY IT WOULD BE
NEEDED THEN SO MANY WE'VE
CONTINUED THAT WORK- IN THIS
BODY. THERE WAS ALSO A MAN OF
GREAT FAITH AND HE WOULD ALWAYS.
REMIND US TO GIVE GOD THE GLORY.
THAT WE DO THE WE DO THE WORK
BUT GIVE TO BUT TO GIVE GOD THE
GLORY FOR ALL THAT WE HAVE. HE
GRADUATED FROM THE OKLAHOMA
MILITARY ACADEMY AND HAD AN A
FROM YUBA COLLEGE AND A BA FROM
CHICO STATE UNIVERSITY. AS MANY
KNOW HE OWNED HIS OWN REALTY
FIRM LOW REALTY. I WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN THAT AND SO MANY
STORIES THAT I'VE HEARD- IN THE
WEEKS SINCE DAN'S DEATH OF
PEOPLE WHO SAID THAT OUT OF NOR
WILL GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
GIVE THEM A JOB- FOUNTAIN YOU.
MADE A REFERENCE FOR THEM- THAT
NOBODY EVER KNEW ABOUT- DAMAGE
TO SOMEBODY WHO HE REALLY
WANTED TO DO RIGHT BY PEOPLE
WHO WANTED TO HELP PEOPLE AND
THAT'S WHY I GOT INVOLVED IN
POLITICS- HE WAS BORN IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
DANIELS CHARLES AND KATE CONNOR
LOVE. AND HE WAS DELIVERED
ACTUALLY BY HIS UNCLE DR
RUSSELL MERIT. AND HE WAS ABLE
TO PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY AT
HIS HOME ON JULY TWENTY SECOND
WITH HIS WIFE PEGGY. WHO IS
ALWAYS BY HIS SIDE AND WAS BY
HIS SIDE ONCE AGAIN- ON THAT
DAY. ONE OF HIS- GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT HE WOULD SAY WAS
MERION PEGGY- IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX. SO DAN AI
DECISIVELY REMEMBER HIS LEGACY
HE WAS ALWAYS A FIGHTER- HE WAS
SOMEONE WHO- FIERCELY ADVOCATED
FOR HIS COMMUNITY. AND HE WAS
SOMEONE WHO WAS ALWAYS LOOKING
TO FIND A WAY. TO FIND A
PATHWAY. ANY WILL WORK ACROSS
THE AISLE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
AS A SAID- DOING A BIPARTISAN.
A TRIP TO TEXAS. LOOKING TO
FIND DIFFERENT WAYS TO IMPROVE
OUR BUSINESS ECONOMY. AND SO I
ASKED MEMBERS. THAT TWEET CLOSE
IN MEMORY OF OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMAN DOWNLOAD.
THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER.
DECEMBER FRIEDMAN YOUR
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS YOU KNOW
WE UNFORTUNATELY OFTEN RISE IN
THESE CHAMBERS TO MEMORIALIZE
AND TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITY- BUT
TODAY I HAVE THE SAID
RESPONSIBILITY TO NOT JUST DO
THAT BUT TO ALSO TALK ABOUT
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN FOR MANY
YEARS A CLOSE AND PERSONAL
FRIEND OF MYSELF AND MY FAMILY.
ARTHUR CHARLES CHARLES DEVINE
WAS BORN IN LOS ANGELES. HE
GRADUATED FROM UC BERKELEY WITH
ABOUT A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE IN CIVIL ENGINEERING AND
RECEIVED A MASTER OF PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION. FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. HE WAS A STATE
LICENSE CIVIL STRUCTURAL AND
FIRE PROTECTION ENGINEER AND
DURING HIS THIRTY SIX YEAR
CAREER WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF BUILDING
AND SAFETY. HE HELD VARIOUS
POSITIONS INCLUDING CHIEF OF
EARTHQUAKE SAFETY DIVISION
CHIEF INSPECTOR BUREAU AND
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. DURING THIS
TIME HE MET AND MARRIED PAULA
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE AND THEY
SHARED A- REALLY BEAUTIFUL LIFE
TOGETHER A LIFE THAT. I HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO INTERACT
WITH MANY MANY TIMES OVER THE
YEARS. SINCE HIS RETIREMENT IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN ART
VOLUNTEERED IN NUMEROUS PLACES.
WITH THE GOAL OF GETTING BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY YOU KNOW WE
ALL HAVE PEOPLE LIKE THIS IN
OUR COMMUNITY PEOPLE THAT WHEN
THERE'S A BOARD OF A NONPROFIT
YOU KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE ON
IT. WHEN THERE'S A BIG
IMPORTANT FUNDRAISER FOR GOOD
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY'RE GOING
TO BE AT THE HEAD OF IT YOU
KNOW THAT THEY WILL OVER AND
OVER AGAIN ALWAYS OPEN THEIR
HOME. TO INVITE IN COMMUNITY
GROUPS TO HOLD FUND RAISERS
THEY'LL BE THE PERSON THAT'S
COOKING THE FOOD OR STANDING IN
LINE. ART WAS DEFINITELY ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE HE HAD A LOVE OF
ANIMALS AND HE VOLUNTEERED AT
THE WHITE WILDLIFE WAY STATION.
HE VOLUNTEERED AS AN ARBITRATOR
FOR THE BETTER BUSINESS BUREAU
SERVED AS AN OMBUDSMAN AT CBS
TELEVISION ENTERED THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES IS UNITED WAY
CAMPAIGN. HE WAS A MEMBER OF
THE GLENDALE FIRE FOUNDATION AS
WELL AS THE GLENDALE POLICE
FOUNDATION WHERE HE RECEIVED
THE FIRST VOLUNTEER OF THE WORD
OF THE YEAR AWARD FOR HIS
SERVICES. HE CONTINUED TO SERVE
THE GLENDALE COMMUNITY ON
VARIOUS BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
I DON'T REMEMBER A TIME WHEN HE
WASN'T INVOLVED AS A BOARD OR
COMMISSIONER. HE SERVED ON THE
GLENDALE BOARD OF ZONING
APPEALS THE CONDO BUILDING AND
FIRE BOARD OF APPEALS AND THE
CIVIL SERVICE COMMISSION. ON
WHICH HE SERVED FOR TWELVE
YEARS. I MET HIM BECAUSE WHEN I
WAS SERVING ON THE DESIGN
REVIEW BOARD OR MAYBE EVEN
BEFORE THAT IN GLENDALE. HE
TOOK ME UNDER HIS WING AND IT
WAS REALLY A MENTOR FOR ME AND
ALWAYS TALK TO ME AND MADE
HIMSELF AVAILABLE ABOUT HOW THE
CITY WORKED. AT ABOUT POLICY.
ANY PUSH ME TO RUN FOR GLENDALE
CITY COUNCIL FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE. AND BOTH
HE AND HIS WIFE PAULA LITERALLY
AT AT THE KITCHEN TABLE. AT
SOMEONE'S HOUSE AND LICKED
ENVELOPES FOR HOURS AND HOURS
AND HOURS I THINK THEY MAY HAVE
ACTUALLY USE ONE OF THOSE
LITTLE SPONGE THINGS. BUT THEY
DID THAT. THAT PHYSICAL WORK
AND SWEAT EQUITY. TO HELP
SUPPORT ME- IN IN MY GOALS- AND
ALWAYS WITH AN EYE TOWARDS
DOING WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS
BEST FOR OUR CITY. ARTS SAID
THAT HIS VOLUNTEER WORK. TOOK
SO MUCH OF HIS TIME BECAUSE IF
HE QUOTED. HIS IS A QUOTE FROM
HIM THERE'S NOTHING MORE
REWARDING AND GRATIFYING THAT
KNOWING YOU'RE HELPING PEOPLE
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE BY
GIVING YOUR TIME AND RESOURCES.
WITHOUT WANTING EXPECTING OR
RECEIVING ANYTHING IN RETURN.
AND THIS WAS A PERSON WHO NEVER
SOUGHT OUT ACCOLADES. YOU NEVER
SAW HIM SAY WELL MAYBE I SHOULD
BE RECOGNIZED IN FACT HE WAS
MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE BEING THE
ONE. GIVING THE RECOGNITIONS.
ASIDE FROM SPENDING THEIR TIME
VOLUNTEERING- IMPALA TRAVELED
EXTENSIVELY TO ALL CORNERS OF
THE WORLD. SPENDING ALMOST
EVERY CONTINENT. THE TRAVELS OF
TAKING THEM FROM CAT MAN TO
BALI. FROM SHANGHAI TO RWANDA
FROM CREATES ARMENIA. AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN. THEY
ALSO HOSTED THESE WONDERFUL
SLIDE SHOWS WE WOULD INVITE
PEOPLE IN TO SEE. PICTURES OF
THE WORLDWIDE TRAVELS. ART WAS
ALSO SOMEONE WHO WAS INCREDIBLY
WARM AND GENEROUS. HE NEVER HAD
A BAD WORD TO SAY ABOUT ANYBODY
EVEN WHEN THEY WERE ACTING
BADLY. HE JUST IGNORE THAT AND
FOCUS ON WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS
GOOD. HE WAS THE EPITOME OF
POSITIVITY. AND HE HAD A GLOW
IN A LIGHT ABOUT HIM THAT I
WILL NEVER FORGET. ART
ALONGSIDE HIS PARTNER PAULA WAS
A FIXTURE IN THE GLENDALE
COMMUNITY AND WE ARE STILL IN
SHOCK THAT HE HAS LEFT US SO
SOON. THEY DEDICATED THEIR
LIVES TO IMPROVING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR EVERYONE. EVERYBODY
KNOWS OF THE THING HE CARED
ABOUT MOST IN THE WORLD WITH
HIS WIFE PAULA. HE WAS HIS ROCK
HE SUPPORTED HER THROUGH ALL OF
HER OWN VOLUNTEER EFFORTS. AS
WELL AS HER SUCCESSFUL CAMPAIGN
TO SERVE ON THE GLENDALE CITY
COUNCIL WHERE SHE NOW SERVES
THE COMMUNITY AS OUR MAYOR. HE
LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK A MARK
ON GLENDALE. ON ON ME
PERSONALLY AND MY FAMILY- HE
WILL BE MISSED AND HE WILL
ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED AND LOVED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU FRIEDMAN. SELLER GIVEN YOUR
RECOGNIZE YOUR JUST FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RISE AND **** BODY TO
ADJOURN. IN THE MEMORY OF
MICHAEL KENNETH WILLIAMS WHO
PASSED AWAY ON SEPTEMBER THE
SIX AT THE HUMBLE AGE OF FIFTY
FOUR YEARS OF AGE MICHAEL WAS
BORN ON NOVEMBER THE TWENTY
SECOND NINETEEN SIXTY SIX IN
BROOKLYN NEW YORK. FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE CALL THEM BIG MIKE
OR MIKE WAS A FRIEND OF MINE-
THE BROTHER TO COMPTON'S OF
MAYOR PRO TEM MICHELE CHAMBERS.
WHO ALSO WORKED. IN MY DISTRICT
OFFICE FOR MANY YEARS. MICHAEL
AS AN EMMY NOMINEE AND- ACTOR
PRODUCER THE LAST SERVICE- YOU
MAY KNOW HIM AS- MIKE YOU MAY
KNOW MICHAEL AS ALL MARKET
LITTLE FROM THE HBO. SHOW THE
WIRE- ALBERT IN THE WHITE
BOARDWALK EMPIRE AMONG OTHER
MANY ROLES THAT HE SERVED
THROUGH. THROUGH ALL HIS WORK
MICHAEL STILL FOUND TIME TO
WORK WITH ME ON THE COMPTON
YOUTH DIALOGUE PROJECTS AND
PANELS AS AT AT THE HOST THERE
ARE HOSTED AT COMPTON- HIGH
SCHOOL- TO ENGAGE YOUTH IN
HELPING AND WORKING FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF THEIR COMMUNITY
MICHAEL IS A GRACIOUS AND KIND
INDIVIDUAL. HE WAS A FORCE OF
NATURE ON THIS ON THE SCREEN AS
WELL AS A GENTLE SOUL IN LIFE
WHO WILL BE GREATLY MISSED MY
HEART IS HEAVY FOR THE
TREMENDOUS TALENT THAT HAS BEEN
LOST HIS FOCUS MISS HIS SPIRIT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MOURN
THE PASSING OF THIS GIANT I MET
HIM. MANY YEARS AGO- AND AXEL
LUTE LY AND MIRED HIM FOR BEING
ON THE SCREEN DOING WORK IN
THAT IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ROLES WITH HBO- I FIRST MET HIM
AT CHURCH WHERE MACHEL THE
COUNCILWOMAN FROM COMPTON-
DECIDED TO HAVE HIM ROLL WITH
ME WHEN I WAS RUNNING FOR
ELECTION IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND HE'S STILL WITH ME
AND MANY MANY CHURCHES- HE'D
HAVE TO DO THAT BUT I
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE HIM
TAKING TIME. OUT OF HIS BUSY
SCHEDULE AND PEOPLE WERE SO IT
MIRED BY HIS WORK AND GIVING
EVEN THOUGH HE READ SOME KIND
OF A STATUS IN HOLLYWOOD HE
NEVER. FAILED TO REMEMBER THE
COMMUNITY THAT RAISED HIM
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY. OF
MICHAEL K. WILLIAMS. THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRAIG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. ASKED WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY THIS AFTERNOON OF
MRS DONNA CANNELLA. MRS
CANNELLA THE MOTHER OF FORMER
STATE SENATOR ANTHONY CANNELLA.
THE WIFE OF OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAL
CANNELLA. IS MY DISTINCT
PRIVILEGE TO STAND HERE TODAY
AND RECOGNIZE MRS CANNELLA. AND
HER CONTRIBUTIONS TO BOTH. OUR
COMMUNITY AND HER FAMILY. THE
CANNELLA FAMILY OR PERSONAL
FRIENDS OF MINE AND- TO MANY
OTHERS IN THIS INSTITUTION.
DONNA AND SAU CANNELLA WERE
MARRIED FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS
AND THEY RAISED THEIR FAMILY IN
CERES CALIFORNIA. MOTHER OF
THREE NICOLE ANTHONY AND
VINCENT DONNA WAS A STAPLE IN
EACH OF OUR CHILDREN SCHOOL
SPORTING EVENTS AND LYFT
MOMENTS. DOMINANCE ALL CANNELLA
LIVE THEIR LIFE BY EXAMPLE. SAU
WAS ELECTED TO SERVE THE CITY
OF SERIES IS BOTH A COUNCIL
MEMBER THAN THE MAYOR IT WAS
DONNA WHO LOOKED AFTER THE
FAMILY INTERESTS AND ACTIVITIES.
WHEN MAYOR CANNELLA WAS ELECTED
TO SERVICES STANISLAUS COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS DISTRICT
FIVE DONNA CONTINUED TO WORK.
TO ENSURE TAT THE FAMILY AND
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE RECEIVE
THE CARE AND THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEEDED. DONNA WORKED
OUTSIDE THE HOME IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY AND WAS A
GREAT RESOURCE TO THE COMMUNITY
IN ENSURING THAT PEOPLE
RECEIVED CARE AND SERVICES. AS
THE CANNELLA FAMILY EXPANDED.
THEY WALK IN THE NUMBER OF
GRANDCHILDREN WHO DON I WAS SO
PROUD. DONNA'S GENTLE WAYS AND
QUIET DEMEANOR. ALWAYS COULD BE
COUNTED ON FOR NOT JUST HER
FAMILY BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. PEOPLE FELT THEY
COULD TALK TO DON AND SHE WOULD
BE THE LISTENING EAR AND A
COMFORTING HUG THAT THEY NEED.
SHE HAD A GREAT SMILE ON A
WINNING PERSONALITY SHE PUT
OTHERS AT EASE AND WILL SURELY
THE GREATEST ASSET. IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CANALIS CAREER AN
INCREDIBLE ASSET TO MY
COMMUNITY- THE COMMUNITY IN
SERIES AND MADE SO MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO THE STATE.
SHE WILL BE MISSED AND ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN HER MEMORY
THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU MR
GRAHAM. AND YOU'RE ALSO
RECOGNIZE YOUR DOES FOR YOUR
SECOND TERM MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS IT IS
WITH GREAT SORROW. THE TODAY
WITH GERMAN IN THE MEMORY OF A
TRUE GIANT IN THE LONG
COMMUNITY. IN MERCED AND AROUND
THE WORLD. WITH THE PASSING OF
JEAN LOWER ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH
AND IRREPLACEABLE CULTURAL AND
EDUCATIONAL LEADER HAS BEEN
LOST. TAUNGOO MOVIE A LATER
KNOWN AS GENE MOORE WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN FORTY IN THE KINGDOM
OF LOS. HE WENT ON TO BECOME
THE FIRST EVER LONG
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
CHEN GUANG PROVINCE IN THE
FIRST LEADER TO BRING FORMAL
EDUCATION TO THE LONG. AND
OTHER ETHNIC MINORITIES IN THE
MOUNTAINS OF LOS. HIS OWN
EDUCATION TO COME TO FRANCE
THAILAND SINGAPORE. AND BEYOND.
THAT IS LEADERSHIP HELD SPECIAL
IMPORTANCE BECAUSE OF THE
SUCCESS IN REBUILDING A SCHOOL
SYSTEM THAT HAD BEEN PARALYZED
BY WAR. IT BEARS MENTIONING
THAT THESE EFFORTS WERE TO THE
BENEFIT PROTECT MINORITIES WHO
ARE FIGHTING AGAINST THE
COMMUNIST DURING A PARTICULARLY
VIOLENT PERIOD. THIS WAS A
FULFILLMENT OF HIS PERSONAL
MODEL IF THE MOUNTAIN TRIBES
CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL. SCHOOLS
MUST GO TO THE MOUNTAIN TRIBES.
WE'LL IS PASSION FOR EDUCATION
EVEN WENT BEYOND SETTING UP
SCHOOLS AS HE CONSTANTLY
DESIRED TO IMPROVE THEM AND TO
CREATE AN EDUCATION SYSTEM
EQUAL TO THAT OF OTHER
SOCIETIES AROUND THE WORLD. THE
QUEST REPEATEDLY TOOK HIM
OVERSEAS IN SEARCH OF BETTER
TEACHING METHODS. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE ONSPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT THROUGH THE U. S.
STATE DEPARTMENT HE TRAVELED TO
THIRTY THREE STATES AND GATHER
IDEAS ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM FOR THE
ETHNIC MINORITY STUDENTS IN
LAOS HE ALSO TRAVELED TO
SINGAPORE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THEIR SYSTEMIC
APPROACH TO EDUCATION. MOLY IS
CARING RELATIONSHIP WITH
STUDENTS PARENTS COMMUNITIES
AND COLLEAGUES. AS WELL AS HIS
EXCEPTIONAL TEACHING SKILLS LED
HIM FROM. NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
TO NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AS
ASSISTANT SUPERNTENDENT
PRIMARY SCHOOLS. HE THEN SERVED
AS SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
FROM. NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. AS
SUPERINTENDENT HE HELPED
REALIZE LISLE EDUCATION REFORM.
BY BUILDING MORE SCHOOLS
TRAINING MORE TEACHERS AND
PROVIDING BETTER INSTRUCTIONAL
TOOLS AND SUPPLIES. AFTER THE
FALL OF LAWS TO COMMUNIST
BACKED OUT THE LOWER NORTH
VIETNAMESE ARMY FORCES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
AS FAMILY RECEIVED POLITICAL
ASYLUM AND TOOK REFUGE IN
FRANCE WHERE HE LIVED AND
WORKED FOR FIFTEEN YEARS. IN
NINETEEN NINETY HE MOVED HIS
FAMILY TO THE UNITED STATES AND
SETTLED IN MERCED CALIFORNIA
WHERE HE SERVED AS THE
COMMUNITY OUTREACH SPECIALIST
IN THE MERCED CITY SCHOOL
DISTRICT. HIS WORK THERE
ASSISTED THE MALL AND ALLOW
COMMUNITIES FOR THE NEXT
FIFTEEN YEARS. HE RETIRED IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE TO CONTINUE
TO ASPIRE TO GREATER
FULFILLMENT BY WORKING ON
PROJECTS SUCH AS HIS MEMOIRS
WHICH IS SOON TO BE PUBLISHED.
JEANNE MOE ARE MORALLY WAS
ACCORDED SPECIAL RECOGNITION
WITHIN THE MON COMMITTEE FOR
HIS MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
DEEPLY APPRECIATED THROUGHOUT
MERCED. HIS FAVORITE MON
PROVERB WAS EVERYTHING IS
ACCOMPLISHED BY HARD WORK. NOT
BY WIZARDRY. AND HE CERTAINLY
LIVED BY THAT. HE IS SURVIVED
HONORED AND CELEBRATED BY HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS INCLUDING
SIXTEEN GRANDCHILDREN AND FOUR
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. PLEASE
JOIN ME THIS AFTERNOON
ADJOURNING IN HIS MEMORY OF
THIS BRAVE AND KIND HERO TO SO
MANY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER GRANT MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DUSTY
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
VOTING. THANK YOU- WHEN. AB
EIGHT SIXTEEN NO TO NOT VOTING.
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TWIN
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTEEN NO
TO NOT VOTING. WHEN AB ONE FIVE
THREE SIX I TO NOT VOTING PRO
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX I TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS WE
WILL BE RESUMING WHAT THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
MEMBERS WILL BE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN THIS IS SB SIXTY
THREE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL SIXTY THREE BY CENTER
STERN AND OTHERS NATALIE THE
FIRE PREVENTION A SUMMER
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT
THIS EXCELLENT BILL. SB SIXTY
THREE IS A RE INTRODUCTION OF
LAST YEAR'S SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD NOT RECEIVE A
VOTE ON THE FINAL THE RECESSION
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO RISE. AS THE
TWENTY TWENTY FIRE SEASON
HIGHLIGHTED CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG PATH TO FORCE IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE FIRE RESILIENCY
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
REDUCING RISK FOR HOMES AND
STRUCTURES AND PROTECTING OUR
NATURAL LANDS. THIS BILL TAKES
SEVERAL STEPS IN THAT DIRECTION
BY ENGAGING WITH COMMUNITIES
FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
COMMUNITY HARDENING WHILE ALSO
ENHANCING BUILDING STANDARDS IN
THE AREAS OF THE HIGHEST BUYER
WRIST IN THE STATE. SB SIXTY
THREE WILL MOBILIZE MORE PEOPLE
IN THE EFFORT TO BRING DOWN
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE RISK BY
EMPOWERING LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
TO TRAIN VOLUNTEERS IN FIRE
PREVENTION EFFORTS. COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS WILL
BE ELIGIBLE FOR FIRE PROTECTION
GRANTS TO HELP WITH THE FESTIVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ASSESSMENTS
FOR RESIDENTS AND TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAINTAINING AND CREATING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND THEIR
STRUCTURES. THE GRANTS WILL
ALSO EXPANDED FENCIBLE SPACE TO
INCLUDE ROADWAYS AND DRIVEWAYS
TO ALLOW FOR BETTER INGRESS
EGRESS AND ACCESS FOR EMERGENCY
VEHICLES AN EVACUATION. THIS
BILL ALSO APPLIES FIRE SAFETY
BUILDING STANDARDS BE ON THE
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES IN THE LOCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AREA TO ALSO
INCLUDE THE HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
SOON WITH AN OPTION TO EXTEND
THEM INTO THE MODERATE FIRE
HAZARDSEVERITY ZONES WHERE
APPROPRIATE. NOT ONLY IS THIS
THE SAFEST OPTION THIS IS A
GOOD FINANCIAL DECISION FOR
COMMUNITIES A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN HEADWATERS ECONOMICS
REPORT FOUND NEGLIGIBLE COST
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN A TYPICAL
HOME AND HOME CONSTRUCTED USING
WILD FIRE RESISTANT MATERIALS
AND DESIGN FEATURES. HOWEVER AS
WE ALL NO. THE DIFFERENCE THE
SAVING THOSE FEW PENNIES WOULD
MAKE SUCH A HUGE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A HOUSE STANDING OR NOT
STANDING. THE COST OF A LOT OF
LETTER OF COURSE IS
ASTRONOMICALLY HIGHER. DECADES
OF RESEARCH AND POST FIRE
ASSESSMENT TO PROVIDE A CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT BUILDING
MATERIALS AND DESIGN. COUPLED
WITH LANDSCAPING ON THE
PROPERTY OR SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT FACTORS. INFLUENCING
WHETHER IT'S STRUCTURE SURVIVES
OF WILDFIRE OR IS LOST. SB
SIXTY THREE HAS THE SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS OF CALIFORNIA AND
MORE. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN
THE SEVEN MEMBER COOLEY
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I'M VERY
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT. THE IMPORTANCE AND
TIMELINESS OF THIS. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT SENATOR DARRELL
STEINBERG. AUTHORED SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES BILL. WHICH REQUIRE
ALL COUNTIES THE STATE TO
IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE THEY
PROJECTED GROWTH IN THE FUTURE.
FOR EXAMPLE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THE PLAN ENVISIONS
GROWTH OUT IN THE SOUTHEAST
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
EIGHT MY DISTRICT ALONG THE
JACKSON HIGHWAY HEADED TOWARDS
AMADOR. COUNTY THIS IS ACTUALLY
A GREAT OPEN AREA WHERE GROWTH.
WILL BE COMPACT THAT THAT'S
SORT OF THE VISION AND THEN
IT'S AN ERROR THIS LIMITED BY
NUMBER RIVERS A RUN THROUGH
THEIR- BY A LACK OF DEVELOPED
AREAS. TO VERY CRITICAL
PATHWAYS FOR EXAMPLE JACKSON
HIGHWAY HAS A HUGE BOTTLENECK
JUSTICE OF A LARGE- KNOWS
RANCHO MURIETA. SOLD THE POINT
IS ALL AROUND CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE GALVANIZED TO COUNTIES TO
ENVISION THEIR GROWTH PATTERNS
AND THOSE AREAS MAY NOT
ACTUALLY BE IDEAL FROM A FIRE
EGRESS EMERGENCY EGRESS
STANDPOINTS WILL BILL LIKE
THIS. IS SOMETHING I BELIEVE IT
WILL HELP COUNTIES COMMUNITIES
DEAL WITH A FIRE RISK NOT JUST
NOW BUT AS THEY GROW UNDER
SMETHING LIKE THE SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE CLIMATE.
SUSTAINABLE COMMITTEES PLAN SO
I THINK IT IS A VERY TIMELY
MEASURE I FEEL A DOUBLE TAILS
WITH IMPORTANT ISSUES. THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT FOR A LONG
TIME AND I BELIEVE WILL HELP
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THE EIGHT
DAY D. DEAL WITH THEIR FIRE
RISKS HIGHER JULY VOTE. THANK
YOU MR COOLEY. SEEING NO
MEMBERS WISHING TO FURTHER
DISCUSS ARE TO BE THIS ITEM NO
FURTHER COMMENT FROM MR
FRIEDMAN THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE CALL NUMBER OF. FIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WE'LL CLOSE THE
ROLLING CALENDAR I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO THE BILL IS PASSED. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THIS IS SB NINETY
EIGHT CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL NINETY EIGHT BY SENATE
MCGUIRE AND OTHERS MAGNITUDE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY THE SELLER MAKES
YOUR RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
NINETY EIGHT THE FREEDOM OF
PRESS ACT ON BEHALF OF CENTER
MCGUIRE AND IS A CO AUTHOR.
FRIEDMAN PRESS IS ONE OF THE
MOST- FOUNDATIONAL COMPONENTS
OF OUR DEMOCRACY IT'S WHAT IN
MANY PLACES SETS US ASIDE AS A
COUNTRY. WE ALL BENEFIT FROM
THIS FREEDOM IT HELPS TO INFORM
OUR DECISIONS IT ALSO KEEPS
PEOPLE LIKE US AND CHECK KEEP
THEIR GOVERNMENT IN CHECK INTO
SOME OF THE STUFF LIKE THAT
SOMETIMES BUT- I VALUE THAT I
KNOW ALL OF YOU VALUE THAT. AND
IT HELPS ULTIMATELY STRENGTHEN
OUR DEMOCRACY. HAVING SAID THAT
THERE ARE SOME CRACKS. WITHIN
THIS FRIEDMAN SB NINETY EIGHT
WILL HELP STRENGTHEN AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO KNOW. LAST
YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY THEY'RE
OVER SIX HUNDRED INCIDENCES
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY MANY OF
WHICH WERE IN CALIFORNIA OF
PRESS BEING DETAINED OR INJURED
WHILE COVERING OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT PROTESTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS. MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS RISK THEIR PERSONAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY EACH TIME
THEY ATTEND A PROTEST RALLY TO
GET THE PUBLIC THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED. AND DESERVE.
CALIFORNIA MOSTLY THE WAY TO
ENSURE THE RIGHT OF THE PRESS
RIGHT OF THE PRESS AND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ARE PROTECTED.
AND HELD TO THE HIGHEST
STANDARD. CURRENTLY IN STATE
LAW REPORTERS ARE GRANTED
AUTHORITY TO ENTER AREAS CLOSE
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT DURING
NATURAL DISASTERS. LIKE FIRES
FLOODS AND EARTHQUAKES. IN
ORDER TO GATHER THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED TO RELATE TO THE
PUBLIC. THEY CAN ALSO GO OUT
DURING CURFEWS AT TIMES OF
NATIONAL DISASTERS. THESE
PROTECTIONS HOWEVER DO NOT
EXPRESSLY EXTEND A FIRST
AMENDMENT DEMONSTRATIONS SUCH
AS MARCHES RALLIES AND
PROTESTS. SB NINETY EIGHT
EXTENDS CRUCIAL PROTECTIONS TO
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS AS THEY
ENTER IN REPORT ON EVENTS
PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. ADDITIONALLY SB
NINETY EIGHT ALLOWS REPORTERS
THE CHANCE TO CHALLENGE THEIR
DETAINMENT OR LACK OF ACCESS BY
WORKING WITH MANAGEMENT ON THE
SCENE. THIS LANGUAGE PROVIDES
THE NECESSARY SAFETY NET TO
REPORTERS WHO WERE NOT GRANTED
ACCESS INTENSELY DETAINED OR
MISTAKENLY DETAINED. I WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS.
THAT I'M SURE SOME OF YOU HAVE
HEARD WITH REGARD TO COMMAND
POSTS. THERE'S NO EXPECTATION
TODAY IN STATE LAW WHEN A
MEMBER OF THE PRESS OR MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC WALKS INTO A
POLICE STATION. THAT THEY WOULD
BE GIVEN UNFETTERED ACCESS OF
COURSE THEY WOULD NOT. THIS
BILL MIRRORS THE SAME ACCESS
THAT EXIST IN STATE LAW FOR
NATURAL DISASTERS. MEMBERS OF
pUNFETTERED ACCESS TO A MOBILE
COMMAND POST UNITS UNDER THIS
BILL. THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN
SEVERAL MOMENTS TO MAKE THIS
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR. SB NINETY
EIGHT REPRESENTS A MULTI YEAR
EFFORT AND THE AUTHOR HAS MADE
MANY AMENDMENTS TO THIS YEAR'S
BILL IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED. BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THIS BILL IS A
MUCH MORE REFINED AND WORKABLE
VERSION OF ANOTHER BILL WHICH
PASSED THIS HOUSE LAST YEAR. SB
NINETY EIGHT WILL ENSURE THE
JOURNALISTS ABILITY TO PERFORM
THEIR CRITICAL ROLE OF
DOCUMENTING HISTORY INFORMING
THE PUBLIC IS PROTECTED. AS
THEY ATTEND THESE
DEMONSTRATIONS MARCHES PROTESTS
AND RALLIES. THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER
ASSOCIATION. ETHNIC MEDIA
SERVICES. THE REPORTER
COMMITTEE AND THE ACLU AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS.
SCENE NO MEMBERS WISHING TO
DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE ITEM THE
PARK WILL OPEN ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO GO. ALL THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO MOVE. ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
HARPAL
CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES
IS FORTY TWO NUMBER SIXTEEN.
THE BILL IS PASSED. WE WILL
MOVE AHEAD TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO THIS IS SB THREE
EIGHTY CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY BY CENTER
EGGMAN AND OTHERS NATALIE TO
END OF LIFE DECEMBER WOULD YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER REMEMBER TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP THREE EIGHTY A
BILL THAT MAKES IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO THE END OF LIFE
ACTION OPTION ACT. WHICH HAS
BEEN AVAILABLE TO DYING
PATIENTS SINCE JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. SENATOR
EGGMAN HELD TWO OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS ON THE ACT AND THROUGH
THOSE HEARINGS WHICH INCLUDED
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
HOSPITALS PROVIDERS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. A.
B. CLAIM CLEAR THAT SOME WELL
INTENTIONED ASPECTS OF THE LAW
SERVE AS BARRIERS FOR
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS WHO
SEEK AID IN DYING. SB THREE
EIGHTY MAKES THE FOLLOWING
CHANGES TO THE END OF LIFE
OPTION ACT. A KAISER PERMANENTE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SERVICE
SURVEY REVEALS THAT ONE THIRD
OF TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS DIED
BEFORE COMPLETING THECURRENT
TIME CONSUMING PROCESS. THIS
BILL REDUCES THE MANDATORY
FIFTEEN DAY WAITING PERIOD
BETWEEN TWO OR WITH QUEST FOR
AID IN DYING MEDICATION TO
FORTY EIGHT HOURS FOR ALL
ELIGIBLE PATIENTS. ELIMINATES
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE FINAL
ATTESTATION. THE FORMER BE
GIVEN TO THE PATIENT BY THEIR
ATTENDING PHYSICIAN WITH
INSTRUCTIONS TO COMPLETE IT
WITHIN THE FORTY EIGHT HOURS
PRIOR TO SELF ADMINISTERING AND
ADMINISTERING THE AID IN TRYING
TO FIND MEDICATIONS. TERMINALLY
ILL PATIENTS WHO ARE NEARING
DEATH HAVE ALREADY BEEN
EVALUATED BY TWO PHYSICIANS
ABOUT THEIR MENTAL CAPACITY TO
MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS. PLACE
TWO ORAL REQUESTS AND ONE
WRITTEN REQUEST WHICH IS
WITNESSED BY TWO INDIVIDUALS.
THIS FOURTH REQUEST WAS
REDUNDANT. THE BILL EXTENDS
THIS THE SUNSET TO JANUARY
TWELFTH AT WORK FIRST TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTY ONE. DATA
COLLECTED UNDER THE LAW- BY
CDPH TELLS US THAT MORE THAN
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED TERMINALLY
ILL INDIVIDUALS RECEIVED A
PRESCRIPTION FOR AID IN DYING
MEDICATION SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. OF THOSE MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DIED FROM
INGESTING THE MEDICATIONS.
MEMBERS THAT MEANS THAT TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WERE
GIVEN A MEASURE OF SERENITY AND
CONTROL OVER THE TIME AND
MANNER OF THEIR IMMINENT DEATH.
THE CORPORATE TAX PROTECTIONS
BUILT INTO THE LAW HAVE BEEN
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
EFFECTIVE. THERE HAVE BEEN NO
REPORTED CASES OR INSTANCES OF
ABUSE OR COERCION. IT'S TIME TO
REMOVE UNWARRANTED BARRIERS TO
ACCESS AID IN DYING SO THAT ALL
ELIGIBLE TERMINALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE RIGHT TO REMAIN AUTONOMOUS.
AND DIE WITH THE DIGNITY IN THE
MANNER THEY DESIRE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU MR ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
IS A PROUD CO AUTHOR THIS BILL
PROVIDES TERMINALLY ILL ADULTS
AN OPTION AT THE END OF LIFE
SHE DIED PEACEFULLY AND WITHOUT
SUFFERING. THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT IN THE LIFE OPTION ACT
INTELLECT OF OPTIONS OF IN
THEIR LIVES THE REGARDLESS OF
HOW YOU FEEL PERSONALLY ABOUT
THE CONCEPT WHY WOULD YOU VOTE
PREVENT OTHERS FROM MAINTAIN
THIS COMPASSIONATE OPTION. THIS
PROPOSAL DOESN'T FIT WITHIN
YOUR MORAL CODE. DON'T USE IT.
I THINK JERRY BRON MY TO PUT
PUT IT BEST WHEN HE SIGNED THE
ORIGINAL BILL IN. TWENTY
FIFTEEN. I DO NOT KNOW WHAT I
WOULD DO IF I WERE DYING IN
PROLONGED AND EXCRUCIATING
PAIN. I AM CERTAIN HOWEVER.
THAT WOULD BE A COMFORT TO
CONSIDER THE OPTIONS AFFORDABLE
THIS BILL. THAT WOULD DENY THAT
RIGHT TO OTHERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER. SOME EVENT
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE SP THREE EIGHTY.
HAVING SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THE PASSAGE OF
THE FIRST BILL AND PEOPLE THAT
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED BY
IT THERE WAS AT THAT POINT
TIME- CONCERNS ABOUT ABUSE AND
WE JUST HAVE NOT SEEN THAT AT
THIS POINT TIME SO I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE- AND I VOTE FOR THESE
COMMONSENSE MODIFICATIONS. TO
REDUCE RESTRICTIONS OF THAT ARE
UNNECESSARY AND CERTAINLY THE
EVIDENCE HAS SUGGESTED- THIS
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT FOR- PEOPLE WHO ARE
DYING IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT DECEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SB THREE AT
THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT.
HOUSE YOU'VE HEARD THE X. THE
SUN THE DAY IN THE ACTS OF
PATIENTS FILMS CA REST EASY
KNOWING. THAT THIS COMPASSION
OPTION REMAIN IN PLACE UNTIL
TWENTY THIRTY ONE. THIS
REMEMBER SB THREE EIGHTY DOES
NOTHING TO ALTER THE LOS
THIRTEEN STEP PROCESS. WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE APPROPRIATE
SAFEGUARDS. ARE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT AGAINST MISUSE OF THE
ACT. THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
HELPING PEOPLE DIED. IT IS
ABOUT ALLOWING PEOPLE DIGNITY A
REDUCING SUFFERING. COMPLEX
PROCESS WELL THEY ARE DYING WE
SHOULD ALLOW PEOPLE TO SPEND
THEIR LAST DAYS WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS ON THEIR OWN TERMS
MAKING THEIR OWN DECISION ON
WHAT THE RIGHT TIME MAYBE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF BOTH THIS
AND THE ORIGINAL BILL OVER THE
PAST YEAR AND A HALF WE HAVE
LEARNED FAR TOO WELL. THAT LIFE
ENDS. THEY WILL ALL COME TO AN
END OF WHAT WE HOPE TO BE A
LONG AND MEANINGFUL MEANINGFUL
JOURNEY. AND SO MUCH CERTAINTY
HAS BEEN STRIPPED FROM US IN
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF. I'VE
GIVEN A LOT OF THOUGHT. TO THE
QUESTION IN THE END WHAT WILL I
HAVE STOOD FOR. MY ANSWER. THE
QUALITY. JUSTICE BUT ALSO LOVE
AND COMPASSION. WHAT MANY
PEOPLE MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT THE
END OF LIFE OPTION IS THAT
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN OTHER STATES
WHO HAVE AUTHORIZED MEDICAL AID
IN DYING NEVER USE THIS
MEDICATION THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
PRESCRIBED. PATIENTS REPORT
THAT JUST HAVING THE MEDICATION
ON HIM PROVIDES THEM TREMENDOUS
PEACE OF MIND IN CASE THEY'RE
SUFFERING BECOMES UNBEARABLE.
DEATH WITH DIGNITY IT'S ABOUT
RESPECT AND UNDERSTANDING. A
TRUE TRUSTING KIND IS FOR THOSE
WHO CHOOSE IT. NO ONE WANTS TO
HAVE TO MAKE THESE CHOICES. ONE
TIME WHEN THE TIME COMES TO END
OUR JOURNEY. WE SHOULD ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GO IN PEACE WITH LOVE
AND COMPASSION FOR THEIR
DECISION I RESPECT FOR THEIR
JOURNEY. AND THEIR CHOICES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED I WILL.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED DOCTOR WE WOULD TRY
TO CLOSE. I JUST WANT TO THANK
MY NUMBER THE MEMBERS WHO
SPOKEN IN SUPPORT- AT THOSE OF
YOU WHO'VE HAD YOU KNOW I KNOW
PERSONALLY I'VE HAD. PEOPLE
CLOSE TO ME WHO- HAVE DIED A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT DEATH- A
VERY PAINFUL DEATH. AND THEY'RE
GONE NOW- AND I DON'T KNOW. IF
ANY OF THEM WOULD HAVE CHOSEN
THIS OPTION. BUT I SURE WISH
THEY'D HAD IT. I SURE WISH I'D
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. MAKE THAT
DECISION ON THEIR OWN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD CRIPPLE
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THESE ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
NO DESIRE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO THE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE INVALUABLE
AS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FOURTEEN
THE BILL IF PASSED. NEXT WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
THIS IS SB FOUR OH SIX CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL FOUR OH
SIX BY CENTER STERN AND OTHERS
BACK WITH OIL AND GAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN TO ME OPEN. MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TO THEM HAD
BEEN FOR SB FOUR OH SIX. I'M
HAVE A SENATOR STERN. BEGINS TO
ADDRESS THE NECESSARY REFORMS
TO THE CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC
ENERGY MANAGEMENT DIVISION. FOR
TOO LONG RECORD KEEPING ON OIL
WELLS AND GAS WELLS. FALLING
SHORT OF EXPECTATIONS WE SET.
AND THE RECORDS THAT HAVE BEEN
KEPT. HAVE BEEN FAR TOO
DIFFICULT FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ACCESS. THIS LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY HAS IMPORTANT
CONSEQUENCES. ESPECIALLY FOR
THE FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. LIVE WITHIN ONE
MILE OF AN OIL WELL. FOR THE
BOARD TO MAKE THE DATA. ON GAS
AND OIL WELLS THEY SHOULD
ALREADY BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. AND THAT'S WHAT SB FOUR
SIX DUFF. A QUIET CAL JIM TO
MAKE ALL DATA THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY COLLECTED AND
MAINTAINED. AVAILABLE AND
SEARCHABLE ON THEIR WEBSITE.
AND GIVE ANNUAL UPDATES TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ADDITIONALLY
FORCES ABOUT ANYONE LIVING
WITHIN ONE MILE OF A WELL NOT
JUST THOSE WHO OWN LAND WITHIN
ONE MILE OF WELL TO FILE A
COMPLAINT WITH CAL JIM IF THEY
FEEL WELL THE OPERATING
IMPROPERLY OR FEEL YOU MISSIONS
FROM THE WELLS. ARE CAUSING
ILLNESSES. SB FOUR OH SIX
IMPORTANT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE. THAT
ALLOWS US TO MONITOR MORE
CLOSELY WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
VENTURA STRONG AS WE ARE ABLE
TO RECEIVE NO NO VOTE IN EITHER
HOUSE TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME SENIOR MEMBERS WISHING TO
DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE ITEM PARK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. TIRO ALL
THOSE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO THE.
CLERK CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
TELEVOTE AS FORTY TWO KNOWS TO
THE MEASURE IS PASSED. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SIX THIS IS SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIVE EIGHTY SIX BY CENTER
BRADFORD MAC WITH THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT SEVEN OVER WHATEVER
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SP FIVE EIGHTY
SIX ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BRADFORD. THIS BILL FIXES A
DRAFTING ERROR IN SB TWO THE
KENNETH ROSS JUNIOR POLICE
DECERTIFICATION ACT. THERE WAS
AN AMENDMENT MADE TO SB TWO
WHICH CLARIFIED THAT EXISTING
LAW REGARDING COLLATERAL
ESTOPPEL APPLIES TO
DECERTIFICATION PROCEEDINGS
UNDER SB TWO. HOWEVER THIS
AMENDMENT WAS PLACED IN THE
WRONG SECTION AND DUE TO A
TECHNICAL ERROR THIS ERROR WAS
UNABLE TO BE FIXED DIRECTLY IN
SB TWO. THIS BILL SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX DOES NOT CHANGE ANY
LANGUAGE IN THAT AMENDMENT. IS
SIMPLY MOVED IT TO THE CORRECT
SECTION. IF SB TWO IS ENACTED
TO ASSIST WITH ITS
IMPLEMENTATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR WEBER. SEEING NO MEMBERS
WISH TO DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE
ITEM PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE LOW WHO DESIRE
TO THE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS
FORTY SIX NEWS TWENTY THE BILL
IS PASSED.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR SB THREE
NINETY TWO CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY TWO BY
CENTER ARCHULETA AND OTHER
SNACK WITH A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES YOU MAY OPEN. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT SB THREE NINETY TWO
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO PREVENT CHAPTER OUT
ISSUES. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYNES SEEING
NOBODY WISHING TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL NUMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO. ALL
NUMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO THE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE BILL IS PASSED.
MEMBERS WE ARE RESUMING
BUSINESS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE.
MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE
EIGHTY THREE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY THREE
BY SENATOR T. EASY AND ACCURATE
IN JUVENILES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT. CENTER CORTESE
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY THREE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL ABOUT
DIVERSIONS FOR JUVENILES. UNDER
PROP TWENTY ONE THERE WERE SOME
SIGNIFICANT LIMITATIONS ON
BEING ABLE TO DIVERT JUVENILES
AWAY FROM JUVENILE HALL AND
INTO APPROPRIATE PROGRAM. THIS
BILL WILL CORRECT THAT. WE KNOW
THAT WHEN KIDS TOUCH JUVENILE
HALL THERE ARE THREE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO RECEIVE HAVE A AND
GROW INTO POTENTIALLY. HAVING
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROBLEMS ONCE
THEY'RE AN ADULT IF WE CAN GET
THEM KEEP THEM AWAY FROM
JUVENILE HALL KEEP THEM AWAY
FROM IN A CARCERAL SENT.
SITUATION AND PUT THEM INTO
PROGRAMMING UNDER SUPERVISION
THEIR SUCCESS RATES RISING
SIGNIFICANTLY IT AT A TIME
WHERE WE ARE REALIGNING
APARTMENT YOU DON'T JUSTICE
THAT A LOT OF THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES DOWN TO
COUNTIES. THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THOSE COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO
DIVERT KIDS AT APPROPRIATE
LEVELS TO THOSE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
RIGHT NOW BUT WE'RE ASKING FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ONSB THREE
EIGHTY THREE THIS IS A BILL
THAT HAS NO OPPOSITION. THIS IS
A BILL THAT IS IMPORTANT FOR
THE SUCCESS OF JUVENILES IN
CALIFORNIA AND I ASK FOR YOUR
ITEMS THANK YOU MR STONE SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE MEASURE
PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THOSE. WHICH TO VOTE A WHOLE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE PLEASE VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE PLEASE A. THIS
IS A THIS BILL REQUIRES TWO
THIRDS MEMBERS.
WHO WHO-
CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL TALLY THE
VOTES I FIFTY SIX KNOWS
FOURTEEN THE BILL IS PASSED
NEXT MOVING THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB FOURTEEN CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AND
OTHERS MEDICALLY THE PEOPLE
HELPING TO CLEAR THE ZERO STICK
FOR COMPLETELY AS A MEMBER LOW
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER BECAUSE SB
FOURTEEN HELPS ADDRESS THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH ESPECIALLY WITH OUR
YOUNG CALIFORNIA'S I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL THE BILL WE
DESIRE TO MOVE. ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO THROW. FOR
FULL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES I IS SIXTY NINE KNOWS
ONE ON THE BILL I FIFTY NINE
KNOWS ONE ON THE URGENCY THE
BILL IS PASSED. NEXT WE'LL MOVE
TO. FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB SEVEN
NINETY TWO CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY TWO BY
CENTER GLAZER AND OTHERS NOT
HAVING TO TAXATION DR QUIRKY
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS SBSEVEN NINETY TWO
WOULD REQUIRE RETAILERS WITH
ONLINE SALES TOTALING MORE THAN
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
REPORT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JACKSON FOR. THE ADMINISTRATION
THE CITY OR CITY ARE COUNTY OF
THE PURCHASES FOR ALL TAXABLE
SALES TRANSACTIONS ONLINE.
ONLINE RETAILERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CHOOSE WHERE THEY
ALLOCATE TAX REVENUES THIS
ALLOWS CORPORATIONS DIRECT
REVENUES TO A SINGLE
JURISDICTION IN THE STATE.
CORPORATIONS USE THIS IN. AS
LEVERAGE WHEN NEGOTIATING WHERE
LO. RESULTS IS A PROCESS
DRIVING CITIES TO ACCEPT
INCREASINGLY ONEROUS TAX
SHARING AGREEMENTS IN EXCHANGE
FOR ONLINE RETAILERS SENDING
ALL OF THEIR SALES TAX THEY
COLLECT IN CALIFORNIA TO THAT
SINGLE JURISDICTION. ALL FOR
THESE REASONS SB SEVEN NINETY
TWO WOULD REQUIRE RETAILERS
REPORT. THEIR DATA THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES AND NUMEROUS CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR GLAZIER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR COR DECEMBER
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINE TWO. WHICH IS SIMPLY
A TRANSPARENCY DATA COLLECTION
MEASURE WHEN SOMEONE IN YOUR
DISTRICT BUYS A PRODUCT AT A
BRICK AND MORTAR STORE THE
SALES TAX THEY PAY STAYS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY BUT WHEN THEY
BUY THE SAME PRODUCT ONLINE THE
TAX THEY PAY CAN GO TO A CITY
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY. YET
THERE IS NO COMPREHENSIVE DATA
ON THE EFFECT OF ONLINE
SHOPPING AND LOSS OF REVENUE
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES WHICH IS
WHY THIS BILL IS NEEDED AS OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMY
CONTINUE TO REBOUND FROM THE
IMPACTS OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS AND AS MORE OF THE
ECONOMY MOVES TO ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS. WE NEED BETTER
DATA TO BE ABLE TO SEE HOW
THESE TAX SHIPS ARE IMPACTING
OUR COMMUNITIES FOR BETTER OR
FOR WORSE ONCE WE HAVE THE DATA
WE CAN CONSIDER PROPOSALS TO
CHANGE THE SYSTEM IF THE
INFORMATION ONCE AND AGAIN IT'S
A DATA SIMPLY OF TRANSPARENCY
DATA COLLECTION MEASURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN NINE
TWO. THIS BILL UNDERMINES A
POLICY THAT IS CREATED JOB
OPPORTUNITIES IN VOLATILE
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE.
SO ARE WE REALLY GOING TO RE
DIRECT FUNDS TO WEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES WHO DO NOT HAVE TO
LIVE WITH THE CONSEQUENCES.
THAT WAREHOUSES BRING TO
COMMUNITIES. ARE WE GONNA
EXASPERATING THE INEQUALITY
AMONG OUR UNDESERVED AND MORE
PRIVILEGE COMMUNITIES. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOM VETOED A SIMILAR BILL
WHICH WOULD HAVE ELIMINATED
THESE TAX INCENTIVES. IN HIS
VETO MESSAGE GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THESE TAX
AGREEMENTS ARE AN IMPORTANT
LOCAL TOOL THAT CAPTURES
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AND
INLAND CALIFORNIA. I DID NOT
SUPPORT THAT BILL. STEAD I
AUTHORED A BILL THAT REQUIRED
LOCAL AGENCIES TO INFORM THE
PUBLIC BEFORE APPROVING-
RANTING ANY ECONOMIC SUBSIDIES
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THAT BILL.
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WE SEE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF WAREHOUSES.
WITH INCREASED TRUCK TRAFFIC
INCREASED AIR POLLUTION WITH
THE- ATION OF ROADS CAUSED BY
TRUCKS SO THE SHIFT WHERE THESE
TAXES WOULD GO WOULD BE A GREAT
OF MISTRUST IN JUSTICE SO I
STAND AND ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
ON SB SEVEN NINETY TWO. THANK
YOU MR MEDINA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOLLING RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE TO THE
GROWTH OF OUR ONLINE ECONOMY
HAS LED TO A SHIFT IN SALES TAX
REVENUE FROM SMALL RULES CITIES
HAVE LOST BRICK AND MORTAR
STORES TO PLACES WHERE ONLINE
RETAILERS HAVE DECIDED TO BUILD
OFFICES AND WAREHOUSES. CITIES
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE CONNECTION
TO ONLINE RETAILERS ARE ABLE TO
SCOOP UP SALES TAX PAID BY
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN RURAL
AREAS LIKE EIGHTY ONE. THE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM WILL
BE COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT BUT WE
CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO ADDRESS IT
UNTIL WE HAVE THE DATA THAT
SHOWS US WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
HOW DIFFERENT POLICY CHOICES
MIGHT AFFECT THE FLOW OF OUR
SALES TAX REVENUE THIS BILL
GATHERS DATA WHICH CAN HELP US
ACCESS HOW WE CAN BETTER
SUPPORT OUR REAL COMMUNITIES I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER ALI SON EVER MAYES ARE
RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT-
WANTED TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE NORTH STATE- IN THIS A NEW
ENVIRONMENT TO ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENT WITH ALL THIS
ONLINE SHOPPING THIS. THERE ARE
CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN GAMING
THE SYSTEM AT AND IT'S A
POSITIVE IT'S A NET BENEFIT FOR
THEM ESPECIALLY FOR CITIES THAT
ARE- THAT ARE DISADVANTAGED I
WAS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN A
CITY THAT WAS IT WAS
DISADVANTAGED BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT CITY THAT I WAS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER OF IS ACTUALLY
BEING HARMED BECAUSE THESE
REVENUES ARE GOING TO OTHER
PLACES AND THEY'RE NOT GETTING
THE BENEFIT. OF THEM SO ONCE
AGAIN THIS IS ABOUT DATA. SO I
RISE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. I WANT
TO REITERATE THAT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE AND SB SEVEN. NINE
TO THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY.
IS THAT SB SEVEN NINE TO
ASSEMBLY DATA COLLECTION BILL.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CITY OF OCEANSIDE THEY WROTE ME
AND WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE GAP. BETWEEN WHERE. SALES
TAX IS GOING IN ORDER TO
MODERNIZE OUR TAX LAWS. SO I
WITHOUT URGENT AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER WARREN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS MY
COLLEAGUES COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY STATED WE NEED DATA. IF
AS LAWMAKERS WE WANT TO DEVELOP
GOOD POLICY. AS MORE THE
ECONOMY MOVES TO ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS IT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL THAT WE ARE ABLE TO SEE
HOW THE OUR ALLOCATION OF LOCAL
SALES TAX REVENUES. AFFECTS OUR
COMMUNITIES. BY STUDYING HOW
ONLINE SALES ARE ACTUALLY
ALLOCATED ACROSS THE STATE SB
SEVEN NINE AT TWO. WOULD BETTER
INFORM THE PUBLIC AND
LEGISLATORS. AND LEAD TO BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS IN THE FLOW OF
GOODS ACROSS THE STATE. THIS
WOULD IN TURN ALLOW POLICY
MAKERS TO MAKE REASONABLE.
THOUGHTFUL DECISIONS AND SALES
TAX POLICY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MS IRWIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. AND I DO THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE COLLECTING
DATA BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE DATA WE COLLECT.
ACTUALLY REPRESENTS WHAT'S
TRULY GOING ON WHERE A LOT OF
THE- WAREHOUSES IN A LOT OF THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON THE ROAD DESTRUCTION THAT'S
GOING ON. THAT WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY GET COLLECT DATA ON
EVERYTHING BRING STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER. TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE DATA THAT'S AND PACKED IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE THAT HAVE SO MANY.
WAREHOUSES THAT ARE THERE AT
THE AIR POLLUTION SHOULD BE ONE
OF THE AREAS THAT WE COLLECT
ON. WE SHOULD ALSO BE LOOKING.
AT THE- TRANSPORTATION HUB
AROUND THE AREAS WHERE THE
WAREHOUSES. ARE SO IT'S NOT
ABOUT. A AGAINST THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IT'S AGAINST
MAKING SURE THAT THE DATA
THAT'S BEING COLLECTED IS WELL
THOUGHT THROUGH AND THE PREMISE
FIRST GOES BACK TO THE
COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE BEING
ASKED TO HAVE THESE WAREHOUSES
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING
ASKED TO HAVE. THE
TRANSPORTATION OF THESE DIESELS
GOING THROUGH SIDE BY SIDE WITH
FAMILIES IN CARS. WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO COLLECT THAT DATA AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT VOICE IS
ALSO PART OF THE EQUATION. BUT
WE ALSO START TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE START TO LOOK AT
COLLECTING DATA. THAT WE ALSO.
IF NOW WE GET TO THAT POINT
WHERE THE SALES TAX REVENUE IS
COLLECTED BY THE END USER IN
THAT JURISDICTION WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY WHERE
THESE WAREHOUSES ARE AT. WOULD
NOW GOING THROUGH THE PLANNING
COMMISSION TACKED ON ANOTHER
IMPACT FEE TO. THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE THERE THAT ARE
CONDUCTING BUSINESS I'M ALL FOR
COLLECTING DATA I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE IT'S THE RIGHT DATA
THAT WE'RE COLLECTING. AND I
THINK THIS BILL DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH TO ENCOURAGE THE VOICES
OF THOSE THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED. I ASK THAT WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
ROBERTS SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED A
QUIRKY MAKE CLOSE. SO TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO OBJECTED TO THE
BILL I THINK YOU'VE GOT A GOOD
POINT IN THAT IT WOULD BE
USEFUL TO TAKE A LOOK AT AIR
POLLUTION. UP THIS DATA WILL BE
COMING TO THE REVENUE TAX
COMMITTEE I AM ON IT- I WILL
CERTAINLY ASK THE CHAIR- AUTUMN.
IT'S ME. THE CHAIR OVER THERE
ARE TO TAKE A LOOK AT ALL THE
DATA AND NOT COS REVENUE GAIN.
LET ME SAY. IF I COULD ONLY
REMEMBER WHICH CITY IS THE CITY
OF LA. WE SORRY. THE MEMBER
FROM INGLEWOOD WE WILL
DEFINITELY LOOK AT ALL OF THAT-
BEYOND THAT. IT'S NOT ALWAYS
THE WAREHOUSE CITY GETS THE-
THE- THE TAX ANYTHING THAT YOU
GET FROM APPLE REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THE WAREHOUSE IS GOES TO
THE CITY OF CUPERTINO. AND THEY
HAVE MADE CONCESSIONS TO APPLE
IN ORDER TO GET THAT PRIVILEGE.
THAT'S THE SORT OF THING WE
WILL SEE IF WE GET THAT DATA
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATE
IS NOT GOING TO BE SO OBVIOUS
BUT AGAIN IT ISN'T ALWAYS THE
WAREHOUSES THAT GET IT. AND WE
NEED TO SEE THAT AS WELL TOO SO
I ASK THE ARRIVE OF. THANK YOU
DR PEPPER WITH THAT WE'LL OPEN
THE ROLE. PRIOR TO VOTE ALL
THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS
FIFTY KNOWS FOURTEEN THE BILL
IS PASSED. NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NINETEEN THIS IS SB
THREE OH SIX CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL THREE OH SIX BY
CENTER PAN AND OTHERS SNAPPED
MEDINA HEALTHCARE SOME REAL LOW
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB THREE ZERO SIX
HELPS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
GREATER HEALTH CARE ACCESS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MR LOW. SCENE NO MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
THE PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
TIRED OF THOSE ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY SIX KNOWS
EIGHT THE BILL IS PASSED. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR THIS IS SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FOR TWENTY THREE BY SEVEN
STERN AND OTHERS BALLOT IN
ENERGY SOME OF OUR EMERGENCY
YOU MAY OFTEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RISE TO PRESENT SB FOUR
TO THREE ON BEHALF OF SENATORS
STERN A BILL THAT REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP. AN ENERGY ASSESSMENT
FOCUSED ON ZERO CARBON FREE
RESOURCES THEY CAN INDIVIDUALLY
OR IN COMBINATION DELIVERS ZERO
CARBON ELECTRICITY SUPPORT OUR
ENERGY GRID DURING EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS OR PERIODS OF
LOW RENEWABLE ENERGY THIS IS
THE IMPORTANT ENERGY PLANNING
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EITHER. THANK YOU MR MURRAY
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN NO MEMBERS
WISHING TO DISCUSS OR DEBATE
THE ITEM THE PARK WILL OPEN THE
WALL. ALL THOSE THOSE. THOSE
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MOVE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO THE. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THE BILL IS
PASSED. WE'LL BE MOVING TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIS IS. THE ITEM NUMBER
ONE OH ONE SENATE BILL. THREE
EIGHTY ONE. FOUR FOUR EIGHT.
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY ONE BY
CENTER PORTANTINO WHEN I PLAY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT MAKING A
PROVISIONAL FOUR TO CLEAR THE
UC THERE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
SONORA RUBIO YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
OUR SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
PROPOSES CHANGES TO THE
DISPENSATION PROCESS HOMES IN
THE SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR
CURRENTLY OWNED BY CALTRANS
THESE AMENDMENTS MAKE IT
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE FOR THE
IMPACT CITY IMPACTED CITIES TO
PURCHASE REHABILITATE
MAINTAINING OF MISS MINISTER IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS.
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I REAP THE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
MEMBERS WILL
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE BEFORE WE
RESUME THE ITEM.
MEMBERS WE
WILL BE RECESSED THING FOR A
BRIEF AND DINNER BREAK THERE IS.
DINNER AVAILABLE FOR DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS AND THE MEMBERS LOUNGE
AND REPUBLICAN MEMBERS AND THE
BROWN CONFERENCE ROOM. THIRTY
MINUTES. MARCH THIRTY ONE
PLEASE WE'LL SEE YOU IN THIRTY
MINUTES THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THE
TIME IS SIX THIRTY FIVE RECESS
HAS EXPIRED PLEASE RETURN TO
THE FLOOR SO WE MAY RESUME OUR
SESSION.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN
TO THE CHAMBER SO THAT WE MAY
RESUME OUR SESSION.
MEMBERS
THERE IS A SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER TWO. MADE UP OF ITEMS
TO- ONE THROUGH TWO TWENTY WE
ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWO TWELVE THIS IS AB
NINE ONE THREE CORKERY SOME
PEOPLE NINE THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
IMMACULATE IN THE COLLATERAL
RECOVERY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SET
THE MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS NINETY AB
NINE THIRTEEN UPDATES AND
CLARIFIES COLLATERAL RECOVERY
ACT IN THE BUSINESS OF
PROFESSIONAL CODES. TO REFLECT
CURRENT PRACTICES SENATE
AMENDMENTS NARAL THE BILL
CONSIDERABLY AND WERE TAKEN AT
THE REQUEST OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND ASK FOR CONCURRENCE OF THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SMITH SENIOR MEMBERS WAS
TO DISCUSS. OR DEBATE THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO THE- ALL THOSE VOTE
RETIRED AGO. ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. MEMBERS OF
YOUR OFF THE FLOOR PLEASE
RETURN TO THE CHAMBERS OF THE
YOU MAY CAST YOUR VOTE. ALL
THOSE VOTERS I ARE TO VOTE.
UHHUH.
MISTER SMITH MOVES THE
CALL. THE THREE OF YOU
RECOGNIZE PROMOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEMS
TWO ONE SEVEN ON SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE TO AB. THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER TO THE
FOLLOWING BILL TO COMMITTEE. A.
B. FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE
O'DONNELL FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
THE NEXT ROOM WILL
BE TAKING UP. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TO EIGHTEEN AB FOUR SIXTY NINE
CORPORATION. SOME PEOPLE FOR
SIXTY NINE BY SOME REYES AND
OTHERS NOT HAVING PEOPLE
INSTRUCTIONS ADVERTORIAL AREA
THEY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I PRESENT TO
YOU AB FOUR SIX NINE WHICH
REQUIRES LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO ENSURE STUDENTS
COMPLETE THE PAST FOUR AND THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATIONS FOR FINANCIAL AID
THIS BILL IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
IS ALIGNED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND ADDS TO CLEAN UP
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MS REYES SEEING NO MEMBERS
WISHING TO DISCUSS THE ITEM THE
PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THE RETIRED TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK
WILL CLOSE A ROLLING CALENDAR I
WAS FORTY THREE KNOWS ZERO
SENATE MEMBERS ARE CONSIDERED
AN- NEXT IS FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
AB NINE HUNDRED FOR KOREAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MARIA'S ENACTED IN THE
TRUST MANDATORY EARLIER YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB NINETY. IS A TECHNICAL BILL
THE SIMPLY FIXES AND THEN
INCONSISTENCY IN CURRENT LAW
AND ENSURES A TRUSTEES ARE
ACTING IN GOOD FAITH. UNDER
EXISTING LAW ON AN NONPROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO GIVE WRITTEN NOTICE
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WHEN.
THE CORPORATION INTENDS TO MOVE
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL OF ITS ASSETS
HOWEVER DUE TO AN EXISTING
CONSISTENCY WITHIN CALIFORNIA
LONG. CHARITABLE TRUST HAVE
BEEN ALLOWED TO CIRCUMNAVIGATE
THE SIMPLE NOTICE BUT ALL OTHER
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE. THIS BILL
WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE CHARITABLE TRUSTEES TO
PROVIDE NOTICE TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHEN THE CHARITABLE
TRUSTEE INTENDS TO MOVE
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL CHARITABLE
ASSETS OWNED BY THE TRUST.
RECENT AMENDMENTS ADDED DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
REYES SEEING NO MEMBERS WISHING
TO BE RECOGNIZED ON THIS ITEM
FOR A FULL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THOSE OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO.
ALL THOSE VOTERS I ARE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. MEMBERS OF YOUR OFF THE
FLOOR PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR SO YOU MAY CAST YOUR VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FORTY ONE
KNOWS THIRTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN. WE
WILL LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ON
ITEM TO TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
THIRTEEN- PLEASE OVER THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO THOSE.
ALL THOSE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO SAN AND THEN IT'S
OUR CONCURRED IN BACK TO THE
TOP OF THE SECOND SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE THIS IS FILE ITEM TO- ONE
EIGHTY FORTY ONE CIRCLE REEF
SOME PEOPLE FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND OTHER
SNACK WHICH COMMUNICATIONS
TOWER WOULD REMAIN OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FORTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL OUTLINES
BASELINE STEPS YOU MUST TAKE TO
BRING CALIFORNIA'S DATE
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. TENEMENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS PER FINING PRESERVE
THE SPIRIT OF THIS BILL BY
DEFINING THE FRAMEWORK FOR MAPS
THEY WILL ACTUALLY ILLUSTRATE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE FACING
CALIFORNIANS THESE MASS WIDE
ENOUGH I COMMONSENSE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PUT EMPLOYED
DIG ONCE PROJECTS IN THE STATE
RIGHT AWAY REDUCING THE COST OF
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT BY UP 290%
WHETHER IT'S EDUCATION THE
DIGITAL MARKETPLACE HEALTH CARE
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT SERVICES
THE GATEWAY TO FUNDAMENTAL
RESOURCES IS INCREASINGLY
ONLINE. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
DISCUSS THIS ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THAT YOU'RE TO
MOVE. ALL THE- RETIRED TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE RETIRED VOTE. CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL INTELLIGIBLE
I FIFTY TWO NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONFERRED AND NEXT IS FILE
ITEM TO- TO AB SEVENTY THREE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS ANOTHER
RESPECTFULLY TO APPOINT SAFETY
AND CLEARLY YOU SEE THERE ARE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REDUCING THE
OPEN. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
THIS LEGISLATION- I ENSURE
FARMING AGRICULTURE WORKERS
WILL. WILL BOTH HAVE ACCESS TO
P. P. E. WHEN THERE'S A
WILDFIRE EVENT AND ALSO HAVE
CONSISTENT ACCESS TO QUALITY
AND COMPREHENSIBLE TRAINING
RELATED TO WILDFIRE SMOKE.
INCLUDING USING ASA PICTOGRAPHS
AND APPROPRIATELY ACCOUNTING
FOR RELEVANT ETHNIC AND
CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS AND
EDUCATION LEVELS. AS CALIFORNIA
IS YET AGAIN EXPERIENCING IN
OTHER YEAR OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. NOW IS THE TIME TO
BILL ON COUCHES FIRST OF THE
NATION'S STANDARD FOR
PROTECTING OUR FARM AND I GO TO
WORKERS FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE AND
UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY.
CONDITIONS RESPECT US WHEN I
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER REVATHY
MEMBERS WISH TO DISCUSS THIS
ITEM PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THE BILL WE DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES.
ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO THE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING CALLIE THE BILL'S
PRICE FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
NEXT IS FILE ITEM TWO OH THREE
ABVD NINE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
OTHERS BY PUTTING THE PEACE
OFFICERS REMEMBER JONES SAWYER
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHTY NINE
TO PEACE ACT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THE PEACE OFFICERS
EDUCATION AT AGE CONDITIONS FOR
EMPLOYMENT ACT. AS PROMISED IN
JUNE THE FINAL PIECE ACT BEFORE
YOU ALL TODAY IS THE
CULMINATION OF THE TIMELINESS
TO PROFESSIONALISE POLICING
WHILE ALSO ADDRESSING THE
SIGNIFICANCE. TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY IN THE WORKFORCE.
WORKING WITH THE ADMIN. THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
POLICE CHIEF'S POST ANY ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION WE NOW
HAVE AB EIGHTY NINE. NOW
INCREASES THE MINIMUM AGE FOR
INCOMING OFFICE FROM EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY ONE YEARS BY THE TIME
OF THE APPOINTMENT. ALIGNED
WITH THAT OF OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
LEGAL AGE TO S. POSSESS A
FIREARM. IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALONGSIDE ADVISES FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT HIGHER EDUCATION
FACULTY MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE. WHICH WILL
INCLUDE TO DEVELOP FRAMEWORK
FOR A MODERN POLICING DEGREE
PROGRAM COURSES IN THIS DEGREE
WILL INCLUDE PSYCHOLOGY
COMMUNICATIONS HISTORY ETHNIC
STUDIES LAW AND THOSE IN
CRITICAL THINKING. AND
EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE THIS
FRAMEWORK AIMS TO EQUIP
OFFICERS WITH THE SKILLS
NECESSARY FOR DE ESCALATION
WHILE ALSO GUARANTEEING THEY
DEVELOPED A CRITICAL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE HISTORY
COMMUNITIES. FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND CULTURES BY
DEPARTMENT WITH ONE OF THE BEST
TUITION FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEMS IN NATION AND
DEVELOPING A MODEL FOR
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS. OF LOW INCOME
AND UNDERREPRESENTED
BACKGROUNDS WE ENSURED A MODERN
POLICING PROFESSION IS
ASSESSABLE AND THAT THE
WORKFORCE REFLECTS THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. WHEN WE
ENHANCE CONDITIONS FOR
EMPLOYMENT RESTRICTED THE
COMMUNITY TRUST AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF COLOR WHO
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IN ADDITION THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS. AND
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES NOW
SUPPORT THE BILL. THE PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. CCPOA THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION PORAC AND
OTHERS HAVE NOW REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION THERE ARE THE
NEUTRAL. OR THEY JUST REMOVED
OF OPPOSITION BY ENSURING THAT
MORE MATURE AND BETTER EDUCATED
WORKFORCE TO PEACE ACT WILL
INCREASE DIVERSITY AMONGST THE
RANKS PERSONALIZED POLICING
TRANSFER FORM DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE STATE MARKING A
TRANSITION IN ADDRESSING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF BEHIND EXCESSIVE
FORCE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS ON AB EIGHTY NINE
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SENATE OVER LACKING. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO HIGHLIGHT MY CONCERNS
ON THE PRINCIPLES OF THIS BILL.
WHEN IT COMES TO RECRUITING
PEACE OFFICERS WE SHOULD
EMPHASIZE CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE.
WE SHOULD EMPHASIZE LIFE
EXPERIENCE IN MY OPINION REMADE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OTHER AS FOLLOWS
FIRST OF ALL WE NEED TO HAVE
LITERATE APPLICANTS THAT'S DONE
THROUGH THE WRITTEN PORTION OF
THEIR APPLICATION SECONDLY.
INTEGRITY WHICH IS DONE THROUGH
THE BACKGROUND CHECK AND HOW
TRUTHFULLY THE ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS LASTLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENT. AS A
PREREQUISITE THEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS HAVING A
SERVANT'S HEART. WILLING TO
GIVE THEIR OWN LIFE FOR THOSE
THEY SERVE AND PROTECT. OUR
PRIORITY SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
APPROVING THE BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATION PROCESS. ONE OF
THE SPECIFIC ISSUES I'VE HAD.
WITH THIS THE CONVERSATION ALL
YEAR LONG. ARE THE OMISSIONS OF
ALLOWING HONORABLY DISCHARGED
MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY TO BE
EXEMPT FROM THE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT. AGAIN BECAUSE LIFE
EXPERIENCES TO BE EMPHASIZED
OVER CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE. ARE
YOU TELLING ME A MEMBER OF THE
MILITARY WHO CARRIED OUT THE
EVACUATION MISSIONS OF IT IN
AFGHANISTAN NEEDS TO SIT IN A
CLASSROOM TO LEARN HOW TO
SERVER NAVIGATE STRESSFUL
SITUATIONS. I ASK FOR YOUR
NOBLE. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKING. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS
ITEM- SUMMER JONES SAWYER YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU AND I AND
I THINK MY STEAM- VICE CHAIR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR HIS COMMENTS.
I WANTED TO KNOW THAT I
PERSONALLY HAVE TAKEN ALL OF
THAT AND THIS IN THE- THE
SYSTEM THAT WE'RE WE'RE-
TRAINING WILL DEFINITELY
INVOLVED. PORAC MAKING SURE THE
POLICE CHIEFS ARE INVOLVED TO
DO WE HAVE A REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE PEOPLE WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNICABLE IS. GREAT BOTH
THE CLASSROOM AND REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE. IN ADDITION I AM
DID NOT IGNORE WHEN YOU CAME TO
ME EARLIER BACK IN JUNE. ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
MILITARY EXPERIENCE AND THAT WE
ALSO GIVE THEM. A BONUS POINTS.
FOR THEIR SERVICE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO HONEST THAT THAT
SERVICE THAT'S IN THIS BILL AND
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT IS THAT IS THERE. WE WILL
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE.
THOSE SKILL SETS THAT YOU
MENTION. THAT YOU MENTIONED THE
TRANSFERABLE. AND YOU'RE GOING
INTO THE COMMUNITIES IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND YOU'RE NOT IN A
WAR ZONE SO I WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL THAT WE DON'T
TRANSFER. THOSE TYPE OF SKILL
SETS. INTO COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND YOU NEED ADDITIONAL.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING DE
ESCALATION ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HOW TO
DEAL WITH DIFFERENT TYPES OF.
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. AND WE'RE
GOING TO BRING THIS BACK TO YOU.
BOB AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
ACTUAL CURRICULUM SO THAT YOU
CAN THEN HAVE EVEN MORE INPUT
SO WE GET THIS RIGHT BECAUSE I
AGREE WITH YOU IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE BETTER
BACKGROUND CHECKS. BECAUSE YOU
TOLD ME IN SMALLER CITIES. THEY
DON'T HAVE MAY NOT HAVE THE
MONEY AND IN THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT KIND OF DEEP DIVE IT YOU
NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU GET THE
BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST FOR
THAT. AND SO I'M LETTING YOU
KNOW WE I HEARD EVERYTHING YOU
SAID. AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS AND WE
GET IT. PERFECT AS PERFECT WE
CAN GET. SO THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WHEN THIS GOES INTO
EFFECT. WE ACTUALLY WILL HAVE
WHAT WHAT YOU WANT AND WHAT I
WANT TO HAVE THE BEST POLICE
FORCE WE CAN HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ALBUM. THANK YOU MISTER
DUNNE CERVICAL OPEN. ALL THOSE
VALUABLE. ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
FOR FULL
ROLLING CALENDAR VOTE BY FORTY
ONE NO SEVENTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE COMPARED. NEXT
WE'LL MOVE THE FILE ITEM TO-
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY
FOUR CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE ONE TWENTY FOUR BY
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER
AND OTHERS MEDICAL IN THE
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CA YOU MAY OPEN. YES
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ONE TWENTY FOUR JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS BY SENATOR COM LONGER
WHICH IS ALSO A WOMAN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN SINCE WE LAST SAW THIS
BILL STRUCK PROVISIONS RELATED
TO CONSECUTIVE SENTENCE ENDS.
AND SENTENCING HAS MEN'S VALLEY
FELT FELONIES ARE NOT EXCLUDED
FROM BAKER TO RELIEF AND
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE. AND THE
MAN THEY DON'T IMPOSE IN THE
LOWER TERM AT SENTENCING TO AN
AGGRAVATING CIRCUMSTANCES
OUTWEIGH THE MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES IS NOT LIMITED.
AB ONE TWO FOUR IS NOT A MODEST
VERSION OF ITS ORIGINAL FORM
AND WE'LL GIVE MANY SURVIVORS A
MECHANISM. TO SEEK JUSTICE THAT
IS HOLISTIC AND REHABILITATIVE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I'VE
VOTE ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND SENATOR COME UNDER.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA SEEING NO
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS
ITEM PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
OF DESIRE TO THEM. ALL THOSE.
CENTERS ARE TO THOSE. ALL THE
VOTE BECAUSE TO VOTE.
WELL
CLOSER ROLAND KELLY THE BILL'S
EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN
SENATE MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE THE FILE
ITEM TWO OH FIVE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWO SIX FOUR
FOUR EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMOS AND OTHERS NOT GOING TO
CARE FACILITIES CINEMA
RAMASWAMY OPEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. AB TWO TWO
SIX IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CREATE IMPORTANT GUARDRAILS TO
ENSURE HIGH QUALITY SERVICE FOR
YOU INCLUDING CLARIFYING THE
RIGHTS OF YOU REINTRODUCE IN
REVIEW AROUND LENGTH OF STAY
AND LIVE EIGHT OPERATORS OF
CHILDRENCRISIS RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES TO
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED
NONPROFITS ALONG WITH OTHER
TECHNICAL IN CHAPTER IN
AMENDMENTS. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING
THEM WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS
ITEM PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE WHO DESIRE TO GO ALL THOSE
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TELEVOTES I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SAN AND MEMBERS ARE GOING.
ERRED IN NEXT WILL TAKE UP ITEM
TWO OH SIX THIS IS AB THREE
SIXTY ONE OR FOR REED ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY ONE BYASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
ACCORDING OPEN MEETINGS THE
CAREERS OF XEROX THE COR
COMMUNITY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
YOU MAY OPEN. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND THIS
LEGISLATION SEEKS TO.
TEMPORARILY GRANT LOCAL
AGENCIES THE FLEXIBILITY TO
MEET REMOTELY ONLY ONLY IF
THERE IS A PRO CLAIMED STE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY AND IF STATE
OR LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE IMPOSED
A RECOMMENDED MEASURES TO- UP
PROMOTE SOCIAL DISTANCING
SENATE AMENDMENTS NOW GRANT-
SOME SOME SOME. SOME SOME
EXCUSE ME SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
MEET REMOTELY TO CERTAIN STATE
GOVERNMENT BODIES IN ADDITION
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
ARE THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED SOME.
SOME BROAD SOME BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECT THAT'S WHAT
I'VE THANK YOU MISTER REAVIS
SENIOR MEMBERS WISHING TO
DISCUSS THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES TWO THIRDS THERE
IS URGENCY ALTHOUGH SPOKE WITH
DIRE TO VOTE. WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS
FIFTY EIGHT NO THREE ON THE%
URGENCY AYE AYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
THREE ON. THE AMENDMENT. ON THE-BILL FOR THEM IN A CERTAIN
BURDEN. NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM. TWO OH SEVEN. AB FORTY
SEVEN CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE
FOR FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS BACK UNTIL HEALTH SEVEN-
SANTIAGO IN THE OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- THIS BILL BACK
FROM CURRENT THIS BILL ENSURES
PATIENTS RECEIVE ADEQUATE AND
EFFICIENT TELEHEALTH SERVICES.
RECENT AMENDMENTS REMOVE
OPPOSITION FROM THE HEALTH
PLANS ARE SPECTRALLY ASPIRIN I
HAVE A- THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
SEEING NO MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO GO. ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO THE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES I FIFTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AND MEMBERS ARE
ENCOURAGED AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE
THE FILE ITEM TO- ATV FOR
SEVENTY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOR SEVENTY ONE BY
SIMILAR BELOW AND OTHERS
MADELINE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB FORTY
SEVENTY ONE ENHANCES THE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW SEEING NO MEMBERS
WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO GO.
ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE ENCOURAGED AND
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON ITEM
TWO OH NINE THIS BRINGS US TO
ITEM TWO TEN AB SEVEN SIXTEEN
FOUR FOUR READ SOME PEOPLE
SEVEN SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT RAGLIN IN THE
COURTS SIMER VALUE ME OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY A. B. SEVEN
ONE SIX. INSURERS TRANSPARENCY
IN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH IMPROVES
TRANSPARENCY IN JUDICIAL THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE HAVE
FURTHER CLARIFIED THE INTENT OF
THE BILL THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES AND THERE ARE NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT SENIOR MEMBERS
WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THE- DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE DESIRE TO GO. ALL THOSE
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO HAVE A.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES HIGH SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SAN AND MEMBERS
ARE CONFERRED IN. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM TWO ELEVEN THIS IS
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
CORPORATION FOR SOME PEOPLE HE
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMOS AND I PUT IN A PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMASAMY OPEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB EIGHT
SEVEN THREE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE MEMBERS ARE
TECHNICAL THIS BILL ELIMINATES
THE TRAVEL SHARE OF COST
REQUIREMENTS FOR AN AGREEMENT
ENTERED INTO BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF TALLOW OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WITH THE TRIBE. TRIBAL
CONSORTIUM OR TRIBAL
ORGANIZATION REGARDING CARE AND
CUSTODY OF INDIAN CHILDREN AND
JURISDICTION OVER INDIAN. CHILD
CUSTODY PROCEEDINGS THIS BILL
FIX THESE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
SENIOR MEMBERS WISHING TO
DISCUSS THIS ITEM REPORT WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL THE- IS
THERE TO THEM. ALL VOTE BECAUSE
I OR TO THE- ALL THOSE PLAYERS
ARE FOR THE. CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL IN TALLY THE VOTES I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE HURT IN THE DISPENSER ITEM
TO TWELVE BRING US TO ITEM TWO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TEN SEVENTY
FOUR CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
WILTON SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS NATIONALLY TO
IMPLEMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ FROM SAN
DIEGO I RISE TO PRESENT AB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR. A LATINO CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY OUT A
DEFINITION FOR GUEST SERVICES
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU NUMBER ONE
CORREO SEEING NO MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
HIGHER TO VOTE ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE FOR THE- ALL THOSE
VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO THE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY SIX NEWS
EIGHTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONFERRED AND- NEXT ITEM TO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ELEVEN OH THREE
KERKORIAN'S SOME PEOPLE LEVIN
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEGAN
DALY AND OTHER SNAPPLE IN
AGRICULTURAL LANDS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY IN THE OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN OH THREE
WHICH IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
ON CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER ALI
SEEING NO MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM FOR CLOVER
THE ROLE. THE DESIGN TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MOVE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. OKAY CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES HIGHS SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE MEMBERS ARE CONFERRED IN.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
TO FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT OR FOR REED ASSEMBLY ROLE
LEVIN FIFTY EIGHT BY SUMMER
PETRIE-NORRIS NAPOLI THE
ALCOHOL ALCOHOLISM AND DRUG
ABUSE SEVEN RPG NURSERY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE THAT THANK YOU MISS BETWEEN
NORTH SEEN NO MEMBERS WISHING
TO DISCUSS THIS ITEM CARPOOL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE ARE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL IN TALLY THE
VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
IN. NEXT IS FILE ITEM TO
SIXTEEN AB TWELVE TWENTY CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE TWELVE
TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS TACKLING
TO STATE GOVERNMENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS IN THE OPEN THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWELVE TWENTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE- IT RENAMES THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING- AND
FINANCING COUNCIL TO THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS. AND CHANGES
ITS MEMBERSHIP IT ADDS THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
SECRETARY AS CO CHAIR OF THE
COUNCIL ENSURES THAT THERE ARE
MEMBERS ON THE ADVISORY COUNCIL
THAT HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE
ENSURES THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WILL MEET WITH THE COUNCIL AT
LEAST TWICE A YEAR AND ALSO
THIS OF BILL NOW RESOLVES OF
THEAMENDMENTS RESOLVE CHAPTER
IN OUT ISSUES- THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS SENIOR
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS
ITEM CARPOOL OPEN. ALL THOSE
THE USER TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE DESIRE TO THE- ALL THOSE
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND-
NEXUS FILE ITEM. TO SEVENTEEN.
APOLOGIES THAT IS NOW INACTIVE.
WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH ITEM.
TWO EIGHTEEN BRING US TO ITEM
TWO NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE SIX
ONE SIX CORKERY SENATE BILL
FIVE SIXTEEN BONUS MEMBER MEGAN
DALLY IN ABILENE THE PEOPLE
ATTENDANCE SOME ARE TELLING ME
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO PRESENT AB FIVE
SIXTEEN WHICH IS BACK FROM SAID
ON CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS FOR NON
CONTROVERSIAL AND ADDRESS
CHAPTER NOW CONCERNS THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND RECEIVE
NO NO BOOKS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE THANK YOU MISTER ALI
THREE MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM PARK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO GO. ALL THE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALTHOUGH THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. FOR FULL
CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES
I SIXTY NINE I SEVENTEEN OH
ZERO SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED AND WE WILL MOVE BACK
TO FILE ITEM TWO OH NINE EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FOUR KOREAN. SYMBOL
SIX EIGHTY BY US FROM THE RIVER
ACTUALLY TO THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE IN THE OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WOULD
IMPLEMENT KEY POLICIES
RECOMMENDED THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR A
RECENT REPORT PUTTING
CALIFORNIANS. ON THE HIGH ROAD
AND JOBS AND CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN FOR TWENTY THIRTY
AMENDMENTS TAKEN INSANITY Q. DO
THE FOLLOWING LIMIT THE
APPLICATION OF THE BILL ONLY
TWO PROJECTS INTENSELY
APPROPRIATED BY THE G. G. R. F.
AS LISTED IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SECTION. THIRTY
NINE SEVEN ONE THIRTY NINE
SEVEN ONE NINE WITH THE
EXEMPTION OF SEAT AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND.
EXEMPT HOUSING PROJECT
FEATURING A 100% AFFORDABLE
UNITS THESE AMENDMENTS REMOVED
OPPOSITION OF ALL THE MAJOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GROUPS AS
WELL AS THE OPPOSITION FROM
GROUPS REPRESENTING RURAL AREAS
FLOOR MA'AM IT'S TAKEN AT THE
REQUEST OF THE MINISTRATION
EXTEND THE DATE TO WHICH THE
AARP AND THE LABOR AGENCY MUST
UPDATE THEIR OUT GUIDELINES.
FROM JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE NONE OF THIS
APPLIES TO CURRENTLY- ANTENNAE
PROJECTS CURRENTLY BEING FUNDED
THESE REQUIREMENTS GO INTO
EFFECT ONLY AFTER A R. B. AND
LABOR AND SEE UPDATE THE
GUIDELINES AND THEY HAVE UNTIL
JULY. FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TO DO SO. NO PROJECT WILL BE
AFFECTED INTO THE GUY ARE TO.
I'VE ALSO SUBMITTED A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
THAT HAVE ARISEN AFTER THE
AMENDMENT DEADLINE THAT GAVE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PROJECTS
GIGI R. F. FUNDS VIA. VIA A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION. MY
LETTERS TO THE JOURNAL STATE
THAT IT WAS NOT THE INTENT OF
THIS LEGISLATION TO INCLUDE
THOSE PROJECTS. IN THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL AND THAT SENATOR DODD
AND I WILL INTRODUCE URGENCY
LEGISLATION IN JANUARY. TO
CONFIRM THAT INTENT. SB SIX
EIGHTY WILL PUT PRINCIPLES OF
EQUITY ON THE FRONT END OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR G. G.
R. UP PROJECTS COVERED BY THIS
BILL. RATHER THAN AN
AFTERTHOUGHT THROUGH A SET OF
ASIDE WE HAVE CURRENTLY PLACED.
AB SIX EIGHTY IS SUPPORTED BY
NUMBER OF LABOR UNIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE HOUSE
CONCUR ON SENATE AMENDMENTS TO
AB SIX EIGHTY. TO THE
COMMUNITIES. THAT NEED THESE
KIND OF INVESTMENTS MOST ARE
NOT LEFT BEHIND I KNOW IT'S A
LATE EVENING AND EVERYONE'S
READY TO GO HOME THANK YOU GUYS
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THIS IS BILL
IS FOUR YEARS IN THE MAKING. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE. SCENE NON MEMBERS
WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS ITEM
THE COURT WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE THE DESIRE TO GO. ALL
THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY
FIVE NEWS THIRTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED IN.
THERE IS READY TO A COUPLE OF
OTHER CHANGES. WELL I GET
SETTLED IN HERE MISS DAVIS FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SOMEWHERE DAVIES-
CHANGES AB THREE SIX ONE FROM I
TO KNOW THANK YOU. BURKE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY ONE I DUNNO.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
SENATE BILL.
THE FORTY THAT MS
REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO TAKE UP ITEM ONE NO
ONE ON SECOND READING SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE PORTANTINO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THIS IS. I
DON'T WANT TO ONE SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE PORTANTINO. CORRECT
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY ONE BY
pCENTER PORTANTINO WHEN I PLAYED
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT MAKING A
PROVISION OF FORTY DECLARE
THEIR SIERRA PACIFIC MEDIALLY.
IT'S RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
SB THREE EIGHTY ONE- SB THREE
ONE PROPOSES CHANGES TO THAT
THIS DISPENSATION PROCESS HOMES
AND THERE. ARE SEVEN TEN
CORRIDOR CURRENTLY OWNED BY
CALTRANS THESE AMENDMENTS MAKE
IT ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE FOR
THE IMPACT OF CITIES TO
PURCHASE REHABILITATE MAINTAIN
AND ADMINISTER AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAM. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EYE FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. DAVIS RUBIO ST
NOTIFICATION OF EIGHT FOR
CALDERON MEMBERS OF. ROSARIO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
MEMBERS ON THE URGENCY. TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR. CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY SIX
KNOWS ELEVEN ON THE URGENCY AS
FIFTY SIX KNOWS ELEVEN ON THE
MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE
UP ON THE SENATE THIRD READING
FILE FILE ITEM FORTY. THIS IS.
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
FORTY. SENATE BILL SIXTY EIGHT.
CORRECT SENATE BILL SIXTY EIGHT
BY CENTER BAKER AND OTHERS
NAPOLI TO ELECTRICITY MISS
CARILLO YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SB SIXTY EIGHT
SENATORS THAT SENATOR BACKERS
BILL TO REDUCE THE BARRIERS FOR
ELECTRIFICATION ELECTRIFYING
BUILDINGS WE PASS THIS BILL
LAST WEEK WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BUT WE HAVE TO BRING IT
BACK FOR A CHAP DURING OUT
AMENDMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. BILL. ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK OF HIS
CAREER. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. FOR
CORPORAL MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS. TWELVE WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT THE- WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE CAN DIVERT CHANGES
WELL THERE'S A WALL OF THE
ACTION DR ARAMBULA YOUR VOTE
CHANGE VOTE CHANGE ARAMBULA SB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN ALL RIGHT TO
NOT VOTING. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY SEVEN I TO NOT
VOTING. ANY ANY OF OUR CHANGES
MEMBERS. MS CLARK SILVA. A VOTE
CHANGE A. B. TEN SEVENTY FOUR
BY TWO NOT VOTING DON'T CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
SYMBOL TEN SEVENTY FOUR- TO NOT
VOTING.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED
TO LIFT THE CALL. ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY SB. SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. WHO WISH TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE HIGHS
FORTY ONE NEWS TWENTY EIGHT.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING MEASURES
FOR CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS AB. TWO FIFTEEN TO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FIFTEEN. WITH A
REFERENCE TO FILE AB TWO
FIFTEEN CORRECT SOME PEOPLE TO
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
AN ACCOLADE IN THE HOUSING. MR
CHIU YOU MAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER GREAT BILL LAST
BILL PLEASE VOTE I. DATE OF
ISSUE. C. NOTIFICATION AVE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO GO. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON THIS
GREAT BILL. CLERK WILL. WELL
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE OF ICE FORTY
NINE KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS. A BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT
WE'VE BEEN INFORMED THAT THE
MEMBER ELEVATOR IS OUT OF ORDER.
THE MEMBER ELEVATOR IS NOT
WORKING SO PLEASE STAY OFF OF
THE- MEMBER ELEVATOR. THAT'S
NOT A METAPHOR. TO READ INTO IT.
REPAIR PERSON IS ON THE WAY.
WELL CHANGES FOR CHANGES
MEMBERS MISTER RAMOS ON YOUR
VOTE CHANGE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- RAMOS. VOTE
CHANGE SB SEVEN NINE TWO FROM
NOTE TO NOT VOTING BURKE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY TWO NO TO NOT
VOTING. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP. MISTER CHANG IS GOING
TO TAKE UP ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT. THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
CARBERY. SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY ONE BY CENTERED RAZA AND
OTHERS NATURALLY THE CRIMINAL
RECORDS MISTER CHANG THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'M VERY PROUD
TO PRESENT S. B. S. SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
DORADO. EARLY EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE EITHER A
CONVICTION OR AN ARREST RECORD.
IN CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY
MAINTAINS AN INDIVIDUAL'S
CONVICTION RECORDS UNTIL THEY
REACH A HUNDRED. YEARS OF AGE.
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW THOSE FOLKS
WITH CONVICTION RECORDS OR BEST
RECORDS THAT IT CAN IMPACT
ABILITY GIVE JOB IMPACT ABILITY
GET HOUSING. IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO HAVE A NORMAL LIFE.
SO WE WANT TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT AFTER PEOPLE HAVE. HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED OR CONVICTED IN
THE- RELIEF THAT THEY SERVE
THEIR TIME. THE SERVE THEIR
PAROLE THIS SERVE ALL THESE
VARIETY OF. SERVICES THAT THEY
CAN GET THESE RECORDS EXPUNGED
SORT OF PEACE SEVEN THIRTY ONE
DOES. ARREST AND RECORD
CONVICTION RELIEF IN THREE WAYS
ONE. EXTENT AUTOMATED ARREST
RECORD FUELING TO FELONY
ARRESTS IF THE INDIVIDUAL IS
NEITHER CHARGED. NOR CONVICTED
SIX YEARS AFTER THE ARREST OR
THREE YEARS AFTER FOR LESS
SERIOUS OFFENSES. SECOND EXTENT
ELIGIBLE FOR AUTOMATIC
CONVICTION RECORD RELIEF TO NON
SERIOUS NON SEXUAL NON VIOLENT
FELONIES AFTER AN INDIVIDUAL
COMPLETE ALL TERMS OF
ACCULTURATION. PROBATION
MANDATORY. SUPERVISION POST
RELEASE SUPERVISION PAROLE AND
AN ADDITIONAL FOUR YEARS
WITHOUT ANY NEW CONVICTIONS.
THEN LASTLY IT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF A
FELONY TO PETITION THE COURT
FOR PARTIAL FEELING RELIEF.
THESE PETITIONS ARE DONE ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS AND THE
COURTS MAKE THE FINAL DECISION.
WE GOT- SOME OPPOSITION BECAME
A PERSON CONSERVE THE CAMPER
LICENSE AGENCIES LICENSING
AGENCY STILL CAN GO TO. THE
PART OF JUSTICE TO GET ALL THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED REGARDING
LICENSURE AND ALL THESE VARIETY
PROFESSIONS. IN A TO RATHER
HAVE COMMITTED TO CONTINUED TO
WORK WITH THESE LICENSES
AGENCIES. NEXT YEAR FOR ANY
POTENTIAL CLEAN UP THAT THEY
MAY HAVE. I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME. CONCERN AROUND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THIS DOES NOT IMPACT
PROTECTIVE. RULES ISSUED BY THE
COURT FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE NO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE GROUPS ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION
THIS BILL IS A VERY MODEST UP
FORWARD. TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET
ON WITH THEIR LIVES. TO GET
EMPLOYED TO GET HOUSING TO
REALLY RESUME. AFTER THEY'VE
SERVED THEIR TIME OR- BEEN
ARRESTED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE ON SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU MR TANG MS RUBIO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE SOME
CLARIFICATION AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
ARE WE CAN HALF AGO AND I HAVE
NOT GOTTEN A CLARIFICATION. I
HAVE A I HAVE A BILL THAT IS
NOT A LAW THAT STATES THAT A
MISDEMEANOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFENSE- IF YOU HAVE ONE YOU
CAN NEVER OWN A GUN IF A-
PERPETRATOR FIVE WEIGHTS THAT
OUT WAIT FOR THIS- I DON'T KNOW
WE'RE CALLING IT EXPUNGED.
MEANT THEN HOW DO WE KNOW OR
HOW IS A GUN SHOP GOING TO KNOW
THAT THEY CAN NEVER OWN A GUN.
MISTER CHANG YOUR RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY CAN SPEAK WITH A
GREAT QUESTION. MY
UNDERSTANDING AGAIN IS THIS
BILL DOESN'T IMPACT ANY
PROTECTIVE RULES ISSUED BY THE
CORPORATE MASSIVE VIOLENCE. MS
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU THAT IS NOT THE QUESTION
IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A
RESTRAINING ORDER IT MIGHT THE
BILL THAT BECAME LAW. STATES
THAT IF YOU HAVE A MISDEMEANOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE YOU ARE
BANNED FROM OWNING A GUN FOR
THE REST OF YOUR LIFE. HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH PROTECTIVE
ORDERS IT SPECIFICALLY STATES.
THAT YOU CANNOT OWN A GUN SO
IF. A AND MY SISTER'S ABUSER IS
SMART ENOUGH TO WAIT THAT OUT
FOR THIS TO BE. EXPUNGED AND-
POTENTIALLY CAN GO BUY A GUN
BECAUSE NOW UNDER THIS. ROLE
HIS MISDEMEANOR WOULD BE- TAKEN
AWAY HOW. ARE WE GOING TO
ASSURE THAT THAT LAW DOESN'T
CONFLICT ITH WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY MISTER CHANG YOU MAY
ADDRESS THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES IF
YOU WISH. OUR ACTIONABLE OFFICE
TO GET THE ANSWER AND I WILL
CLOSE WITH THE- MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
A PRO PALCO AUTHORED SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WHICH RIGHTFULLY
BILLS OFF A BILL THAT ARE FLOOR
MANAGER PERCENT CISCO AUTHORED
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH
AUTOMATICALLY CORRECTS FOR
CHARGERS THE NEVER RESULTED IN
THE CONVICTION OF THOSE PERSONS
OR PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY
ARE TRYING TO REENTER SOCIETY.
FOR THOSE THAT CONCERN THAT
AUTOMATIC CONVICTION REGULARLY
WILL BE HASTILY. PROCESS FOR
THOSE MYSTERIES CONVICTION
RECORDS. I'LL ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. AT LEAST FOUR YEARS
FREE OF CRIMINAL CHARGES AND
ALL SERIOUS BIO AND SEXUAL
FELONIES ARE EXCLUDED FROM THIS
RELIEF. ADDITIONALLY THE
AUTHORS INCLUDED SAFE CARS ARE
A LOT OF COURT AND PROSECUTORS
TO OBJECT TO ANY RELIEF GRANTED
IN ORDER TO RETAIN FINAL
DECISION. LAST ECONOMIC AS
BRITTONIC BARRIERS TO HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
WHICH HAS COLLATERAL DAMAGE TO
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. LEADING
THE MULTI GENERATIONAL POVERTY.
THESE BARRIERS WITHIN THE CYCLE
OF POVERTY SEVERELY LIMITING
THE OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO
FUTURE GENERATIONS. TRAGICALLY
PEOPLE SHORT ON ALL
ALTERNATIVES. AND OFTEN CRUSHED
UNDER COURT- DEBT FREE WE
RETURNED TO JAIL OR PRISON.
NEARLY 75% OF FORMING CLOSER
INDIVIDUALS ARE STILL
UNEMPLOYED A YEAR AFTER
RELEASED. THE EFFECTS OF
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT VERY BY
RACE. AND AFTERMARKETS ARE MOST
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. SB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE IS A SMARTER MORE
COMPASSIONATE APPROACHABLE
TOWARDS THOSE WITH PAST
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS OR TRYING
TO RECONSTRUCT THEIR LIVES AND
AVOID THE BARRIERS THAT TOO
OFTEN LEAVE BACK. TO JAIL OR
PRISON SPECT WE ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK KALRA. MS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AYE AYES
AYE RISES A CO AUTHOR IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB SEVEN THREE ONE
TODAY CALIFORNIANS WITH
CONVICTIONS FACE OVER FOUR
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED LAWS
THAT PLACE POST SENTENCE
COMPLETION RESTRICTIONS ON
THEIR LIVES THROUGH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS NEARLY 75% OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE STILL
UNEMPLOYED. A YEAR AFTER
RELEASE THE AFFECTS OF BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT VARY BY RACE BUT
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE THE MOST
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED EXPERTS IN
REENTRY OFTEN THIS BARRIERS TO
STABLE HOUSING IS AMONG THE
MOST DIFFICULT BARRIERS I WOULD
PEOPLE WITH CONVICTIONS THAT
THEY FACE STABLE HOUSING LIKE
EMPLOYMENT IS STRONGLY
CORRELATED. OUT WOULD REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND INCREASED
CAPACITY FOR PEOPLE WITH
CONVICTIONS TO BECOME
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
WE CONTINUE TO PUNISH
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME AND SHOULD HAVE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO RESTART
THEIR LIVES AND BE ABLE TO BE
THRIVING MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. AN AYE VOTE. THANK A
MYSTERY- MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION-
I HEARD A CONCERN THAT THIS
BILL MAY PREVENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FROM BEING ABLE TO
CONDUCT A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEES.
WE HAD DISCUSSIONS REGARDING
THE TEACHERS COMMISSION- AND-
WITH CITY REGARDING THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE- BIG CONTINUE
TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
INFORMATION THEY REGULARLY GET
FROM D. O. J. I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS FROM A NUMBER OF
OTHER COMMISSIONS AS WELL IN
THE- SENATOR HAS ABSOLUTELY
AGREED TO WORK WITH THEM TO
IRON OUT ANY PARTICULAR.
CLASSIFICATIONS OR THE
PARTICULAR ISSUES BUT IN MY
DISCUSSION WITH THE COMMISSION
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO GET THERE BUT
THEY'LL BE GETTING ANY LAST
INFORMATION OR THE CRITICAL
INFORMATION THEY'LL NEED. FOR
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS. MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. IT
DOESN'T CONCERNS- SO I WAS
PRESENT FOR GIRLS SOFTBALL THE
CANNELLA GROVE AND BECAUSE
ALWAYS YOU DEAL WITH KIDS YOU
GET THE DOJ RETURNS EVERYBODY'S
FINGERPRINTED AND WE HAD
SOMEONE IS GONNA BE TREASURER
HE HAD MULTIPLE CONVICTIONS FOR
EMBEZZLEMENT. OBVIOUS ARE YOU
NOT RELEASES CRIMINAL RECORD
BUT I MADE SURE THE PRESIDENT
OF MY OWN THAT HE DIDN'T. WAS
INVOLVED MONEY SO THAT WAS AN
ISSUE OF CONCERN. SO I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS IF THAT RIGHT
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THANK YOU IF
THAT RECORDS EXPUNGED IT'S BEEN
SAY SEVEN YEARS THE OWNER THE
BUSINESS OWNER BANK WOULDN'T
KNOW THAT I GUESS WHAT I'M
REALLY CONCERNED IS ON CHILD
ANNOYANCE ANY CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN OF MR METERS THERE
SEVERAL KINDS OF THE
MISDEMEANORS FILTER EXPLAINED
SO YOU CAN BE A SCHOOL EMPLOYER
BUS DRIVER YOU WANT TO HIRE
THAT PERSON SO JUST BECAUSE
EVERYTHING BUT A FELONY LOTS OF
MISDEMEANOR CHILD THINGS.
EMPLOYERS NEED TO KNOW WHO
THEY'RE HIRING AND I'M I'M ALL
FOR HEY IF YOU DID SOME OTHER
CRIMES ASSAULT INSULT BETTER
THINGS LIKE THAT SO I FOR
SECOND CHANCE BUT SOME OF THESE
THINGS I DON'T CARE WHO YOU ARE
IF SOMEONE'S DOING THINGS TO
CHILDREN YOU SHOULD NOT BE
ADVOCATING FOR THEM. OKAY I'M
NOT PULL MY HAND UP AND SAY
OKAY. YOU'RE DOING THIS SO YOU
DESERVE A BREAK. THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT SHOCKED THE
PUBLIC CONSCIENCE. AND WHEN IT
COMES TO KIDS. THAT'S A BIG
ONE. AND WE DON'T THINK ABOUT
THE INDECENT EXPOSURE. THAT
HAPPENS A LOT SOMEONE'S DOING
THAT. DO WHAT THEY WORK IN A
SCHOOL. SEWER DAYCARE CENTER
SO. I GUESS IT IT'S A SLUSH ME
SOMETIME WHEN WE WANT TO HELP
PEOPLE IN AND CHANGE THINGS.
BUT DAMMIT. WHY ADVOCATE FOR
SOMEONE LIKE THAT. THERE'S NO
REASON. TO KEEP THAT PERSON
THEY SHOULD GET A BREAK BECAUSE
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT. THE VAST
MAJORITY PUBLIC WILL NEVER DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT EVER. EVER
NEVER TOUCH A KID NEVER DO THAT
LIEU THAT BOTTOM LINE IN THERE
ARE PEOPLE LIKE THAT'S BEEN
THIRTY YEARS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO I WOULD CHALLENGE ANYONE HAS
EVER SEEN THAT. PARTICULAR
REPORT FROM SOMEONE FROM A
VICTIM A KID THIS HAS HAPPENED
TO THE WAY HOME WALKING HOME.
THAT'S NOT DAILY BASIS OR
SOMEONE DOES CRAZY STUFF LIKE
THAT. SO LIKE I SAID. I'M NOT
ADVOCATING FORM AND THEY SHOULD
NOT GET A BREAK. FOR A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS OF COURSE BUT FOR
SOME REASON WE ALWAYS WANT TO.
LET EVERYBODY IN THERE. AND IF
YOUR SEX OFFENDER. OF SOME SORT.
YOU SHOULD NOT GET A BREAK
BECAUSE NINETY NINE POINT 9%
THE PUBLIC WILL NEVER EVER DO
THAT. SO I CAN WHEN I SEE
PEOPLE STAND UP AND ADVOCATE
FORM. INTO A GREAT IS NOT YOUR
BILL. BUT THE TAX SAID THERE'S
REALLY NO GOOD REASON WE MAKE
OURSELVES. LOOK SILLY IN THE
PUBLIC AND YOU ASK THEM OUT
THERE LIKE THAT THAT WE BELIEVE
IN SECOND CHANCES REDEMPTION.
BUT NOT FOR THESE PEOPLE. SO
LIKE I SAID. ON THE MISDEMEANOR
STUFF. THERE'S A LOT OF
MISDEMEANORS OTHER CRIMES ARE
CONSIDERED SERIOUS CRIMES OR
VIOLENT CRIMES. THERE'S ABOUT
SIXTEEN CRIMES I MEAN YOU KNOW
I MEAN GONE INTO THAT YET. SO
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS THAT
CRIMES ARE TREATED VIOLENT. IT
IS LENGTHY LIST SO THERE'S A
LOT INVOLVED A LOT OF PARTS SO.
I SAID I SUPPORT IT BUT LIKE I
SAID. FOR SOME THESE FOLKS WE
SHOULD BE ADVOCATING FOR. THANK
YOU MISS COOPER. MISTER BRIAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MRS BIGGER AND TIMINGS MISTER
BRIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
TAKING A MAJOR US THOSE
QUESTIONS IN YOUR CLOTHES IF
YOU WILL MISTER BRIAN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU. WHY
ADVOCATE FORM WHY HIRE THEM.
WHY GIVE THEM A PLACE TO LIVE
WHY FREEDOM WATCH BELOW THEM
WHY DON'T WE JUST INCARCERATE
THEM FOREVER. THAT'S WHAT I'M
HERE ON THE FLOOR AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING WE
KEEP THESE CONVENTIONS OVER
PEOPLE IT'S EITHER A HUNDRED
YEARS OLD THEY CAN'T GET
HOUSES. THEY CAN'T GET
EMPLOYMENT. THEY STRUGGLE TO
BECOME ON HEALTH. INDECENT
EXPOSURE IN THE BILL FROM HERE
ON THE SIDEWALK BECAUSE YOU
HAVE NO PLACE TO LIVE. SIX
CRIMES VIOLENT CRIMES ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THE SUNSET BILL
THE THOUGHTFUL BILL BUILT ON
THE BANDOBAST THINKING IT BUILT
ON THE IDEA THAT EIGHT MILLION
PEOPLE DON'T RECIDIVISTS WHEN
THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITY. AND THIS
IS A STATE WE PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY WE'VE GOT A LONG
YEAR WHICH WAS THE IN THE
SESSION LET'S NOT GO BACKWARDS
RIGHT AT THE FINISH LINE.
MISTER MESS YOUR READINESS. I
WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING ON
THIS ITEM- THIS EVENING BUT
JUST HEARING SOME OF THE DEBATE
TONIGHT IN FACT I TOLD AUTHOR
AS I SHE HAD ASKED ME WHETHER I
WAS GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
OR NOT AND I SAID I WAS GONNA
LISTEN TO THE DEBATE- TONIGHT
BUT AFTER LISTEN TO THE DEBATE
I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BILL-
THIS EVENING. I'LL TELL YA. OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE JUSTICE SYSTEM
HAS ISSUES WE ALL KNOW THAT IT
DOES WE KNOW THAT IT DOES AND
SOME OF THE STUFF IS BROUGHT
BEFORE US I THINK WE GO A
LITTLE BIT TOO FAR. BUT IF WE
FORGOTTEN IF WE FORGOTTEN ABOUT
THE SIMPLE CONCEPT OF
REDEMPTION. ABOUT REDEMPTION.
IT PEOPLE CAN DO BAD THINGS.
BUT MAKE THEMSELVES WHOLE AGAIN
IF WE DISPOSE OF FOLKS LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM L. A. HAD SAID.
WE'VE LOST OUR WAY AND WE'VE
WHAT WE'VE DONE WE SAID THE
POLITICS ARE TOO TOUGH. THE
POLITICS ARE TOO TOUGH I VOTE
FOR THIS. IT COULD HURT ME MY
NEXT REELECTION. AS IF YOUR RE
PEOPLE. I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN REDEMPTION. WEBER
CITY LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN A
BAY PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES AT THIS TIME MISTER
FLORA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. ONE
TALK ABOUT REDEMPTION. I DON'T
WANNA TALK ABOUT REDEMPTION IS
A FATHER OF TWO LITTLE GIRLS.
IF SOMEBODY TOUCHES THEM
SOMEBODY DOES SOMETHING BAD TO
THEM. I BELIEVE IN SECOND
CHANCES. WE HAVE A COURT ROOM
TO DEAL WITH THAT THESE ARE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE DONE THINGS TO
KIDS. BETTER CONSIDERED NON
VIOLENT. DO NOT FORGET THAT.
AGAIN MEMBERS PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MAC FUNDS AT THIS TIME IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE BAIT
MR ONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I DON'T HAVE
ANY PLAN AND SPEAK ON THIS
EITHER. IF YOU WANNA TALK
REDEMPTION I'M GONNA HAVE TO
SAY I'M A MOTHER OF TWO
ELEMENTARY BOYS. TEN AND EIGHT.
I WOULD DO ANYTHING I CAN TO
PROTECT MY TWO CHILDREN AND WE
ALL HERE. I HAVE NO PROBLEM WAS
GIVING PEOPLE A SECOND CHANCE.%
BUT YES THE CORWOMEN'S WHERE
IT BELONGS. THEY NEED TO GO TO
THE COURT. FILED THE PETITION
IS NOT AUTOMATIC. ONE CHILD. IF
IT HAPPENS TO ONE CHILD. IT'S
MORE THAN ENOUGH. WE SAW THE
BILL NOBEL WHAT HAPPENED THIS
WEEK IN SACRAMENTO. TO A WOMAN.
SHE WAS ASSAULTED SEXUALLY HER
TWO DOGS WERE KILLED. AT HER
HOUSE BURNED DOWN. ONE MISTAKE
WE LOSE A LIFE. I'M NOT GOING
TO BE HERE. AND BE OKAY WITH
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
BE. THE ONE WHO HAVE TO SAY- I
VOTED FOR THAT AND THAT ONE
CHILD'S LIFE DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING SO I'M ASKING YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MR MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. LIKE IT'S
LATE THE END OF SESSION. WE'RE
ALL EMOTIONAL WAS A TOUGH WEEK
THAT WAS MY DISTRICT WHERE
SOMEONE WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED I
GET A- LOT OF US HAVE CHILDREN.
I HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS I'M A
SOFTBALL COACH. BUT THERE'S
FACTS AND THERE'S FICTION. THE
WHAT THE FACTS ARE WHAT THIS
BILL SAYS AND I WANT TO ASK A
SIMPLE QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
FOR THE FLOOR JOCKEY WITHOUT
OBJECTION MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFUSION ON WHAT THIS BILL
DOES AND DOESN'T DO. IF
SOMEBODY IS. HOUSE IN THE
RECORD A SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
OFFENSE. OFFENSE AGAINST A
MINOR SXUAL CRIME WHAT THIS
PROVISION BE APPLICABLES NO
WE'RE NOT. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY.
MR LACKEY YOUR ADDRESS. I JUST
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE TEMPER OF THIS DISCUSSION.
WAS SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
OVERLOOKED AND FORGOTTEN.
ALMOST EVERY TIME WE TALK ABOUT.
REDEMPTION WE TALK ABOUT SECOND
CHANCES. SOMETHING THAT IS
COMPLETELY FORGOTTEN AS A
LIFETIME OF BEING A VICTIM. A
LIFETIME OF THE SCARS LEFT
BEHIND BECAUSE OF OTHERS
BEHAVIOR. A LOT OF THESE
CONVICTIONS WERE TALKING ABOUT
OUR PLEASE FOLKS WE'RE NOT
REALLY WHAT HAPPENED. THOSE ARE
FACTS. PLEASE CONSIDER THE
FACTS AND NOT JUST THE FICTION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. WE'LL SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE MR
TANG YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER LET ME LET ME
JUST BE CLEAR- SINCE THERE'S
BEEN. SOME SPECIFIC INSTANCES
FROM A NUMBER OF SPEAKERS THERE
IS NOTHING IN THIS BILL IN
TERMS OF SEX OFFENSES OR ANY
SEX CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN
THESE ARE NOT IN THIS BILL.
THEY ARE NOT IN THIS BILL.
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO ASSIST WITH THIS. TICKLER
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AGAIN THIS
ELIGIBILITY IS EXTENDED FOR
AUTOMATIC CONVICTION RECORD
RELIEF TO NON SERIOUS NON
SEXUAL NON VIOLENT FELONIES
THIS IS ONLY AFTER. AN
INDIVIDUAL COMPLETE ALL TERMS
OF INCARCERATION PROBATION
MANDATORY SUPERVISION POST
RELEASE SUPERVISION PAROLE AN
ADDITIONAL. FOUR YEARS WITHOUT
A NEW CONVICTION. SO IN THE END
OF THE CASE IS THAT YOU ALL
DESCRIBE ABSOLUTELY.
REPREHENSIBLE UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE DOING THE TO. AGAIN
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO. TWO
CATEGORIES PEOPLE WHO GOT
ARRESTED. AND NEVER GOT
CONVICTED AND THEN THE SPECIFIC
CONVICTION RECORD RELIEF THAT I
DESCRIBED BEFORE. THIS IS BILL
IS A SMALL STEP TO MOVE US IN
THE DIRECTION FOR ONCE PEOPLE
HAVE EITHER BEEN ARRESTED OR
CONVICTED THE ONCE THEY HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME THAT THEY GET
TO MOVE ON. WITH THEIR LIFE.
WITH ALL THIS BILL THIS. OR WE
CAN HAVE THE OTHER CHOICE.
WHERE THIS AIRPORT. THIS DAY
HOMELESS. THEY DON'T EVER GET
TO REENTER SOCIETY SO THAT'S
THE CHOICE THAT WE HAVE TODAY.
WITH THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US
RIVALED ON SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE.
FOR COLLATERAL. RESERVE THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MISTER TANK MOVES A CALL MS
RAYOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING MEASURES
FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. AB ELEVEN FORTY
ROBERT RIVAS EIGHTY SIX SEVEN
ZERO CALDERON AND AB TEN FIFTY
FIVE RAMOS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT REQUEST IS GRANTED. THIS
IS A B. ELEVEN FORTY MISTER
REAVIS. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FORTY
CORPORATE SYMBOL LEVIN FORTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND ACTUALLY IN THE FOSTER CARE
THIS RIVAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SO THIS LEGISLATION
WILL CLARIFY THAT THE OFFICE OF
THE STATE'S ABOUT PERSON FOR
FOSTER CARE CAN AND SHOULD. UP
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND SERVICES
TO UNACCOMPANIED IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN FEDERAL
CUSTODY AND PLACED IN
CALIFORNIA STATE LICENSED CHILD
CARE SETTINGS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION OR A
SINGLE NO VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.%
DAVIS RIVAS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. VOTERS ARE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE
TELL YOU ABOUT I. SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. AB SIX
SEVENTY. FIVE MINUTES CALLED
AROUND AB SIX SEVENTY CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE SIX SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
ACCORDING TO CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT MISTER CALDERON. THANK
YOU MISTR SPEAKER AB SIX
SEVENTY IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
OF SENATE AMENDMENTS WHICH
SIMPLY PROVIDE DOUBLE JOINING
LANGUAGE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DAVIS CALDERON C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE.
RESERVE THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
HIGHS SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. AND
THIS IS MISTER RAMOS A. B. TEN
FIFTY FIVE WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY
FIVE SEPARATE. SINGLETON FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
AND I PUT IN A FOSTER YOUTH
MISTER ROSS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN FIVE
FIVE IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
SIDE ON CONCURRENCE WITH
AMENDMENTS AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
TECHNICAL CHANGES EXPANDS ON
THE PROGRAM TO ALL CHILDREN AND
AVOIDS CHAPTER IN ISSUES WITH
AB ONE THIRTY- THIS BILL.
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD AND
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK RESTAURANTS SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM CLICK LIBERAL. WHO IS OUT
OF A LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A- ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ESERVER.
WELL. CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE ENTERTAINING
VOTE CHANGES. IF NEED BE WE'RE
ENTERTAINING HER CHANGES AT
THIS TIME. C. NINE. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS THE CHANGE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
CHANGE PETRIE-NORRIS SB THREE
EIGHTY THREE I TO NOT VOTING-
CHANGES LET ME REPEAT YOU
NORRIS SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
ANY
OTHER CHANGES MEMBERS. WE HAVE
YEARBOOKS CIRCULATING THE SURE
SIGN THEIR BOOKS. STAY COOL
OVER THE BREAK. OKAY.
MS REYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THERE ARE SERIES
OF LETTERS OF INTENT AT THE
DESK THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
BOTH SIDES PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY TWO C. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO PRINT THE
LETTERS IN THE JOURNAL I WOULD
ASK THAT THE READING CLERK READ
THE LIST. NOW CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN RODRIGUEZ
SOME AGO NINE IT WOULD ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY SALAS ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SEVENTY NINE GALLAGHER
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY NINE
GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN SANTIAGO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY BURKE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH SEVEN
CORK ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR PENNANT SOME PEOPLE TEN
NINETY FOUR ARAMBULA ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE ALL ONE TEAM AND
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH SIX
MCCARTY. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
LETTERS WILL BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED
TO LIFT THE CALL.
NOT YET
PREPARED TO LET THE CALL
MEMBERS.
WEBER SEPARATE LIVE
THE CALL. ON SENATE BILL. SEVEN
THIRTY ONE. DORADO CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS HAD WHICH
TO VOTE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE.
AND ITALIAN VOTE. HIGHS THIRTY
FIVE KNOWS TWENTY SIX THAT
MEASURE FAILS MISTER CHANG
NOTICES RECONSIDERATION.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE
HAVE FINISHED WITH THE BUSINESS
FOR THE EVENING. MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT FOR
SOME IMPORTANT RECOGNITIONS AS
WE NEAR THE END OF OUR SESSION.
OUR CHIEF CLERK SUE PARKER IN
THE ASSEMBLY DEATH STAFF HAVE
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO PROCESS
THE BUSINESS WE HAVE COMPLETED
THE THREE. WE SIMPLY COULD NOT
HAVE COMPLETED THIS LEGISLATIVE
YEAR WITHOUT THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE. AND
THEIR HARD WORK. THEY SET A
NATIONAL STANDARD. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN FORMALLY THANKING OUR
ASSEMBLY CHIEF CLERK AND THE
DESK STAFF. ADDITIONALLY OUR
CHIEF SERGEANT ALYSSA BUCKLEY
IN OUR ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS HAVE
BEEN BY OUR SIDE MORNING AND
NIGHT FACILITATED THE
OPERATIONS OF OUR FLOOR
SESSIONS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THANKING OUR ASSEMBLY CHIEF
SERGEANT AND THE REST OF OUR
ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS FOR THEIR
OUTSTANDING SERVICE. THIS WEEK
AND EVERY WEEK. ALL THROUGHOUT
THIS PAST YEAR AS THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS PERSISTED
IN THE ASSEMBLY IS CONTINUE TO
ADAPT TO THAT REALITY. OUR CORE
STAFF AND SERGEANTS HAVE BEEN
UNDAUNTED IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT US. ON A PERSONAL NOTE
A BIG THANK YOU TO OUR FLOOR
TEAM STAFF IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
WORK ESPECIALLY THIS WEEK BUT
EVERY WEEK. THIS SESSION THANK
YOU ALL IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU TO OUR FLOOR
TEAM OF COURSE AND THANK YOU
ACROSS THE AISLE TO MISS
WALDRON AYE MR FLORA. FOR YOUR
COOPERATION AND MATTERS. AND
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
IT'S BEEN A INTERESTING HERE
FOR SURE- AND BUT WE MADE IT
THROUGH I WANNA JUST A
KNOWLEDGE A FEW PEOPLE ON OUR
TEAM THAT HAVE MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE FOR US ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE- ARE FLOOR TEAM
OF COURSE HEADED UP BY HE FLOOR
WHO WORKS ALL WEEKEND AND ALL
THE TIME SO. A LOT OF WORK
BEHIND THE SCENES. AND OF
COURSE OUR AMAZING WHIP TEAM-
WITH DEVON MATHIS LAURIE DAVIES
AND PHILLIP CHEN I WANT TO
THANK THEM AS WELL FOR THEIR
HARD WORK. WE HAVE OUR POLICY
TEAM HEADED UP BY A POLICY
DIRECTOR SUSAN SUTTON THEN THE
BACK ALONG WITH JOHN AGAIN. AND
OF COURSE BECAUSE THE BUDGET
HAS GONE ON ALL YEAR LONG I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE VERY
HARD WORK OVER VICE CHAIR VINCE
FONG. AS WELL AS OUR FISCAL
DIRECTOR JOCHEN STOCK ON OUR
WHOLE POLICY TEAM WHO WORK OVER
THE L. R. B. L. O. B. THANK YOU.
IT MEMBERS THEY ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE WEEK DOLLARS THE
SPECIAL SERVICES STAFF AS WELL
FOR THEIR GREAT. DAN IS RADIUS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I DO
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU YOU'VE
WORKED SO HARD EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF YOU TO MAKE THIS A
SUCCESSFUL END OF SESSION.
ALMOST NINE SO YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO LEAVE HERE BY NINE O'CLOCK
THAT IS HISTORICAL. THAT IS
HISTORICAL. I WITH THEM ATTHE
BACK TO DO ALL THE WORK DOUBLY
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SO
WE STAY SAFE AND THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE ALL HERE- THE MAST
VACCINATED I SINCERELY THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK OUR CHIEF CLERK SUPARCO
HER FOR ALL HER HARD WORK OH MY
GOODNESS. YOU IN ALL YOUR TEAM
THANK YOU. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
OUR CHIEF SERGEANT LISA BUCKLEY
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO YOU THE
SERGEANTS NOW FOR ALL THEY GIVE
DANTE PROTECT US. SOME OF US
HAD NEEDED TO HAVE NEEDED MORE
PROTECTION THAN OTHERS. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKERS
FLOOR TEAM AND MOST ESPECIALLY.
BRIAN BRANDON AND RENEE. MY
WORD. AMAZING AMAZING WORK. IN
MY ROLE FROM THE SPEAKERS TEAM
AS WELL. THEY DON'T JUST WORK
HERE WHILE WE'RE ALL HERE THEY
ARE WORKING INTO THE WEE HOURS
OF THE NIGHT ESPECIALLY AT THE
END OF SESSION AND VERY EARLY
IN THE MORNING. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE ASSISTANT MAJORITY
LEADER MR ED CHAU. I'D LIKE TO
THANK OUR MAJORITY WHIP CHRIS
WARD AND THE SYSTEM MAJORITY
WITH ISAAC BRYAN. AND ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE MY CHAIR MISTER
MIKE GIPSON. AND ALTHOUGH HE
ISN'T HERE NOW HE HAS LET US
EVERY MORNING YEAH AND A PRAYER
THAT IS IMAM MUHAMMAD YASIR
KHAN. AND MAY I PLEASE THANK.
MY CHIEF OF STAFF AND MY LEGS
DIRECTOR MARK DIRECTOR MARK
FAROUK AND MELISSA CLOSE YOU.
AND NOW FOR THE MOST IMPORTANT
PERSON QUITE FRANKLY HERE ON
OUR FLOOR. OUR LEADER OUR
FRIENDS BUT OUR BROTHER PART OF
OUR FAMILY THIS IS A BIG FAMILY.
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON. I WANT
TO THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS FOR THE SACRIFICES THAT
YOU MADE TO BE HERE WITH US TO
HELP US ON THOSE DIFFICULT
VOTES NOT ONLY FOR OUR HOUSE
BUT FOR THE SENATORS WHO
BROUGHT THEIR BILLS HERE YOU'VE
MADE A DIFFERENCE I WOULD BEEN
ABLE TO PASS SOME AMAZING
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND MISTER SPEAKER THEY ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'VE BEEN HERE
NINE YEARS. FOR NINE YEARS.
EVERYBODY HAS SAID- WE'RE GONNA
GET OUT BEFORE MIDNIGHT ON THE
LAST DAY AND- LOOK WE DID IT-
AND WHEN WE LEAVE HERE TODAY WE
SHOULD LEAVE WITH OUR HEADS
HELD HIGH WE DID SOME AMAZING
WORK THIS YEAR. WE ACCOMPLISHED
SOME INCREDIBLE THINGS SOME
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILLS.
LAST YEAR WAS AN INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT YEAR FOR THOSE OF YOU
HURRY YOU ARE HERE WE MISSED
NINE WORK NINE WEEKS OF WORK
LAST YEAR. THIS YEAR WE- FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO OUR JOBS UNDER
THE MOST TRYING CONDITIONS
IMAGINABLE. AND WE RE
ESTABLISHED OUR PROPER ROLE ARE
PROPER OVERSIGHT FUNCTION ARE
PROPER LEGISLATIVE FUNCTION.
AND THIS HOUSE THE MEMBERS THE
EIGHTY MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I THINK IN
PARTICULAR OUR STATE BUDGET I
THINK IS THIS IS THE GREATEST
BUDGET IN THE HISTORY OF THE
STATE OUR BUDGET CHAIR IT NEEDS
TO BE THANKS FOR THAT THANK YOU
MISTER. LEGISLATIVELY WE WORK
TO STRENGTHEN THE- THE
FOUNDATION FOR THE STATE BUT
INTERNALLY WE VERY MUCH I THINK
HELP TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR OUR
OWN INTERNAL FOUNDATION. HAS
BEEN STRENGTHENED. WE CONTINUED
OUR EFFORTS TO GUARANTEE EQUITY
AND PARITY FOR THOSE WHO WORK
IN THE ASSEMBLY REGARDLESS OF
GENDER RACE OR ETHNICITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. GENDER EXPRESSION
OR DISABILITY WE WILL CONTINUE
THOSE EFFORTS. AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR I TALKED ABOUT
DECERTIFICATION WE GOT THAT
DONE I TALKED ABOUT BROADBAND
ACCESS WE GOT THAT DONE- WE ARE
HAVE. A TREMENDOUS. TREMENDOUS
STRIDES. TOWARD TOWARD
ACHIEVING THOSE GOALS THE SAME
TIME WE KNOW WE HAVE MORE TO DO
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE COMING
BACK NEXT YEAR THE SECOND
SECOND OF A TWO YEAR PERIOD SO
WANT TO THANK YOU IN ADVANCE
FOR THE WORK YOU'RE GOING TO DO
NEXT YEAR AS WELL- LOGISTICALLY
OF COURSE WE DEPEND ON OUR
CHIEF CLERK SUE PARKER AND HER
STAFF THANK YOU. TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE PROCEEDINGS ARE RUNNING
SMOOTHLY WE HAVE THE BEST IN
THE GAME KEVIN MULLIN THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. ASSISTANCE
SPEAKER PRO TEM REBEKAH AMERICA
HAD THANK YOU. WE HAD A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE ON OUR FLOOR
TEAM WO ARE DOING THIS FOR THE
FIRST TIME A BUNCH OF FOLKS
WORKING ON THE FOURTEEN FOR THE
FIRST TIME- MY RIGHT HAND
ELOISE REYES THANK YOU SO MUCH
HOURS. STALWART EFFORT AS OUR
MAJORITY LEADER- WE HAD. HARD
WORK PERSISTENT MAJORITY LEADER
AT CHAO. THANK YOU ED AND THEN
OUR MAJORITY WHIP CHRIS WARD
THANK YOU CHRIS. ZAP THERE
WITHIN VOTES FOR NEXT YEAR SO
MORE AND OUR SYSTEM MAJORITY
WHIP I SURPRISED THANK YOU
ISAAC. IT IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE
SEEN A BIT OF THE COMPLETE LACK
OF RESPECT FOR STATE HOUSES- IN
PLACES LIKE WASHINGTON IN
PLACES LIKE MICHIGAN- WE ARE
SAFE HERE IN OUR HOUSE AND THIS
HOUSE IS RESPECTED BECAUSE OF
THE EFFORTS OF OUR CHIEF
SERGEANT. ALYSSA BUCKLING AND
HER STAFF THANK YOU. OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM MUHAMMAD
YASIR KHAN HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE INSPIRATION TO ALL
OF US THANK YOU. AT A TIME OF
INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE
WORKPLACE- CHALLENGES OUR CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER DEBRA
GRAVERT AND HER STAFF HAVE GONE
OUT OF THEIR WAY TO. DAY TO DAY.
ON BOTH THE POLICY AND
LOGISTICS FRONT I HAVE TO THANK
THE STAFF WHO WORKS FOR ME-
UNDER UNDER THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE LED BY MY CHIEF OF STAFF
CARRY CORN WELL THANK YOU CAN.
I'M THE ONE. WITH THE
MICROPHONE SO WHEN I THINK
KERRY I THINK CHARACTERS MY
MICROPHONES UP BUT I'M I KNOW
THAT ALL OF YOU. ALL EIGHTY IF
YOU WANT TO TAKE YOUR STAFF
YOUR CHIEFS BOTH YOUR YOUR
CAPITAL STAFF AS WELL AS YOUR
DISTRICT STAFF AS WELL SO. AND
AS LONG AS WE'RE- AS LONG AS I
HAVE THE MICROPHONE UP AND I'M
THINKING PEOPLE MY WIFE AND
DAUGHTER HERE. AND YEAH. OUR
LADY OF THE SACRIFICE A LOT WE
SACRIFICED A LOT TO BE HERE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THIS WORK
IS IMPORTANT WE KNOW THE WORK
IS IMPORTANT BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE DON'T SACRIFICE WE
SPEND. A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME ALL OF US AWAY FROM OUR
FAMILY SO IN EFFECT MY LIFE AND
I THINK MY DAUGHTER I'M
THINKING YOU'RE FAMILIES ON
BEHALF OF YOU AS WELL- SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO. IN
THE FALL AND IN THE WINTER AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA COME BACK IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DON'T COME
HERE COME ACROSS THE STREET.
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN OUR NEW
OFFICES I'LL SEE YOU NEXT YEAR
THANK YOU. MEMBERS I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE- MEMBERS ELEVATOR IS
NOW WORKING. JUST IN TIME MS
RADIUS MS RADIANCE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO THE
PROVISIONS OF JOINT RULE FIFTY
ONE I MOVE THAT THE ASSEMBLY DO
NOW ADJOURN FOR THE INTERIM
STUDY RECESSED TO RECONVENE ON
MONDAY JANUARY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND CONSENT FOR THE
SENATE TO DO THE SAME. DO WE
HAVE A SECOND. MISTER FLORA
SECONDS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO THE MOTION SEEING AND
HEARING ON THE MOTION CARRIES
ASSEMBLY WILL NOW JR FOR THE
INTERIM STUDY RECESS UNTIL
MONDAY JANUARY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT ONE PM THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.